NINE OKAY GREAT- ALL RIGHT WELL
THE- LET US PROCEED WELCOME TO
THIS HEARING OF THE ASSEMBLY
EDUCATION COMMITTEE. ON THE RE
OPENING OF CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
SCHOOLS FOR THE 202-021-2020
TWENTY ONE SCHOOL YEAR. I AM
CALLING- THIS HEARING TO ORDER.
I'D LIKE TO WELCOME ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE MEMBER CENTER LEYVA-
COLLEAGUES FROM THE SENATE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE AND THE
PUBLIC TO THIS HEARING ON A
VERY IMPORTANT TOPIC- TO OUR
CHILDREN TO THE FUTURE OF OUR
STATE TO OUR ECONOMY TO
PARENTS. TO JUST ABOUT
EVERYBODY THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
TOPIC IMPORTANT MAY I HAVE TWO
KIDS IN SCHOOL AND- I OFTEN
SEVEN THE FALLEN. SO THIS THIS
THIS IS- THESE DYNAMICS ARE
INTERESTING AND CHALLENGING
BOTH THE SAME TIME. WE'RE HERE
TODAY TO TALK ABOUT WHAT SCHOOL
WILL LOOK LIKE IN THE FALL
UNDER THE UNPRECEDENTED
CONSTRAINTS IMPOSED BY THE CODE
NINETEEN. EPIDEMIC. WE WILL
HEAR ABOUT THE MEASURE SCHOOLS
WILL NEED TO TAKE TO PROTECT
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
STUDENTS AND STAFF. WE'LL HEAR
ABOUT WHAT TEACHING. AND
LEARNING WILL LOOK LIKE OR
MIGHT LOOK LIKE BECAUSE THINGS
ARE VERY FLUID AND MAY CHANGE
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR. AND WE'LL
HEAR ABOUT THE SUPPORT SCHOOLS
WILL NEED TO PROVIDE TO
STUDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES IN
THIS MOST UNIQUE TIME IRAQ
CANNOT HIGHLIGHT ENOUGH THAT
THE SITUATION IS FLUID. AND MAY
CHANGE THROUGHOUT THE YEAR WE
MAY HAVE KIDS AT SCHOOL ONE
MONTH KIDS AT HOME ANOTHER
MONTH KID SPLITTING TIME.
ANOTHER MONTH WE JUST DON'T
KNOW AT THIS POINT SO BE
PREPARED FOR FLUID YOUR FOR
SURE. BUT LET'S START BY BEING
REAL AGAIN THIS IS NOT GOING TO
BE EASY WE ARE IN UNCHARTERED
TERRITORY. WITH MORE
UNCERTAINTY AHEAD. WHEN AND
WILL CONTINUE TO CONTINUE TO BE
A VERY DIFFICULT. AND
CHALLENGING TASK. AND AGAIN
IT'S GONNA BE DIFFERENT ACROSS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHAT
HAPPENS A MODOC COUNTY WAY UP
NORTH MAY BE VERY DIFFERENT
THAN WHAT HAPPENS AND LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN FACT ON ANY ONE DAY LOS
WILL HAVE A MILLION PEOPLE ON
THEIR SCHOOL SITES SO WHAT DOES
THAT MEAN TO THE CHILDREN
ATTENDING THE STAFF THERE AND
THEN ONCE THEY LEAVE THE
BORDERS OF THAT. THAT SCHOOL
SITE WELL THE ALL THE
INTERACTION THEY'RE GOING TO
INCUR AS FAR ASTRACING EXCEPT
ROOM. BUT THIS IS WHERE WE ARE
AND WE MUST BE FORWARD AND DO
OUR BEST MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIA
FAMILIES DEPEND ON OUR PUBLIC
SCHOOLS TO KEEP THEIR CHILDREN
SAFE. LEARNING AND GROWING AND
THAT IS OUR CHIEF MISSION. THE
JOB OF SCHOOLS NEXT YEAR WILL
TO BE STRIKE A BALANCE BETWEEN
PROTECTING PUBLIC HEALTH. AND
PROVIDING EDUCATION THE TO THE
KEY TO OUR TO OUR CHILDREN. TO
ACHIEVE THAT BALANCE SCHOOLS
WILL NEED TO USE A VARIETY OF
MODELS TO KEEP STUDENTS AND
STAFF PHYSICALLY DISTANT. MANY
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE PLANNING
HYBRID MODELS WAS STUDENTS
ATTENDING SOME DAYS IN PERSON
AND OTHER DAYS USING THE
DISTANCE LEARNING MODEL. FOR
EXAMPLE SOME SCHOOLS WILL OFFER
A MONDAY WEDNESDAY TUESDAY
THURS OR MONDAY WEDNESDAY AND
THEN A TUESDAY THURSDAY
SCHEDULE- FOR GROUPS OF
STUDENTS OF DIFFERENT GRADES.
OTHERS MAY ESTABLISH A WEEK ON
WEEK OFF SCHEDULE OR STAGGERED
HALF DAY SCHEDULES WE JUST
DON'T KNOW BUT AGAIN IT. SHOULD
REALLY BE UP TO THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT FOLLOWING- APPROPRIATE
PROTOCOLS TO DESIGN WHAT BEST
MEETS THE NEEDS OF THEIR
STUDENTS. WE SHOULDN'T. DR WHAT
EVERY SCHOOLS RESPONSE TO THIS
CRISIS SHOULD BE WE SHOULD JUST
SET PARAMETERS NOT SCHOOLS BE
CREATIVE. THE OTHERS AGAIN
MAYBE WE DON'T KNOW A MINUTE
SOME SCHOOLS MAKE ONLINE FOR A
WEEK OFF LINE FOR WEEKS I MAY
GO ONLINE SOME STUDENTS MAY BE
ONLINE SOME STUDENTS MAY NOT BE
ONLINE- I WOULD ENCOURAGE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO BE READY
TO PROVIDE ONLINE LEARNING A
CONTINUE THAT APPROACH. BECAUSE
THEY MAY WELL NEEDED SOME
SCHOOLS SOME STUDENTS MAY BE
VERY VULNERABLE ANDNEED TO
REMAIN ONLINE WHILE OTHERS CAN
COULD IN IT CAN ATTEND SCHOOL
EVERY DAY AGAIN WE JUST DON'T
KNOW. SCHOOLS WILL NEED TO WORK
WITH THEIR COMMUNITIES AND WE
KNOW THAT THERE IS A WIDE RANGE
OF OPINION AMONG PARENTS ABOUT
WHAT SCHOOL SHOULD LOOK LIKE
NEXT YEAR. I GOT A CALL FOR ONE
LAST NIGHT. ONLINE LEARNING
AGAIN WILL PROBABLY CONTINUE IN
SOME FORM FOR ALL STUDENTS. BUT
AGAIN CERTAIN GROUPS STUDENTS
BROUGHT GONNA HAVE TO GO TO USE
THE ONLINE. MODEL BECAUSE THEY
AGAIN HER FROM VULNERABLE
GROUPS MANY SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ARE HEARING FROM SOME PARENTS
THAT THEY DO NOT FEEL
COMFORTABLE SENDING THEIR
CHILDREN TO SCHOOL SO AGAIN
THAT ONLINE LEARNING APPROACH
MAY BE BEST FOR THEM. SCHOOLS
WILL NEED YOUR HAIR TO THE NEW
SAFETY PRECAUTIONS FOR MASS.
DID TO DISINFECTING TO
TEMPERATURE CHECKS AND
CRITICALLY THEY WILL HAVE TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO KEEP KIDS
LEARNING. UNDER ALL OF THE
CIRCUMSTANCES. AND AGAIN WHAT
HAPPENS IN VERY NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA MAY BE VERY
DIFFERENT WHAT HAPPENS IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. MANY OF
OUR- ESPECIALLY ALMOST AS
STUDENTS STRUGGLED WITH
DISTANCE LEARNING THIS SPRING
AND WILL ARRIVE AT SCHOOL. WAS
SIGNIFICANT ACADEMIC DEFICITS.
IT APPEARS THAT MANY STUDENTS
WILL HAVE TO CONTINUE WITH AT
LEAST PARTIAL DISTANCE LEARNING
NEXT YEAR. AND THEIR FEARS THAT
THESE STUDENTS. MAY HAVE
LEARNING DEFICITS DEFICITS THAT
CONTINUE. THAT COMPOUND. THERE
ARE MANY ISSUES FOR SCHOOLS TO
GRAPPLE WITH. BUT FUNDAMENTALLY
OUR QUESTION TODAY IS. HOW CAN
SCHOOLS KEEP STUDENTS HEALTHY.
LOOK THAT KEEP STUDENTS HEALTHY
LEARNING ENGAGE AND SUPPORTED
WHEN OUR SYSTEM IS IN FLUX.
MANY OF OUR FAMILIES ARE IN
CRISIS AND ARE FISCAL OUTLOOK
IS GRIM. OUR JOB AS I SEE IT IS
REALLY TO MAKE SURE THAT YES IT
KNOWLEDGE AT THIS IS A STORM
BUT IS OUR JOB TO MAKE SURE IT
IS NOT THE PERFECT STORM. BY
CONTROLLING OR ALTERING AS MANY
VARIABLES AS WE CAN. THERE ARE
MANY QUESTIONS TO EXPLORE TODAY
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
DISCUSSION AND I WOULD OFF OR-
SENATOR LEYVA MY COUNTERPART ON
THE SENATE SIDE SHE WANTED TO.
SAY A FEW WORDS. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE UP FIRST THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DAHLE FOR
INVITING THE SENATE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE TO PARTICIPATE IN
THIS VERY IMPORTANT HEARING.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO THINK
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TONY THURMOND. CD
STAFF AND ALL STAKEHOLDERS WHO
HAVE ENGAGED IN THIS DIFFICULT.
BUT THOUGHTFUL DISCUSSIONS OVER
THE PAST SEVERAL MONTHS TO HELP
PRODUCE THE GUIDANCE THAT WILL
SURELY BE DISCUSSED HERE TODAY.
MOST IMPORTANTLY WE NEED TO
GIVE A HUGE THANKS TO OUR
TEACHERS STUDENTS AND PARENTS.
FOR THEIR INCREDIBLE EFFORT AND
FLEXIBILITY SINCE IS
UNPRECEDENTED CRISIS BEGAN. AS
A YEAR STARTED THAN OF US WOULD
HAVE THOUGHT THAT WE HEAR
TODAY. BUT HERE WE ARE AND IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE RECOGNIZE
EVERYONE'S HARD WORK. IN MANY
WAYS THE REAL WORK IS JST
BEGINNING AS WE STRIVE TO OPEN
OUR SCHOOLS AND THE SAFEST WAY
POSSIBLE. IT NEED FOR ELLIE A
TO. THEIR THROUGH THE END OF
THE SCHOOL YEAR IS OVER I'M
SURE THEY'RE VERY HAPPY ABOUT
THAT. AND NOW AS MANY OF
ALREADY BEEN DOING FOR SOMETIME
ELOISE MUST THOUGHTFULLY AND
CREATIVELY PLAN FOR THE NEW
REALITY WE FACE GOING INTO THE
NEW SCHOOL YEAR. IT IS CLEAR
CALIFORNIA'S SCHOOLS WILL LOOK
AND FEEL DIFFERENT. SCHEDULES
WILL LIKELY BE DIFFERENT FOR
MANY AND THE BARRIERS TO
STUDENTS OF COLOR FACE. WILL BE
WORSENED WITHOUT ACTION BUT
THROUGH PARTNERSHIP CAREFUL
PLANNING AND PRACTICING AND A
LITTLE PATIENCE. I'M CONFIDENT
THE ELLIE IS CAN PROVIDE
ESSENTIAL STANDARDS BASED
EDUCATION TO ALL OF OUR
STUDENTS IN A SAFE AND HEALTHY
MANNER. IT HAPPENED SAID
BEFORE. THIS GREAT OPPORTUNITY.
IT WOULD BE A- TO TRY TO
RECREATE EXACTLY WHAT WE HAD
BEFORE COVERT NINETEEN. BECAUSE
WHAT WE HAVE IS NOT PERFECT. IT
USES CHALLENGING UP. THINK
ABOUT HOW WE PROVIDE EDUCATE.
BOTH IN THE SHORT TERM. TO
ACCOUNT FOR THE EFFECTS OF
COVERT NINETEEN BUT JUST AS
CRITICALLY IN THE LONG TERM TO
RECOGNIZE THAT NOT ALL THE
STRUCTURE THAT COVERT.
DISRUPTED WORKED EQUITABLY SO
AS WE CONTINUE TO CAREFULLY
PLAN FOR WHAT COMES NEXT LET'S
ALSO PLAN TOGETHER IN A WAY
THAT PLANS FOR EQUITY AND
ENSURES ACCESS OF A QUALITY
EDUCATION FOR ALL STUDENTS. I
AM PERSONALLY WORRIED ABOUT THE
LOSS OF LEARNING AND THE
POSSIBLE WIDENING OF THE
OPPORTUNITY GAP IN MY CAPACITY
AS CHAIR OF ST EDUCATION I'M
WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION AS CO CHAIR OF THE
CLOSING THE DIGITAL DIVIDE TASK
FORCE. APPROXIMATELY 20% OF
STUDENTS DO NOT HAVE ACCESS TO
EITHER A COMPUTER THE INTERNET
OR BOTH WHICH SHOCKING AND
TWENTY TWENTY. AS PART OF THE
TASK FORCE I AM EXCITED TO BE
WORKING WITH INTERNET SERVICE
PROVIDERS TO FIND A PATH TO
HOPEFULLY FINALLY CLOSE THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE FOR THE BENEFIT
OF OUR STUDENTS ONCE AND FOR
ALL. WE'RE ABOUT TO HEAR FROM
LOS ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT ABOUT THEIR EXTENSIVE
WORK TO CLOSE THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE UNFORTUNATELY THIS
HEARING CANNOT PROVIDE A FORM
TO EXPLORE ALL OF THE ISSUES
THAT NEED TO BE ADDRESSED. I
WOULD LIKE TO TAKE THIS OP TO
FROM A SMALL AMOUNT OF CA FOR
RURAL CA. MANY OF WHICH DO NOT
HAVE THE FOR STRUCTURE TO
SUPPORT INTERNET SERVICE.
DIGITAL DIVIDE NOT ONLY HELLO
OF. ALSO THE LAW OF A MANY
AREAS OF OUR STATE HOW CAN WE
EXPECT LA ELLIE FIVE IT
CURRENTS AND WERE OTHERS JUST
LEARN FOR THE IT IT SAYS. BUT
SHOULD BE THANKFUL HOW THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE STEW AND RURAL
AND YOU SUBURBAN AREA OF OUR
STAY AGAIN THINKING IT THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO PREPARE
PROTESTS TODAY. THANK YOU ARE
SENATOR LET I ANY OTHER MEMBERS
OF THE THERE'S THE SOME LIKE
EDUCATION MEMBERS OR ANYONE ONE
OF WHICH COMMON. KALRA I JUST
WANT TO THANK YOU MISS SURE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR FOR
CONTINUED EFFORTS TO MAKE SURE.
THE ADVICE FROM A LOT OF THE
EXPERTS ALL THESE PEOPLE FOR US
NUYS SIR. LOOKS TO HEARING FROM
THE SHIP AND AS ONE THANK YOU.
GREAT THANK YOU SO BE WE- MOVED
OUR FIRST SPEAKER I HAVE TO
READ A FEW NOTES ABOUT THE
LOGISTICS OF OUR HEARING TODAY.
IT'S NOT A TYPICAL HEARING- SO
LOGISTICS ARE A LITTLE
DIFFICULT WITH WITH FOLKS BEING
SPREAD ACROSS THE STATE.
BECAUSE YOU CANNOT BE PRESENT
IN THE ROOM. SO DUE TO THE STAY
AT HOME ORDER WE ARE CONTINUING
TO PRACTICE PHYSICAL DISTANCING
SO WE ARE ONLY ABLE TO HAVE A
LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE WATCH.
AND PARTICIPATE PURPOSE. IN
PERSON. WE HAVE A FEW DIFFERENT
OPTIONS FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
TODAY WHICH WILL OCCUR AFTER
OUR THIRD AND FINAL PANEL THE
BE THREE PANELS. HEY ARE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM IF ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK DURING THE PUBLIC
COMMENT PERIOD PLEASE RAISE
YOUR HAND I WILL ASK YOU TO
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE. AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. I WOULD ASK
THAT THE PUBLIC NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE IF YOU'RE IN THIS
ROOM. FOR MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
CALLING IN BY PHONE WE WILL
ALSO BE USING A MODERATED
TELEPHONE SERVICE WHICH I THINK
IS DOWN RIGHT NOW IS THAT
ACCURATE. IT WAS DOWN SO IF
IT'S NOT WORKING IT'S BECAUSE
IT'S DOWN OF ALL GIVE YOU THE
NUMBER AND IT MAY WORK- BUT BY
THE TIME WE GET TO THE TO
PUBLIC COMMENT MAY WORK. THE
CALLER NUMBER FOR THE HEARING
IT'S EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX
NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN.
AND THE ACT AS CODE IS. ONE
THREE ONE FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO
TWO AGAIN THE CALL IN NUMBER
FOR THIS HEARING IS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN IN THE ACCESS CODE
IS. ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR TWO
ZERO TWO YOU CAN ALSO FIND THIS
NUMBER IN THE ASSEMBLY
EDUCATION COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS
WELL AS ON YOUR SCREEN. IF
YOU'RE CALLING ON THE OPERATOR
WILL GIVE YOU INSTRUCTIONS HOW
TO BE PLACED IN THE QUEUE.
PLEASE BE SURE TO ELIMINATE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE IS A VERY
IMPORTANT ALL BACKGROUND NOISE
ONCE YOUR PLACE IN THE QUEUE.
YOU ALSO NEED TO MUTE YOURSELF
UNTIL YOUR CALLED MYSTERY MUTED
SO YOU YOUR CALL. IF YOU ARE
LEAVING IF YOU'RE HAVING ANY
PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATED
PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN CALL THE
COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE SIX.
THREE NINE TWO ZERO SEVEN OF MY
STAFF WILL BE THERE. TO HELP
YOU. I ALSO WANT TO KNOW THEY
WERE ACCEPTING WRITTEN COMMENT
THROUGH THE POSITION- LETTER
PORTAL ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE THIS THE ASSEMBLY
EDUCATION COMMITTEE IS WEBSITE
YOU CAN GO TO THAT WEBSITE IS A
PLACE FOR YOU TO SUBMIT
WRITTEN. WRITTEN COMMENTS. FOR
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC AT REMOTE
VIDEO STATIONS IS ASSEMBLY S.
ESTABLISHED TO VIDEO TESTIMONY
STATIONS AT WHICH PANELS WILL
TESTIFY. THE PUBLIC MAY ALSO
USE THE STATIONS FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THE END OF THE YEAR
TOWARDS THE END OF THE HEARING.
OKAY THE LOCATION OF THOSE
SUSPICIONS WHICH ARE N SAN
DIEGO IN PALO ALTO ARE LISTED
ON THE ASSEMBLY EDUCATION
WEBSITE. OF OUR PANELISTS ARE
PANELS WILL BE SPEAKING TODAY
AND ONE OF FOUR WAYS IN PERSON.
BY PHONE. THE WITNESS OF
CONFERENCING ROOM AND THE
REMOTE VIDEO TESTIMONY STATIONS
YOU ASKED KEEP YOUR TESTIMONY
TO FIVE MINUTES- IN PLEASE FIVE
MINUTES OR LESS BECAUSE WE WANT
TO GET ALL. WHO WHO ARE READY
TO PURCHASE. TODAY AT TO PER.
WE OTHER INFORMATION THE SO
AGAIN OF NO MORE THAN FOR
MINUTES AND WE FOLKS TO CALL IN
FOR PA COMMENT YOU'LL LIMITED.
TO MINUTE FOR PA CALM THANK YOU
FOR YOUR HEARING WITH US AS WE
IMPLEMENT THIS METHOD TO HOLD
PUBLIC. WHILE KEEPING THE
PUBLIC SAFE. WITH THAT SAID
LET'S START WITH OUR FIRST
SPEAKER AND THEN THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION. TONY THURMOND
WHO'S JOINING US BY REMOTE
VIDEO FROM THE LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT-
SUPERINTENDENT JANET THURMAN
YOU HAS AN INTRODUCTORY REMARKS.
ABOUT THREE OR. THANK YOU CHAIR
THE- THANK YOU CHAIR LEYVA TONY
THURMOND STAY SUPER UP AND
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. IF I WAS GOING TO
GIVE MY REMARKS THE TITLE THE
TITLE WOULD BE NO EASY CHOICES
LIKE MANY OF YOU I'VE WORKED IN
SCHOOLS FOR MANY YEARS FOR ONE
CAN ASKING. OUR STUDENTS TO
COME BACK TO AN ENVIRONMENT
WHERE THEY HAVE TO BE SPACED
OUT WITH SIX FEET OF DISTANCE
AND WEARING A FACIAL COVERING.
YOU WE KNOW THAT FALLS UNDER
THE BANNER OF NO EASY CHOICES.
BUT THE PANDEMIC. DOES NOT
DISCRIMINATE AGAINST THOSE THAT
MIGHT BE IMPACTED AND THIS IS
THE MOST SERIOUS OF MATTERS AND
SO EVEN THOUGH WE KNOW THAT IT
PROVIDES NO EASY CHOICES. THERE
ARE THREE THAT WE TO DO TO IT
HERE TO ENSURE A SAFE AND
THAT'S WHAT. OUR GUIDANCE
SPEAKS TO I WANT TO START BY
ACKNOWLEDGING THE RESILIENCY OF
OUR STUDENTS AND OUR STATE. AND
THEIR PARENTS AND OUR
EDUCATORS. THEY LITERALLY MOVED
INTO DISTANCE LEARNING
OVERNIGHT. WITH NO INSTRUCTION
ON HOW TO DO THAT AND WHILE
THERE ARE BUMPS I WANTED
KNOWLEDGE YOUR RESILIENCY IN
THE MANNER IN WHICH OUR
STUDENTS AND OUR EDUCATORS AND
OUR FAMILY MEMBERS. HAVE WORKED
HARD TO KEEP STUDENTS SAFE AND
LEARNING- THROUGH THIS
PANDEMIC. THIS PANDEMIC IS VERY
DANGEROUS- IT IS CLICK ALREADY
CHRONICLED UNDOCUMENTED THE
NUMBER OF LIVES THAT HAVE BEEN
LOST. I JUST WANT TO ADD
EMPHASIS TO WHAT WE ALREADY
KNOW. THAT AFRICAN AMERICANS
AND LATINOS IN PEOPLE WITH
UNDERLYING HEALTH CONDITIONS
FACE A HIGHER RISK OF
INFECTION. AND WE KNOW THAT
THIS HAS IMPLICATIONS FOR
STUDENTS. FOR THOSE REASONS
BECAUSE OF THESE HEALTH
DISPARITIES. THE GUIDANCE THAT
WE PROVIDED. PROVIDES THE
STRONGEST RECOMMENDATIONS ABOUT
HOW TO KEEP OUR STUDENTS AND
OUR EDUCATORS SAFE. WHILE
THEY'RE SUPPORTING OUR STUDENTS.
THEY'RE ASKING ALL OF OUR
STUDENTS AND STAFF TO WEAR A
FACIAL COVERING. RASKIN THAT
DEATH WILL BE SPACED OUT SIX
FEET APART. AND THAT EVEN ON
BUSES SIX FEET A SPACING IS
WHAT WE ARE RECOMMENDING. WE
KNOW THAT THESE ARE DIFFICULT
RECOMMENDATIONS TO IMPLEMENT.
AND SO WE'RE HAVING THOSE SAME
CONVERSATIONS. WITH MANY OF OUR
SCHOOL DIFFERENT PARTNERS ABOUT
HOW THESE WOULD BE IMPLEMENTED.
WE KNOW THAT THIS IS HARD BUT
AGAIN WERE PROVIDED WITH NO
EASY CHOICES AS SENATOR LEYVA
POINTED OUT THIS PANDEMIC HAS
TAUGHT US A VERY EMBARRASSING.
SECRET ABOUT CALIFORNIA'S
STUDENTS. THAT IN IN IN A STATE
THAT HAS THEMOST ACCESS TO
TECHNOLOGY. MORE THAN A MILLION
STUDENTS IN OUR STATE. WENT
WITHOUT THE INTERNET BECAUSE
WE'VE HAD A DIGITAL DIVIDE FOR
DECADES. WE'VE GOT TO RESPOND
TO THE TECHNOLOGY NEEDS OF OUR
STUDENTS DURING THIS PANDEMIC.
AND DO SO IN A WAY THAT HELPS
US TO OLD MOVIE CLOSE AT DIVIDE
NO DEVICE. BITES OF CAN REPLACE
WHAT A GREAT TEACHER DOES. BUT
A DEVICE IS A TOOL TO KEEP AN
EDUCATOR IN THEIR STUDENTS
CONNECTED AND IT HELPS IN THE
PROCESS. WE KNOW THAT DURING
DISTANCE LEARNING OUR STUDENTS
EXPERIENCE DEPRESSION. IT'S
JUST. IN WE THAT IN THE LAST
SEASON WEEKS OUR STUDENTS ARE.
EGGS OF. DIFFICULT AND HARD TO
WATCH POLICE BRUTALITY THAT
PLAYED OUT IN TERMS OF RACE.
AND BIAS. WE KNOW THAT. THIS IS
WHAT OUR STUDENTS WILL BE
COMING BACK TO SCHOOL WEARING A
FACIAL COVERING. AND DEALING
WITH THE TRAUMA THEY HAVE
EXPERIENCED IN THEIR WORLD
AGAIN. NO EASY CHOICES. BUT
THIS IS AN EQUITY ISSUE AS THE
CHAIR HASPOINTED OUT. MANY OF
OUR STUDENTS LIVE IN HOUSEHOLDS
WITH THEIR PARENTS HAVE TO
WORK. AND FOR THOSE WHO HAVE IT
THEY MUST GO BACK TO WORK. AND
SO WE MUST CREATE SAFETY FOR
ALL OF OUR STUDENTS A SPECIAL.
SINCE FROM OF HOUSEHOLDS IN
ROLE TO. AND STUDENTS OF COLOR
WHO MAY NOT A CHOICE. BUT TO
RETURN WE DO KNOW THAT SOME
FAMILIES WILL FOCUS ON DISTANCE
LEARNING. BUT WE KNOW THAT THE
MAJORITY OF OUR FAMILIES THAT
HAVE BEEN SURVEYED HAVE
INDICATED THE NEED FOR. CLASS
INSTRUCTION AND SO RIGHT IT'S
PROVIDES REPUTATION. ABOVE THAT
HAD A THAT SAFELY. I DON'T IS
BASED ON SOME. WE'VE ALWAYS HAD
IFSCHOOL BE OPEN IT'S GOT TO
BE. ON IT SCIENCE. WHAT WE KNOW.
KNOW WHAT WE KNOW COMES FROM
THE CDT. AND SEE P. H. HELLO.
AND IT WARMED AND ARE COUNTY
OFFICERS AND IT. WITH OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS LITERALLY HELP
IN THE MEASURE. SQUARE FOOTAGE
TO DETERMINE HOW MANY STUDENTS
THEY CAN SERVE IN THEIR CLASSES.
AND WHAT THEY'RE OVER. MORE
THAN THIRTY WEBINARS SINCE
MARCH THIRTEENTH TO TALK ABOUT
HOW TO PROVIDE DISTANCE
LEARNING HOW TO SUPPORT
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES HOW
TO SUPPORT OUR ENGLISH LEARNERS.
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO MORE THAN
SEVENTY THOUSAND STUDENTS
IMMEDIATELY GET ACCESS TO A
COMPUTER ANOTHER HUNDRED
THOUSAND GET ACCESS TO A HOT
SPOT. MANY STUDENTS WITH A TASK
FORCE AND I'M GRATEFUL TO THE
CHAIRPERSON SHIP WITH SENATOR
LEYVA. HAD BEEN ABLE TO RECEIVE
FREE INTERNET REDUCE COSTS
INTERNET BUT WE KNOW THAT THERE
ARE MANY STUDENTS WHO STILL
CANNOT ACCESS IT. DUE TO
INFRASTRUCTURE BARRIERS THAT
EXIST IN OUR STATE AND SO WE'RE
LOOKING TO OUR STATE LEADERS
AND TO OUR FEDERAL LEADERS TO
PROVIDE US WITH THE RESOURCES
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN
ACHIEVE. THESE BARRIERS.
GRATEFUL TO THE WORK OF THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND OTHERS TO
ENSURE THAT OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WOULD HAVE A STARTING
AMOUNT OF PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT. FACIAL COVER.
SHIELDS HANDS. AND OTHERS HAVE
BEEN DELIVERED TO THE COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION THROUGHOUT
OUR STATE. TO HELP OUR SCHOOLS
OPEN WITH PP. WE CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH OUR COUNSELING GROUPS
ON HADDOCK HELP CLOSE THE GAPS.
THAT MANY HAVE EXPERIENCE AND
WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THEM TO ADDRESS TRAUMA. WE
INVITE YOU TO TUNE IN ON
THURSDAY WHEN WE HOLD A VIRTUAL
SUPPORT CIRCLE FOR OUR
STUDENTS. TO TALK ABOUT TRAUMA
AND THE TRUMP OF THE
EXPERIENCES THAT WITNESSED
POLICE TALLY AND ACTS OF
RACISM. THAT HAVE OCCURRED IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES AND WE'RE
ASKING CHALCIS THROUGHOUT OUR
STATE. WAS PROVIDE FOR THE
MOTION NEEDS OF OUR STUDENTS WE
PUT IT IN THESE CONTEXTS WE
MUST ADDRESS THEIR SAFETY. YOU
MUST ADDRESS THE EMOTIONAL
NEEDS OF OUR- WE- AT GAPS. I
HAVE EXIST WE KNOW THAT. WE
KNOW WHAT'S GOING AS TEACHERS
WITH HAVE ALWAYS DONE. STUDENT
ENTER AND HELP THEIR STUDENTS
IF THEY NEED A DAY SO. TO GET
ON GRAY LEVEL AND WE KNOW THAT
THE BE PART YOU CAN BE AND IN
OTHERS. TO AID IN THAT EFFORT
AND SO. WHILE THERE ARE NO EASY
CHOICES WE DO NOT HAVE THE
CHOICE TO AVOID OR INVADE WHAT
IS IN FRONT OF US. WE HAVE TO
MOVE FORWARD TOGETHER WE HAVE
TO COME UP WITH ANSWERS
TOGETHER. WE'RE STRONGER
TOGETHER AND TOGETHER WE CAN
ANSWER THIS QUESTION WHICH IS
PROBABLY THE BIGGEST CHALLENGE
WILL FACE IN OUR LIFETIME AND
THAT'S HOW WE MOVE FORWARD. TO
SUPPORT THE NEEDS A SIX MILLION
STUDENTS IN OUR STATE. THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THAT THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS MAY
HAVE AT THIS TIME. I THANK YOU
MISTER THURMAN- LET'S MOVE TO
OUR FIRST PANEL WHICH WE
ADDRESSING THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY. OF STUDENTS AND STAFF
AND A REMINDER THAT WOULD BE
HOLDING QUESTIONS. FOR THE
PANELISTS IN TILL THE END. OF
THE PANEL OUR FIRST SPEAKER IS
DR GIL CHAVEZ FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH. DR
TRAVIS IS JOINING US FROM VIDEO
CONFERENCING ROOM HERE IN THE
CAPITAL. DR CHAVEZ YOU MAY
PROCEED WHEN READING. GOOD MR
TERM AND- OF THE COMMITTEE. I
AM DOCTOR CHAO. FOR CHIEF OF
THE CENTER EFFECT DISEASE.
RENTS ADVISER THAT YOU'RE OF
THE CAL DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY TODAY. I WOULD LIKE
TO BEGIN BY THANKING ALL THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA FOR THEIR
SUPPORT OF THE STATE WIDE OPEN
NINETEEN FUND EMIC RESPONSE BY
STAYING HOME IN FOLLOWING THE
EVIDENCE BASED GUIDELINES THAT
WE HAVE PROVIDE. AS A RESULT
CALIFORNIA MANAGED TO KEEP THE
NUMBER OF COLVIN NINETEEN CASES
AND DEATHS FAR BELOW. THE
NUMBER. THAT WE WOULD OTHERWISE
HAVE HAD. AS AN EXAMPLE WELL
CALIFORNIA HAS NEARLY 15% OF
THE US POPULATION. WE HAVE HAD
LESS THAN 5% OF THE DEATHS
NATIONWIDE. ADDITIONALLY WE
WERE VERY SUCCESSFUL IN
FLATTENING THE CURVE. HOWEVER
LET ME BE VERY CLEAR THAT THE
PANDEMIC IS FAR FROM OVER AND
WE CANNOT LET OUR GUARD DOWN.
THERE IS A LOT ABOUT THIS VIRUS
THAT WE DO NOT KNOW IF WE MUST
BE VIGILANT AND PROTECT
OURSELVES AND PROTECT EACH
OTHER. I HAVE BEEN ASKED TO
PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF THIS
SCHOOL AND SCHOOL BASED
GUIDANCE THAT THAT THE BARMAN
RELEASE WITH AN EFFECTIVE DATE.
OF JUNE TWELFTH TWENTY TWENTY.
THESE A GUIDANCE SEEKS TO
ASSIST LOCAL COMMUNITIES ARE
THEY CREATE PLANS TO REOPEN
SCHOOLS. AND PREPARED TO RESUME
IN PERSON INSTRUCTION. THROUGH
THE LENS OF PROTECT THE SAFETY.
ALSO THROUGH THEN WERE THE
SAFETY OF STOP AND SAFETY OF
THE COMMUNITY. THESE ARE THIS
INNER. THE SILENCE
CONSIDERATIONS BASED ON THE
AVAILABLE PUBLIC DATA AT THIS.
YOU AND NATIONAL BEST PRACTICES
SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE AND THE
PRACTICAL REALITIES OF MANAGING
SCHOOL OPERATIONS. AS NEW DATA
IN PRACTICE TO MERGE THE
GUIDANCE WILL BE UPDATED.
IMPLEMENTATION OF THESE
GUIDELINES WILL DEPEND ON LOCAL
PUBLIC HEALTH CONDITIONS.
COMMUNITIES MEETING FREE AGREED
UPON CRITERIA SUCH AS LOWER
INCIDENCE OF COMMON NINETEEN
CASES. STABLE HOSPITALIZATION
RATES THAN ADEQUATE
PREPAREDNESS MAY IMPLEMENTED
THE GUIDANCE DESCRIBED BELOW AS
PART OF A FACED RE OPENING. AS
A GOVERNOR NEWSOME HAS STATED
ON NUMEROUS OCCASIONS LOCALISM
IS THE TERMINATE THE-
INDICATING THAT THE ACTUAL
COVER NINETEEN RESPONSE
DECISIONS ARE TO BE MADE
LOCALLY. THEREFORE ALL
DECISIONS ABOUT FOLLOWING THESE
GUIDELINES SHOULD BE MADE IN
COLLABORATION WITH LOCAL HEALTH
OFFICIALS AND OTHER
AUTHORITIES. IMPLEMENTATION OF
THESE GUIDELINES SHOULD BE
TAILORED FOR EACH SETTING
INCLUDING ADEQUATE
CONSIDERATION OF INSTRUCTIONAL
PROGRAMS OPERATING AT EACH
SCHOOL SITE. AND THE NEEDS OF
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES. SCHOOL
LEADERS SHOOTING GATE TO
RELEVANT STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING
FAMILIES STAFF A LABEL PARTNERS
IN THIS GOAL COMMUNITY TO
FORMULATE AND IMPLEMENT PLANS.
GENERALLY THE GUIDELINES
EMPHASIZE PREVENTION MEASURES
WHILE OFFERING SCHOOLS SOME
FLEXIBILITY TO APPROPRIATELY
MEDICAID BASED. BASED ON THE
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT THEY HAPPEN
NAVIGATE. THIS INCLUDES AN
EMPHASIS ON PROMOTING HEALTHY
HI TO PRACTICE THIS. BUILDING
THOSE PRACTICES INTO THE SCHOOL
DAY AND INTENSIFYING CLEANING
THIS INFECTION AND VENTILATION.
THE GUIDANCE DISCUSSES
IMPLEMENTING THIS NOTHING
INSIDE AND OUTSIDE OF THE
CLASSROOM. EMPHASIZING
PRACTICES THAT MINIMIZE CONTACT
A SHARING OF RESOURCES AND
EQUIPMENT AND PROMOTE THE USE
OF NON CLASSROOMS BASIS TO
MAXIMIZE SPACE WHENEVER
POSSIBLE. THE GUIDANCE ALSO
DISCUSSES TRAINING OF ALL STAFF
INACTIVE INFREQUENT SCREENING
FOR SIGNS AND SYMPTOMS IN ORDER
TO IDENTIFY ANY POTENTIAL
CASES. IN CREATING PLANS TO
ISOLATE INDIVIDUALS HO MAY BE
COME SYMPTOMATIC. ADDITIONALLY
THE GUIDANCE ADDRESSES THIS
YEAR COMES DOWN SAYS UNDER
WHICH SCHOOLS MAY HAVE TO CLOSE
SHOULD THERE BE A RISING CASE
THIS THING THE SCHOOL
POPULATION WITH AN EMPHASIS ON
CONSTANT CONTACT WITH THE LOCAL
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICER FOR
GUIDANCE AND CONSULTATION.
FINALLY I WANT TO EMPHASIZE
THAT OUR GUIDANCE PROVIDES A
GENERAL FRAMEWORK FOR SAFE RE
OPENING AND DOES NOT CONSTITUTE
A REGION MANDATE OR SET OF
REQUIREMENTS I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND ATTENTION.
THANK YOU DOCTOR CHAVEZ WILL
NOW TURN BACK TO-
SUPERINTENDENT THURMAN OF AGAIN
FROM LOS ANGELES. BABY THERE
AND NUMBER EIGHTY. WE'RE HAPPY
TO PROVIDE COPIES OF THE
GUIDANCE TO ANYONE WHO WISHES
TO HAVE A COPY OF IT- WE ALSO
IN THE GUIDANCE HAVE A NUMBER
OF APPENDICES AND SUMMARIES AND
A HEALTH AND SAFETY CHECK LIST
THAT POINTS TO MANY OF THE KEY
AREAS THAT WE THINK ARE
ESSENTIAL. TO PROVIDING SAFETY
FOR OUR STUDENTS AND OUR STAFF
I LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE- ON THE
PANEL TODAY YOU'LL HEAR FROM-
DAVID SHIP HIGHER FROM THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION- WHO CO CHAIRED- I
HEALTH AND SAFETY GROUP THAT
WAS PART OF OUR- GUIDANCE TASK
FORCE ALONG WITH EDGAR IS JUST
WAIT- FROM THE- FROM MAX- THE
SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS- THIS
CHECKLIST YOU'LL HEAR ABOUT IN
DETAIL FROM MR SHIPP PIRA BUT
IT HAS MANY OF THE THINGS THAT.
WE CONSIDER TO BE MEDIUM
MINIMUMS THE RECOMMENDATIONS-
FOR STUDENTS AND STAFF AS
YOU'LL SEE OUR GUIDANCE WILL
TALK ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
WEARING A FACE COVERING FOR
STUDENTS AND FOR STAFF IT'LL
TALK ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
TEMPERATURE TAKING SOME WILL BE
IN A POSITION TO TAKE
TEMPERATURE. BEFORE AND STAFF
ENTER THE CAMPUS IT WILL TALK
THE IMPORTANCE OF MAINTAINING
THE GOAL DISTANCE AND WE READ
SIX THE END OF EDUCATIONAL IS
AN ECHO S. AND ALL EIGHT EVEN
ON A AND HAD DEEP CONVERSATIONS
AND I. REMEMBER ALL THE AND FOR
TENNIS THERE IS A LET ME KNOW
THAT THESE RECOMMENDATIONS REP
CHAO. RULE TO MEAN WORST AFTER
RIDE A BUS TO SCHOOL SOMETIMES
FOR LAW DISTANCES WE HONOR.
LEAVE THIS IS CRITICAL. THE
GOAL BY AN ABERRATION LEE. AND
SO WE'VE MADE DIRECT THAT HE ON
A BUS SIX FEET IS I SHOULD BE
THE ORDER OF THE DAY THAT
THEY'LL BE PHYSICAL DISTANCING
UP AND THAT WE RECOGNIZE THAT
MANY OF OUR SCHOOLS WILL
CONTINUE TO USE DISTANCE
LEARNING UP BOTH BECAUSE OF THE
REQUEST OF THE FAMILIES BUT
ALSO AS A STRATEGY TO HELP MAKE
THE CAMPUS SIZE SMALLER TO MAKE
THE CAMPUS FOOT PRINT SMALLER
TO BE ABLE TO ADDRESS. THE
NEEDS OF OUR STUDENTS AS THE
CHIP XIN ARE AND IT SPEAKS
ABOUT THEIR TYPES OF
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMMING HOUSE
STAFF CAN BE CHANGED HOW
STUDENTS CAN BE RANGE WE OWE
THAT MANY MAY. MAKE DISTANCE
LEARNING BUT WE KNOW THAT FOR
THOSE WHO CHOOSE TO COME TO
SCHOOL THAT WE MAY SEE COHORTS
THAT COME A FEW DAYS A WEEK. WE
MAY EVEN SEE DIFFERENT SESSIONS
BEING OFFERED ONE IN THE
MORNING. AND ONE AT THE END OF
THE DAY WE'VE HEARD FROM
DISTRICTS LIKE GLENDALE UNIFIED
THAT PLAN TO STAGGER THEIR
START TIMES THAT DAY TO
ACCOMMODATE SMALLER CLASS SIZES
THEY'RE- THEY'RE THEY'RE
THEY'RE TRYING TO GET TO AN
AVERAGE OF TWELVE STUDENTS. PER
CLASSROOM THAT MEANS THAT
THEY'VE GOT A PARTNER WITH
LIBRARIES AND COMMUNITY CENTERS
TO EXPAND THE SPACE THAT THEY
HAVE TO WORK WITH FOR THE
ENTIRE CAMPUS FOOT PRINT WE
KNOW THAT THIS IS HARD. BUT
WE'RE REACHING OUT TO DISTRICT
TO WORK WITH THEM AS THEY TO
MAKE OUT HOW THEY CAN BUY THIS
SPACE TO PROVIDE DIFFERENT
OFFERINGS OF FOR STUDENTS AND
SO. WE LOOK FORWARD TO THE
CONVERSATION. THE COMMITTEE
WILL HAVE THIS. DISTRICTS NEED
TO HAVE IN PLACE AND WE'RE
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MAY
HAVE THIS TIME. JUST HEAR FROM-
DO SHAPIRO WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION IS
HERE IN THE- IN THE HEARING
ROOM WITH US AND- LET ME IS
COMMON ABOUT THE FOLKS THAT HE
REPRESENTS HERE TODAY- THAT
THESE FOLKS HAVEN'T GONE HOME.
THESE FOLKS HAVE REMAINED AT
SCHOOL SITES THEY BEEN FEEDING
FAMILIES FEEDING COMMIT THESE.
MODERN DAY SOUP LINE THESE
FOLKS HAVE BEEN FOR ABOUT
PROVIDING IT. SO YOU ARE
UNIQUELY POSITIONED TO SPEAK
ABOUT WHAT'S BEEN GOING ON THE
CHALLENGES THEY FACE THE
CHALLENGES THEY WILL FACE. AS
WE PHASE IN AND EXTRADITED SEE
HOW MUCH I'M I SPEAK FOR ALL
OF. ALL THIS ALL THIS THISTHIS
THIS THIS COMMITTEE. AND
REALLY- YOU KNOW STATE- WE
THANK YOU AND YOUR POINT ON THE
GROUND AND OF AGAIN. GONE WORK
EVERY DAY. AND EVEN FEEDING
MORE PEOPLE THAN EVER BEFORE.
ENTIRE FAMILIES AND BEYOND SO
THANK YOU FOR ALL THE- MEMBERS
DOES WITH THAT. RECEIVE THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AND
APPRECIATE THAT A KNOWLEDGE
MEANT OF THE HARD WORK OUR
MEMBERS OF THE JOINT BEEN DOING
DURING THIS. DISCLOSURE GOOD
MORNING I'M DAVID SHIPLER I'M
THE DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS AT THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION.
WE REPRESENT NEARLY A QUARTER
MILLION CLASSIFIED SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES WORKING IN
CALIFORNIA'S K. THROUGH
FOURTEEN SYSTEM. I'M ALSO PROUD
TO SPEAK TODAY AS A
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE LARGER
EDUCATION LABOR COMMUNITY.
SCHOOLS MUST BE A SAFE PLACE
FOR STUDENTS AND STAFF. THAT IS
ALWAYS OUR HIGHEST PRIORITY IN
THE EDUCATION SYSTEM BUT THAT
OBJECTIVE HAS NEW MEANING IN
THE CO IN NINETEEN AIR. EVER
SINCE SCHOOLS CLOSED IN MARCH
LABOR ORGANIZATIONS HAVE BEEN
ENGAGE WITH THE MANAGEMENT
GROUPS AND STATE OFFICIALS TO
DEVELOP A PLAN. FOR RE OPENING
FOR PHYSICAL INSTRUCTION OF
STUDENTS. TO BE CLEAR. WE KNOW
HOW TO REOPEN SCHOOLS. OUR
MEMBERS DO WHATEVER YEAR
USUALLY WITHOUT INCIDENT. BUT
UNIQUE TIMES CALL FOR UNIQUE
MEASURES. THAT'S WHY
SUPERINTENDENT THURMAN ASKED
ACTORS AS WHAT MY COUNTERPART
AT THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS AND MYSELF TO
LEAD A COMMITTEE TO CONSTRUCT
ITEMS WITH SUPPORT FROM CITY.
LEGISLATIVE STAFF HHS AND
COUNTLESS OTHER STATE AGENCIES
TO PLAN FOR THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF STUDENTS AND STAFF ON
SCHOOL SITES. AS THE
SUPERINTENDENT SAID THROUGHOUT
THE PROCESS WILL BE CONSIDERED
WHAT IT TAKES TO RE OPEN SCHOOL
SAFELY. WE HAVE BEEN COGNIZANT
OF DISTINCT LOCAL CONDITIONS.
FOR EXAMPLE SCHOOLS MIGHT BE BE
UTILIZED VERY DIFFERENT
SOLUTIONS TO LIMIT THE NUMBER
OF STUDENTS REPORING THE
CAMPUS AT A TIME IN ORDER TO
MEET PHYSICAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS. SOME SCHOOLS WILL
HAVE STAGGERED SCHEDULES OTHERS
MIGHT USE COHORTS SOME SCHOOLS
MIGHT EVEN BE ABLE TO MANAGE
DISTANCE IT WITHOUT SCHEDULING
JAMES. ON THE OTHER HAND THERE
ARE SOME ISSUES WHICH SHOULD BE
ADDRESSED CONSISTENTLY. ACROSS
THE STATE. TO MEET THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY NEEDS OF EVERY
CALIFORNIA STUDENT AND STAFF
PERSON. OUR COMMITTEE REFER TO
THESE SORTS OF GUIDELINES AS
UNIVERSAL TRUTHS. FOR EXAMPLE
STUDENTS AND STAFF WITH
TEMPERATURES OVER A HUNDRED
POINT FOUR DEGREES SHOULD BE
SENT HOME WHETHER YOU'RE IN
OAKLAND OR CURSED LONG BEACH
FOR A LONG TIME. EVERY
CALIFORNIA STUDENT AND ALL
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES DESERVE THE
SORTS OF MINIMUM PROTECTIONS.
BOTH SETS OF GUIDANCE THE CITY
PH AND SEE YOU GUYS BEING
DISCUSSED THIS MORNING PROVIDE
RELATIVELY COMPREHENSIVE SET OF
GUIDELINES FOR RE OPENING
SAFELY. THE EDUCATION LABOR
COMMUNITY IS GENERALLY SUPPORT
OF. OF BOTH OF THESE SETS OF
GUIDELINES. THE LABOR COMMUNITY
IS THANKFUL FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO HAVE HAD FEEDBACK IN THE
PROCESS OF FINALIZING THE C. PH
GUIDANCE AND YOU HAD A DIRECT
ROLE IN WORKING WITH MANAGEMENT
GROUPS CD AND PUBLIC HEALTH
AGENCIES TO BUILD THE CD REOPEN
CHECKLIST. SEE YOU GUIDANCE
ANSWERS MANY OF THE QUESTIONS
FOLKS MEDICATION COMMUNITY ARE
ASKING. LIKE HOW TO ADDRESS
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT FOR STAFF
AND STUDENTS THE SUBJECT OF
WHICH I'VE HAD MANY
CONVERSATIONS WITH BOTH THE
CHAIRMAN AND THE CHAIR WOMAN.
THE CDC GUIDANCE MAKES CLEAR.
THAT BOTH STAFF AND STUDENTS
SHOULD WEAR FACE COVERINGS ON
CAMPUSES AND IN SCHOOL
VEHICLES. WE APPRECIATE THAT CD
ANSI PIZZA RECOGNIZED THAT SOME
EMPLOYEES WILL BE MORE ROBUST
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT DEPENDING
ON THEIR JOB DUTIES. WE ALSO
APPRECIATE THE WORK OF CALLAWAY
YES IN THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
ALONG WITH HEAVY DOSES OF
ADVOCACY FOR MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE. AND OF BOTH
CHAMBERS. TO PRODUCE AND
PROCURE FACE COVERINGS AND
ADDITIONAL IT MEANT LIKE
SURGICAL MASKS AND NINETY
FIVE'S FACE SHIELDS AND
DISPOSABLE GLOVES FOR SOME
CLASSROOM EDUCATORS. WORKER BUS
DRIVERS FRONT OFFICE STAFF AND
FOOD SERVICE FOLKS AND
CUSTODIANS. FOR WILL BE TASKED
WITH NEW AND DUTIES LET FORMING
SYMPTOMS INCLUDING CHAPTER
CHECKS. AS STUDENTS AND STAFF
AND- BUSES AND CAMPUSES TO
PREVENT COVERT NINETEEN
POSITIVE STUDENTS STAFF AND
VISITORS FROM ENTERING SCHOOL
FACILITIES AND VEHICLES. THE
CRITICAL WORK WILL REQUIRE
TRAINING EQUIPMENT AND THE
NECESSARY STAFF TO KEEP OUR
CAMPUSES SAFE. AS THE
SUPERINTENDENT MENTION
CUSTODIANS WILL HAVE TO OPERATE
UNDER ENHANCE CLEANING AND
DISINFECTING PROTOCOLS TO
SERVICES LIKE DOOR HANDLES
HANDRAILS AND SINKS SERVICES
LIKE DESK TABLES CHAIRS SCHOOL
BUS BENCHES MIGHT NEED TO BE
CLEAN BETWEEN USES. SCHOOL FOR
LIKE WE NEED MORE STAFF PORT
NOT LESS TO MEET THE NEW
STANDARDS. WE APPRECIATE THIS
LEGISLATURE'S WORK IN RECENT
DAYS AND WEEKS TO PROVIDE THE
NECESSARY RESOURCES FOR THAT TO
HAPPEN. CVE ALSO RECOMMENDS.
ARE COMPLYING WITH THE STRICT
PHYSICAL DISTANCING STANDARDS
THAT WERE RECOMMENDED BY THE
CDC SIXTY MINIMUM DISTANCING
WILL REQUIRE SUBSTANTIAL
REDUCTION THE PASSED THE BUSES
AND CLASSROOMS IN MANY CASES.
HEALTH EXPERTS AGREE THAT ALONG
WITH HAND WASHING AND FACE
COVERINGS PHYSICAL DISTANCING
IS CRITICAL TO PREVENT SPREAD
ESPECIALLY TO VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS INCLUDING MANY
STUDENTS FAMILY MEMBERS AND
MANY OF OUR SCHOOL EMPLOYEES.
THE CITY GUIDE ALSO ADDRESSES
THE ACUTE NEEDS OF SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES TO FACILITATETHEIR
ABILITY TO KEEP CAMPUS IS SAFE
FOR EVERYONE. OUR MEMBERS ARE
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS GUIDANCE AND
WE BELIEVE EXECUTION OF THE
PARTICLES THERE IN WILL GIVE US
THE BEST CHANCE OF KEEPING
STUDENTS AND STAFF SAFE.
SCHOOLS FOR EXAMPLE WILL BE
SUFFICIENT STAFFING RATIOS TO
IMPLEMENT THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
pGUIDANCE WITH FIDELITY. THE
DOCUMENT MAKES CLEAR THE
STAFFING LEVELS MUST BE QUOTE
SUFFICIENT TO MEET UNIQUE
FACILITY CLEANLINESS PHYSICAL
DISTANCING STUDENT LEARNING AND
HEALTH AND SAFETY NEEDS. AS YOU
MAY KNOW THE EDUCATION LABOR
COMMUNITY HAS ASKED LEGISLATIVE
LEADERS TO PREVENT LAY OFS FOR
ALL SCHOOL EMPLOYEES SO SCHOOLS
CAN MEET THESE GOALS. THE CDC
GUIDANCE ADDRESSES THE NEED FOR
REASONABLE ACCOMMODATIONS FOR
STUDENTS AND STAFF. FOR
EMPLOYEES WHO NORMALLY HAS TO
WORK IN CLOSE QUARTERS CHANGES
IN PHYSICAL WORKS SPACES MAY BE
NECESSARY. DOES WILL LIKE WE
NEED TO BE RE ARRANGED PHYSICAL
BARRIERS MAY NEED TO BE
CONSTRUCTED IN SOME CASES THESE
MODIFICATIONS THAT PROTECTIONS
WILL ALSO REQUIRE RESOURCES.
LEDS ARE ALSO ASKED TO PROTECT
AND SUPPORT STAFF WHO ARE AT
HIGHER RISK FOR SEVERE ILLNESS.
BY PROVIDING OPTIONS SUCH AS
TELEWORK OR NEGOTIATED CHANGES
AND CLASSIFICATION WE'RE DUTIES.
SOMETIMES SUCH ACCOMMODATIONS
MAY NOT BE PRACTICABLE. IN
THOSE CASES ELEAZAR ASKED TO
WORK WITH THE EMPLOYEE TO
DEVELOPING LEAVE PLAN THAT
AVOIDS EXHAUSTING THE EMPLOYEES
OR LEAF. A CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES SHOULD NOT BE
DEPRIVED OF THEIR LIVELIHOOD OR
ROBBED OF THEIR OWN BENEFITS
BECAUSE OF CIRCUMSTANCES
TOTALLY BEYOND THEIR CONTROL.
EMPLOYEES MUST ALSO RECEIVE THE
TRAINING NECESSARY TO DO THEIR
JOBS UNDER THESE UNIQUE
CIRCUMSTANCES. SUBSTANTIAL
TRAINING BEFORE AND AFTER
SCHOOLS REOPEN WILL BE
NECESSARY TO ENSURE VIGILANCE
IN MEETING THESE HEALTH AND
SAFETY STANDARDS TO KEEP
EVERYONE SAFE. FINALLY ELEAZAR
INSTRUCTED TO ENGAGE WITH THEIR
EMPLOYEES AND LABOR GROUPS TO
WORK COLLABORATIVELY AND
TAILORING BARGAINING AGREEMENTS
TO ADDRESS ALL OF THESE ISSUES
IDEALLY BEFORE SCHOOLS ARE
REOPENED. CSE IS MEMBERS AND
THE MEMBERS OF THE OTHER
EDUCATION ORGANIZATIONS
INVOLVED IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF
THE GUIDANCE LOOK FORWARD TO
SCHOOLS RE OPENING AND SEEING
OUR STUDENTS IN PERSON AGAIN.
E WANT TO ASSURE STUDENTS AND
PARENTS ACROSS CALIFORNIA. THAT
WE WILL DO EVERYTHING IN OUR
POWER TO PREVENT SCHOOLS FROM
BECOMING PLACES WHERE THIS
DISEASE IS SPREAD. I REALLY
WANT MY APPRECIATION TO THE
MEMBERS OF THE CD REAL BRING
TASK FORCE ESPECIALLY OR HEALTH
AND SAFETY COMMITTEE. THESE
FOLKS ESSENTIALLY TOOK ON A
SECOND JOB DURING ALREADY BUSY
TIMES OVER A PERIOD OF WEEKS TO
COMPILE THE SCHOOL RE OPENING
CHECKLIST. I ALSO WANT TO THANK
THE FOLKS AT T. PERSONALLY
SUPERINTENDED BERMAN CHIEF
DEPUTY SEVENTY GREGSON AND
SCHOOL FACILITIES AND
TRANSPORTATION DIRECTOR ONE
MORALIS. FINALLY THE HEALTH
EXPERTS IN SCHOOL PRACTITIONERS
OUT IN THE FIELD REALLY GUIDED
OR WORK. AND I CAN'T THINK ALL
OF THEM ENOUGH FOR THEIR
INSIGHTS AND FEEDBACK THE
CALIFORNIA EDUCATION LABOR
COMMUNITY REALLY APPRECIATE.
HAVING OUR VOICES HEARD IN THIS
PROCESS. AND IN THE PROCESS OF
THIS COMMITTEE HEARING AND I'LL
BE HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
AFTER MY COLLEAGUES CONTACTS.
THANK YOU MR SHIPP BUYER. AND
JOB JUST FOR SOME FOLKS AT HOME
WHO MIGHT NOT KNOW SOME
ACRONYMS WE THREW AROUND
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S MORE
PEOPLE WATCHING TODAY THAN.
USUAL THAT HAVE AN INTEREST IN
THIS TOPIC BECAUSE OF THEIR OWN
CHILDREN- CD IS THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION THAT'S
MISTER THURMAN'S DEPARTMENT OR
SUPERINTENDENT PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION OF YOU'VE HEARD
SPEAK TWICE. AND ELLIE A IS
LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCY WHICH IS
TYPICALLY. A SCHOOL DISTRICT'S
SO WHEN YOU HEARD THOSE TERMS
THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE THEY'RE
REFERENCING US WITH THAT WE'RE
GOING TO- AGAIN THEY CAN
STRUCTURE FIRE WE'RE GOING TO
OUR NEXT SPEAKER. IS DOCTOR
KATIE MCNAMARA. THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF THE SOUTH BAY
UNION SCHOOL DISTRICT THAT'S
DOWN IN SAN DIEGO- SHE IS
JOINING US BY A REMOTE- Y.
VIDEO FEED FROM THE SAN DIEGO.
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION
AGAIN DOCTOR KATIE MCNAMARA.
YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN READY.
VERY NICE BACKGROUND ARE YOU
REALLY OUTSIDE. THAT'S GREAT I
REALLY OUTSIDE I SHOULD HAVE
DONE THAT THANK YOU TO
BEAUTIFUL SAN DIEGO DAY. MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
DOCTOR KATIE MCNAMARA AND I AM
THE SUPERINTENDENT IN THE SOUTH
BAY UNION SCHOOL DISTRICT AT
THE BORDER OF MEXICO IN SAN
DIEGO COUNTY WITH SEVENTY FIVE
HUNDRED PRE CHOOL THROUGH
EIGHTH GADE STUDENTS. OF WHICH
84% ARE HISPANIC AND LATINO AND
86% ARE EITHER ENGLISH LEARNERS
FOSTER YOUTH OR SOCIO
ECONOMICALLY DISADVANTAGED. I
AM ALSO THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS ACCESS
SUPERINTENDENTS COUNCIL
PRESIDENT AND I WAS PRIVILEGED
TO BE THE CHAIR OF THE AXE
EVERY OPENING SCHOOLS TASK
FORCE. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE A PART OF
THIS IMPORTANT DISCUSSION. I
CONSIDER IT AN HONOR TO SPEAK
WITH YOU TODAY. IN MY THIRTY
FOUR YEARS I EDUCATION I HAVE
TRULY NEVER EXPERIENCED A MORE
CHALLENGING TIME FOR OUR
PROFESSION. IN THE CONTEXT OF A
GLOBAL PANDEMIC AND WITH THE
SOCIAL UNREST WE ARE
EXPERIENCING AS A COUNTRY. WE
HAVE NEVER NEEDED YOU AND STATE
LEVEL LEADERSHIP MORE. THE JOB
EVERY OPENING SCHOOLS IS
EXTREMELY CHALLENGING. THE AXE
THE RE OPENING SCHOOLS TASK
FORCE DEVELOPED A CALL TO
ACTION FOR CLEAR HEALTH AND
SAFETY PROTOCOLS ESSENTIAL
STANDARDS FOR TEACHING AND
LEARNING FUNDING AND
FLEXIBILITY. MY ENTIRE CAREER
HAS BEEN FOCUSED ON CLOSING
ACHIEVEMENT OPPORTUNITY GAPS
AND CHAMPIONING EQUITY
UNCOVERING DIFFERENCES IN THE
SCHOOL EXPERIENCES OF OUR
CHILDREN. TODAY I STAND BEFORE
YOU CONSIDERING HOW VERY ALIKE
SCHOOLS HAVE ACTUALLY BàN. AND
HOW WORRIED MY COLLEAGUES ARE
AS THEY DESCRIBE OUR NEW
SITUATION AS BEING IN THE WILD
WILD WEST. WHILE THIS PANEL IS
FOCUSED ON HEALTH AND SAFETY IT
GOES WITHOUT SAYING THAT
GREATER EROSION TO CONSISTENCY
OF LEARNING EXPERIENCES WILL
FURTHER EXACERBATE THE
INEQUITIES THAT HAVE PLAGUED
OUR SCHOOL SYSTEMS. WHEN I
FIRST READ THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
INDUSTRY GUIDANCE DOCUMENT AND
STRONGER TOGETHER THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION GUIDE BOOK I WAS
RELIEVED THAT THE SPIRIT AND
INTENTIONS OF THESE DOCUMENTS
WERE A LINE TO WHAT I HAD BEEN
PLANNING. FOR MY SCHOOLS IN MY
DISTRICTS. I WAS SHOCKED TO
LEARN THAT WHEN THAT THERE WAS
A SIGNIFICANT LACK OF ALIGNMENT
FOR SOME OF MY SUPERINTENDENT
COLLEAGUES. ON THE ONE HAND WE
HAVE LEADERS WHO BELIEVE IF WE
OPEN UNDER THESE CONDITIONS AT
ALL WE WILL BE FINANCIALLY
DEVASTATED BY LAWSUITS WHEN WE
CAN'T POSSIBLY GUARANTEED. THAT
EMPLOYEES AND STUDENTS ARE
COMPLETELY SAFE. ON THE OTHER
HAND SOME LEADERS ARE IMAGINING
OPENING SIMILARLY TO THE WAY WE
CLOSED IN MARCH. AS AN EXAMPLE
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
GUIDANCE SAYS TEACH AND
REINFORCE USE OF CLOCK FACE
COVERINGS MASTER FACE SHIELDS.
BUT THE CDC GUIDE BOOK SAYS IF
AN ALLEY A REQUIRES STUDENTS TO
WEAR FACE COVERINGS THEN THE
ELLIE A MUST PROVIDE FACE
COVERINGS TO BE USED. ALTHOUGH
I'M NOT ONE OF THEM SOME
LEADERS HAVE INTERPRETED THAT
TO MEAN THAT MASKS ARE NOT
REQUIRED AND NO LONGER PART OF
PLANNING FOR RE OPENING. IF THE
INTENT WAS UNIFORMITY OF
DIRECTION IT IS TURNING OUT TO
BE QUITE VARIED IN ITS
IMPLEMENTATION. WITH SEVENTY
SIX PAGES OF DIRECTION IN THESE
JUST TO DOCUMENTS YOU CAN
IMAGINE THERE ARE MORE
QUESTIONS AND WE HAVEN'T EVEN
RECEIVED THE NEXT ANTICIPATED
DIRECTION FROM OUR COUNTY
OFFICE SAYS. ONE OF THE
STRONGEST RECOMMENDATIONS FROM
THE OXYTOCIN FORCE WAS FOR
CONSISTENCY AND WE CONTINUE TO
NEED AND WANT TO BE ABLE TO
REOPEN SCHOOLS IN THE MOST
REASONABLY CONSISTENT MANNER.
THE LEVEL OF DIFFICULTY IN
OPENING SCHOOL IS VERY HIGH I
MADE A LIST OF NEW ROUTINES
TEACHERS WILL NEED TO TEACH.
JUST ARRIVING TO SCHOOL
INVOLVES LEARNING WHAT TO DO
ABOUT STOCK HOW TO GET ON A BUS
HOW TO SIT HOW TO GET OFFTHE
BUS HOW DO ARRIVE ON THE SCHOOL
CAMPUS HOW TO GET YOUR
TEMPERATURE AS FAST WHERE TO GO
IF YOU'RE ALLOWED ENTRANCE AND
IF NOT. HOW THE HALLWAYS ARE
DESIGNATED FOR POUNDS OF TRAVEL
AND MORE. I HAVE THOUGHT OF
FIFTEEN SEPARATE VIDEOS THAT
WOULD TAKE A MINIMUM OF TWENTY
MINUTES IN LENGTH. FIVE HOURS
OF CONTENT TO KNOW AND
UNDERSTAND FOR CHILDREN WHO ARE
COMING TO SCHOOL FOR THE FIRST
TIME AT FIVE YEARS OLD. AND FOR
UPPER MIDDLE GRADE SCHOOLERS
WHO ARE GOING TO HAVE TO RE
LEARN YEARS OF PRACTICE WITH
THE ROUTINES OF THE PAST. THIS
FEELS CLOSE TO IMPOSSIBLE
WITHOUT MORE STAFF. EVEN WITH
THE POTENTIAL ROSIER FINANCIAL
PICTURE THAT THE LEGISLATURE
HAS BEEN DISCUSSING I AM
CONFIDENT THAT I WILL BE MAKING
CUTS TO PERSONNEL IN OUR FUTURE
BOARD MEETINGS. FURTHER
DISTRICTS MUST SPECIFICALLY AND
ACCURATELY REASSESS THEIR
OPENING PLANS BEFORE THEY'RE
ABLE TO NEGOTIATE THE IMPACTS
AND EFFECTS OF THOSE PLANS WITH
THEIR LABOR PARTNERS. GREATER
DIRECTION FROM THE STATE MAKES
THAT EASIER. WE HAVE VERY
LITTLE TIME AND IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT THE WORK OF
ADULTS DOES NOT COMPROMISE A
SINGLE DAY OF HIGH QUALITY
INSTRUCTION FOR A CHILD. LAST
THE GUIDANCE FROM MULTIPLE
AGENCIES THAT IS SOMETIMES
CONTRADICTORY HAS NOT SOFTENED
THE FULL WEIGHT OF THE
RESPONSIBILITY I FEEL TO BE THE
FINAL AUTHORITY RELATED TO
MATTERS ASSOCIATED WITH THREE
OPENING MY SCHOOLS. QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE AUTHORITY OF WHO
SHOULD BE MAKING THE CALL O
CLOSING AND REOPENING SCHOOLS
HAVE BEEN RAISED IN THE FIELD
AND WE CONTINUE TO SEEK
GUIDANCE. I WOULD LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT TONY THURMOND
FOR HIS LEADERSHIP ON BEHALF OF
SUPERINTENDENT WEBINARS ARE
COUNCIL MEETING AND DOCUMENTS
THAT HAVE SUPPORTED OUR WORK
AND I'M SO INCREDIBLY. FOR YOUR
INTEREST IN HEARING MY
REFLECTION ON THE WAY A- THANK
YOU ARE TO RENT DR MCNAMARA. AT
A IS A GREAT QUESTION ABOUT
LIABILITY THAT YOU BROUGHT UP
FOR SURE- AND ALSO THE GUIDANCE
SOMETIMES CONFLICTS SO I THINK
WE MAY HAVE SOME QUESTIONS ON
THAT COMING UP. ABOUT WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO OUR LAST WITNESS
OF PANEL NUMBER ONE AND AGAIN
OUR FINAL SPEAKER FOR THIS
PANEL IS CAROL GREEN. SHE IS
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE PTA
AND SHE IS ALSO JOINING US FROM
OUR LOCATION YOUR LOCATION IN
SAN DIEGO. AGAIN A SCREAM OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE- PTA.
THANK YOU SO MUCH YES WERE
OUTSIDE AND DEFINITELY SOCIAL
DISTANCING. THE PAST FEW MONTHS
HAVE BEEN VERY DIFFICULT FOR
EVERYONE ESPECIALLY FOR OUR
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
CALIFORNIA STATE PDAS BEEN
ASKING PARENTS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE HOW THINGS ARE GOING AND
IN SUCH A LARGE DIVERSE STATE
YOU MIGHT IMAGINE WE'RE NOT
GETTING SINGLE ANSWERS BUT
THERE ARE A FEW UNIVERSAL
THEMES THAT KEEP EMERGING THEY
SEEM TO FALL INTO THREE MAIN
CATEGORIES. CONCERNS ABOUT THE
SOCIAL NO WELL BEING OF
CHILDREN THEIR FAMILIES AND
TEACHERS CONCERNS ABOUT
COMMUNICATION PARENTS WANT TO
KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON BUT THE
SCHOOL PLANS TO DO AND WHAT
THIS PROCESS WILL BE LIKE IT
ALSO LIKE TO BE PART OF THE
PROCESS. CONCERNS FOR MOST
VULNERABLE CHILDREN STUDENTS
WITH SPECIAL NEEDS SOCIO
ECONOMICALLY DISADVANTAGED
FAMILIES AND OTHER VULNERABLE
STUDENTS ALL KIDS NEED TO BE
CONSIDERED IN THIS PROCESS.
CALIFORNIA STATE PTA WAS PART
OF THE STATE SUPERINTENDENT'S
RE OPENING TASK FORCE AND WE'RE
PLEASED TO SHARE THE PARENT
PERSPECTIVE IN THOSE
DISCUSSIONS. WE SUPPORT THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF STRONGER
TOGETHER AND ALSO SUPPORT THE
DECISION THAT MOST DECISIONS
WILL BE MADE BY LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. PTA HEARD FROM
PARENTS ACROSS THE STATE AND IN
MAY WE HELD A LISTENING SESSION
I'D LIKE TO SHARE WITH YOU SOME
OF THE QUOTES WE RECEIVE FROM
PARENTS. KATE A MOTHER OF ONE
SON SAID I HAVE GOOD DAYS AND
BAD DAYS BUT THE SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL ASPECT IS THE HARDEST
MY SON IS MISSING HIS FRIENDS.
AND HE HAS TO STAY HOME WITH ME
ALL DAY. A MOM OF THREE SAID
IT'S HARD TO HEAR MY KIDS
CRYING THEY MISS THEIR TEACHERS
AND THEIR FRIENDS. THEY'RE
AFRAID AND THEY DON'T KNOW
WHAT'S GOING ON AND I DON'T
KNOW WHAT TO TELL THEM. REBEKAH
A MOM OF TWO SAID PERSONALLY
I'M GREAT BUT I'M COMPLETELY
DISCONNECTED FROM THE SCHOOL
COMMUNITY. THE SCHOOLS NOT
TELLING US ANYTHING WE HEAR
DIFFERENT THINGS ON THE NEWS
IT'S NOT SAFE IT IS SAFE
SCHOOLS WILL OPEN SCHOOLS ONE
OPEN THEY'LL CHANGE SCHEDULE
REQUIRE MATH. JUST TELL US
WHAT'S GOING ON. MICHELLE A MOM
OF HIGH SCHOOL ATHLETES SAID
I'M NERVOUS ABOUT WHAT THE
FUTURE OF EDUCATION LOOKS LIKE
WITH THE CUTS TO EDUCATION
BINDING. AND AARON SAID I WISH
THERE WERE MORE SUPPORT FOR
PARENTS THROUGH THIS PROCESS.
HOW DEAR SAID I'M CONCERNED
ABOUT THE HEALTH WITH THINGS
OPENING UP. BUT I'M ALSO
CONCERNED ABOUT HERE HOW
PARENTS INCLUDING MYSELF ARE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO WORK. AND I
WISH I KNEW WHAT WAS GOING ON.
SHAUNA MY KIDS WANT DON'T WANT
TO LEAVE THE HOUSE. IT MAY BE
BECAUSE OF THE VIRUS BUT NOT
BEING ALLOWED TO GO PLACES
THEY'RE JUST NOT USED TO IT OR
THEY'RE JUST USED TO BEING HOME
IT WILL BE ESPECIALLY TOUGH.
WHEN THEY HAD BACK TO SCHOOL.
TALKED ABOUT TANTRUMS AND
MELTDOWNS CONCERNS ABOUT TOO
MUCH SCREEN TIME. AND NO WAY TO
TURN OFF THE NEWS AND THEY ALL
SEEM CONCERNED ABOUT MENTAL
HEALTH ESPECIALLY WHEN CHILDREN
RETURN TO SCHOOL. WHEN TALKING
ABOUT RETURNING TO SCHOOL
PARENTS MENTION THEIR KIDS WERE
AFRAID CONCERNS ABOUT COVERT
NINETEEN ABOUT KIDS WEARING
MASKS ABOUT TOUCHING ABOUT
HUGGING ABOUT BEING ALONE ABOUT
BEING IN GROUPS. AND ABOUT
BULLYING. ANOTHER MAJOR CONCERN
PARENTS HAD WAS GETTING
ACCURATE INFORMATION THEY SAID
THEY FELT DISCONNECTED THEY
WERE HEARING CONFLICTING
MESSAGES AND THEY DON'T KNOW
WHAT TO BELIEVE OR HOW TO GET
ACCURATE INFORMATION. PTA
STRONGLY RECOMMENDS THAT
SCHOOLS ENGAGE FAMILIES EARLY
IN THE RE OPENING PROCESS
INCLUDE THEM IN THE DISCUSSION
IN THE DECISION MAKING. AND AS
SCHOOL SHARE BEST PRACTICES AND
PROTOCOLS PARENTS CAN BE PART
OF THE PROCESS AND EXPRESS
THEIR CONCERNS WHEN FAMILIES
HAVE A BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF
WHAT'S GOING ON AND WHY THE
ACTIONS ARE BEING TAKEN. THEN
THEY CAN HELP SUPPORT THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY EFFORTS THAT
ARE BEING PUT FORWARD. WE
SUGGEST ENGAGING FAMILIES AND
ACTIVITIES TO HELP THEM FEEL
MORE COMFORTABLE WHEN RETURNING
TO SCHOOL. PARENTS WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT EVERYONE HAS ACCESS
TO APPROPRIATE EQUIPMENT.
SCHOOLS THEY SAY SHOULD HAVE
EXTRA THERMOMETERS WIPES MASK
WHATEVER IS NEEDED. AND PARENTS
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT SOCIAL
DISTANCE SEEN PROPER HAND
WASHING AND MAKING SURE THEIR
BASIC THINGS LIKE SOAP AND
PAPER TOWELS IN THE BATHROOM.
THEY WOULD LIKE TO KNOW THAT
THEY'LL BE EXTRA THEY WOULD
LIKE TO KNOW IF THERE WILL BE
EXTRA CANCELAR IS NURSES AND
STAFF TO ADDRESS THE SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL THE TRAUMA AND HEALTH
CARE NEEDS OF STUDENTS AS THEY
RETURN TO SCHOOL. THEY'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT HOW THEY'RE
GOING TO BALANCE THEIR WORK
SCHEDULES WITH PROPOSED FLEX
SCHEDULES PLEASE KEEP IN MIND
FAMILIES THAT HAVE MORE THAN
ONE CHILD AND NAY THAN HAVE
THEM A DIFFERENT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. MOST OF ALL.
FAMILIES WANT TO KNOW THAT
THEIR CHILDREN ARE SAFE AND
HEALTHY IN OUR SCHOOLS THEY
WANT TO KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON
AND THEY WANT TO BE PART OF THE
SOLUTION IF AT ALL POSSIBLE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU- WHAT WE
GO TO QUESTIONS NOW AND I JUST
HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS FOR A
COUPLE THE PRESENTERS. AND ALL
US A QUESTION KIND OF. AN
EXPEDITED FASHION IF YOU COULD
RESPOND IN AN EXPEDITED FASHION
YES WE DO OF OTHERS SPEAKERS
AND OTHER FOLKS UP HERE THE
PROBABLY WANT TO ASK QUESTIONS.
IF YOU COULD JUST AGAIN LIMIT
YOUR RESPONSE TO YOU KNOW GIVE
US THE INFORMATION WE NEED BUT-
BUT AGAIN JUST SO WE CAN GET
THROUGH ALL OF THE QUESTIONS WE
HAVE UP HERE- THE FIRST
QUESTION IS FOR DOCTOR CHAVEZ.
THERE'S BEEN SOME DISCUSSION
YOU SAW SOME FROM THE SOME-
FROM SOME OF THE PRESENTERS
WHERE AND THERE APPEARS TO BE A
CONFLICT IN SOME OF THE
GUIDANCE FROM- THE- CD E. VERSE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH. IS THERE A PLAN TO
MAYBE- FIGURE THAT OUT SO THAT
GUIDANCE DOESN'T APPEAR TO
COMPLEX THERE'S GONNA EXAMPLES
FACE COVERING.CD SAYS- THAT AT
A MINIMUM FACE COVERING SHOULD
BE WORN- CD PH- SAYS STUDENTS
SHOULD BE ENCOURAGED SO THERE'S
A BIT OF A DISCONNECT THERE. DO
YOU KNOW IF ANY. I'M NOT ASKING
YOU TO FIX IT TODAY BUT AS OUR
PLAN FOR THE DEPARTMENTS TO
COMMUNICATE TO THE SCHOOLS AND
GET. KIND OF A CONSISTENT.
CONSISTENT GUIDANCE. YES THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION I THINK
IT'S A GREAT IDEA WE WILL BE
HAPPY TO AYE ENGAGE WITH OUR
COLLEAGUES HAD TO THE E. AND-
OFFLINE ON COMMON GROUND US ON
YOU KNOW WE EACH HAD OUR
GUIDANCE FIRST ON AND AS I
INDICATED THAT IS BASED ON ON
OUR BEST THINKING AT THE TIME-
BUT- WE CERTAINLY CAN- MEET
AND- UNDERSTAND THE DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVES AND IF WE THINK
THAT ARE WE NEED TO UPDATE OUR
GUIDANCE WE WILL AND THEY NEED
TO UPDATE THING I ASK PERHAPS
THEY WILL. THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR THAT- THAT COMMITMENT- IT
JUST TOOK A COUPLE OTHER THINGS
THAT THAT WE WOULD COME OUT OF
YOUR WILL HOUSE. DO WE DO WE
HAVE THE FOOD IS THERE A
SPECIFIC TYPE OF MASK BEING
REQUIRED IS THAT TO FIND IN ANY
OF THE GUIDANCE. YES WE
REFERRED TO- FACE COVERINGS-
THAT- CAME BE EITHER MADE FROM
CLOTH. OR THEY CAN BE MADE FROM
MATERIALS. LIKE IN SURGICAL
MASKS. AS YOU HEARD EARLIER- WE
ARE WORKING VERY ACTIVELY ON
YOU KNOW ACTUALLY SUPPLYING
SCHOOLS SOME OF THIS MATERIALS.
AND IT IS MY UNDERSTANDING THAT
IN THE L. LOCATIONS THAT WE
WILL BE GIVEN TO COUNTIES TO
PROVIDE TO SCHOOLS. AND SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WE WILL HAVE BOTH
ANA. CLOTH FACE COVERINGS AS
WELL AS- SURGICAL MASK FACE
COVERINGS. AND AS I UNDERSTAND
IT THAT THAT IS- THE GOVERNMENT
THE GOVERNOR MADE THAT
ANNOUNCEMENT COUPLE WEEKS AGO.
TWO THREE WEEKS AGO ABOUT THE
STATE PROCURING THAT FOR THE
LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS. HOW
THAT GET TO THE LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IS GOING TO THE
COUNTY HEALTH DEPARTMENT. OR IS
IT GOING TO THE COUNTY OFFICES
OF EDUCATION. DO YOU KNOW YOU
KNOW I DON'T KNOW EXACTLY I SAW
YESTERDAY THAT THERE IS DONE ON
A LOCATION TABLE ALREADY THAT
IS BASED ON ON SCHOOLS AND ON
COUNTIES- AND THERE ARE OFFICE
OF EMERGENCY SERVICES WILL BE
GETTING THOSE ON OUR TO
COMMUNITIES BUT I'M NOT CLEAR
WHETHER THEY GO TO COUNTY.
HEALTH DEPARTMENT SORT TO ON
SUPER SO OUT OF SCHOOL DISTRICT
AND SO I WOULD JUST FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE I WOULD HOPE THAT
THERE WE GO TO COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION BECAUSE I THINK I
DISTRIBUTION WILL BE MUCH
SMOOTHER MUCH MORE DIRECT AND
THE COUNTY ARE OF THAT THE
COUNTY- HELP OUR AND SOMETIMES
HAVE OTHER PRIORITIES NOT
THEY'RE NOT GREAT PEOPLE IN
DOING IT MISSION. THIS IS CARED
FOR SCHOOL I TO GO TO SCHOOL
SITES AND I GET. I THINK THE
BEST WAY TO GET THERE'LL JUST.
AS THE- COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION AGAIN WITH REGARD TO
LIABILITY. THERE'S BEEN NO
EXECUTIVE ORDER WITH REGARD TO
LIABILITY. AT THIS POINT AS I
UNDERSTAND US BECAUSE FAR AS A
DEMO FINING SCHOOLS BECAUSE
SCHOOLS COULD. EVENTUALLY COME
A LAWSUIT MACHINE. WRITING
COULD CRIPPLE THE SYSTEM. WITH
A POTENTIAL LAWSUITS DUE. TO BE
AGAIN THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH'S
ISSUED NOTHING WITH REGARD TO.
TO LIABILITY OR INDEMNIFICATION
IS THAT CORRECT. THAT IS
CORRECT TO MY KNOWLEDGE BUT I'M
NOT A 100% CERTAIN ABOUT THAT
BUT WE CAN COVER LOOK OKAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND THEN
JUST. JUST JOB MAYBE FROM
RESCUE THERMAL JUST WANT TO
GIVE YOU A PERSPECTIVE FROM THE
HIGH SCHOOL THAT I TEACH IT WAS
HAS PROXIMITY FIVE THOUSAND
STUDENTS. BERMAN HIGH SCHOOL-
TYPICALLY THE LARGEST HIGH
SCHOOL IN THE STATE THAT'S THAT
THAT'S NON VIRTUAL. AND STUDENT
ACTUALLY ATTEND- IN THE
CHALLENGES AND I'M SURE YOU
LOOK KNOWLEDGE AS TO MR THURMAN
THE CHALLENGES ASSOCIATED WITH
THE CHECKING THE TEMPERATURE.
OF EVERY STUDENT AS THEY ENTER
THE SCHOOL SITE EVERY DAY ARE
GOING TO BE SIGNIFICANT I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT ON
THAT. AS FOR MR THURMAN. I'D
LIKE TO COMMENT IF I COULD GET
MY MICROPHONE YOUR LIFE. YOUR
LIFE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR WE
HAVE BEEN SPEAKING WITH
DISTRICTS ABOUT THE DIFFICULTY-
IN ACCOMMODATING SPACE AND IN
MANY DISTRICTS ARE LITERALLY
MEASURING. TO SEE HOW MANY
STUDENTS THEY CAN SHARE AS I
MENTIONED IN IN GLENDALE
THEY'RE- GONNA USE- PARTNER
FACILITIES TO HELP THEM
ACCOMMODATE THE SPACE- BACK TO
YOUR QUESTION ABOUT PP ABOUT
PERSONAL PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT.
I WANT TO LET YOU KNOW THAT
THAT HAS ALREADY BEEN DELIVERED
TO ALL THE COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION. AND IF YOU WANT WE
HAVE AMOUNTS OF FACIAL
COVERINGS AND I HAND SANITIZER
AND THINGS OF THAT AND SHIELDS
THERE'S BEEN SHIELDS DELIVERED
FOR EVERY TEACHER IN CALIFORNIA
AS WELL AS THE FACE COVERINGS
AND THE HAND SANITIZER WE CAN
PROVIDE YOU THAT INFORMATION IF
YOU LIKE IT. THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR THAT CLARIFICATION ON
THE LOGISTICS FOR THE
VERIFICATION OF THE WITNESSES-
AND JUST- QUESTION FOR MR SURE
PIRA- WITH YOUR SUPPLIER OF IT
WE HAD CONVERSATIONS THIS YEAR.
AFTER THIS CRISIS HAD ABOUT
THAT GETTING YOUR FOLKS ON THE
GROUND ADEQUATE PP TODAY DO
THEY HAVE ADEQUATE BE PAY DAY
DO THEY HAVE. WOULD BE.
QUESTION ON THE- AND THE FOLKS
CONTINUE TO STUDENTS SO A TO
SIR THROUGH THE FOOD SERVICE
AND BECAUSE STORY IN SOME CASES
WE HAVE BUS DRIVERS DELIVERING
MEALS AS YOU KNOW EARLY ON A
CRISIS DID NOT HAVE ACCESS TO
EVEN FACE COVERINGS LET ALONE
GLOVES HAND SANITIZER ABILITY
TO WASH THEIR HANDS FREQUENTLY
IN SOME CASES. I WOULD SAY
TOWARD THE END OF APRIL- THE
SUPPLIES REALLY STARTED FREEING
UP. AND AT THIS POINT TO OUR
KNOWLEDGE PP. AT EAST FACE
COVERINGS MAYBE MAYBE NOT
SURGICAL MASKS OR WERE AND
NINETY FIVES HAVE BEEN
DISTRIBUTED TO ALL OF OUR
MEMBERS ACROSS THE STATE THE
QUESTION IS. IS THERE ENOUGH
SUPPLY FOR THEM TO CONTINUE
GOING FORWARD AND THAT'S THAT'S
WHERE WE'RE LOOKING FOR HELP
FROM THE S. P. I. N. FROM
CALLAWAY YES. AND I THINK THE
GOVERNOR ANNOUNCED A PLAN NOT
TOO MANY THAT NOT JUST A FEW
JUST A FEW WEEKS WE NOTICED A
PLAN TO DO JUST THAT WERE IN
THE STATE WILL PROCURE THOSE
MATERIALS THAT AGAIN AS WE-
SHARED. GET THEM DOWN TO THE
ALLEY ACE SO THANK YOU. OFFER
ME TURN TO THE OTHER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS QUESTIONS ANY QUESTIONS.
MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR OF MY FOR A QUESTION IS
FOR SUPERINTENDENT THURMAN AS
WELL. FIRST I AS HE'S GETTING
BACK SWITCHED OVER ON LET ME
THANK YOU FOR EVERYTHING THAT
YOU PERSONALLY AND CD HAS DONE
DURING THIS TIME I KNOW YOU
GUYS HAVE DONE A LOT OF
WEBINARS BUT I DIDN'T GET THAT
THIRTY CENTS MARCH THIRTY AND
THAT'S RIDLEY GREAT- SO MY
QUESTION- MISTER SUPERINTENDENT
IS. DO YOU THINK THAT CD IS
GUIDANCE TO SCHOOLS IS
SUFFICIENT. THERE ARE A LOT OF
DECISIONS THAT EACH SCHOOL
DISTRICT WILL HAVE TO MAKE.
WE'LL HAVE TO MAKE. I THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION MADAM CHAIR-
YOU KNOW THE GUIDANCE
REPRESENTS THE BEST INFORMATION
THAT WE KNOW NOW AND YOU KNOW
WE BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE TO
CONTINUE TO MONITOR ON A DAILY
BASIS BETWEEN NOW AND SCHOOLS
WE OPEN IN THE FALL- BECAUSE AS
YOU KNOW MANY OF THE
PROJECTIONS ABOUT THE NUMBER OF
INFECTIONS ARE CHANGING. AND WE
NEED TO MONITOR THAT AND ADJUST
THE GUIDANCE AS NECESSARY AND
SO WE ENVISION- YOU KNOW THIS
IS A GUIDANCE DOCUMENT THAT
CHANGES OVER TIME BUT WE FELT
IT WAS IMPORTANT TO PROVIDE
BASED ON THE SIZE THAT WE KNOW
NOW THE STRONGEST
RECOMMENDATIONS- IN I KNOW THAT
YOU KNOW SOMEONE SUGGESTED
THAT. YOU KNOW THAT WE MIGHT OF
EQUIVOCATE IT ON FACE COVERINGS
BUT WE'RE MAKING THE STRONGEST
RECOMMENDATION THAT ALL
STUDENTS AND STAFF WE'RE A FACE
COVERING IN EVERY IN EVERY
ACTIVITY IT WAS A HARD PROCESS
BUT OUR TASK FORCE ON THE
OPENING- REALLY HAD A STRONG
PARTICIPATORY PROCESS THAT
BROUGHT TOGETHER TEACHERS.
CLASSIFIED STAFF ADMINISTRATORS
AND PARENTS AND WE'RE GRATEFUL
FOR ALL THOSE WHO HELPED
PROVIDE THAT INFORMATION AND SO
THIS IS THE BEST INFORMATION WE
HAVE AT THIS TIME WILL CONTINUE
TO MONITOR AND UPDATE THE
GUIDANCE AS NEW INFORMATION
BECOMES AVAILABLE SO REALLY
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING IT'S A
LIVING DOCUMENT THAT'S PERFECT
THIS IS WHAT I HAVE NOW AN
UPDATE AS WE GET MORE
INFORMATION PERFECT- BECAUSE
THE GUIDANCE IS NOT MANDATORY.
WHAT SHOULD BE ON A PARTICULAR
ELOISE THE CHANCE TO RE OPEN-
WITH CLEARLY INSUFFICIENT
MODIFICATION INSUFFICIENT.
HELLO FOR AT THE REPRESENTATIVE
FROM THE APARTMENT PUBLIC
HEALTH WILL SPEAK ABOUT THAT
BECAUSE AS I UNDERSTAND IT THE
ONLY AGENCIES IN THE STATE THAT
REALLY HAVE ANY ENFORCEMENT
CAPABILITIES- IN THIS AREA
WOULD BE THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH. NOW
OF COURSE COUNTY HEALTH
OFFICERS DO HAVE THE ABILITY TO
MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS ABOUT WHEN
THINGS CAN BE MORE FLEXIBLE OR
WHEN THINGS HAVE TO BE MORE
RESTRICTED AS YOU'RE SEEING
RIGHT NOW. COUNTY HEALTH
OFICERS ARE MAKING DECISIONS
TO SAY THAT COUNTIES CAN REOPEN
ALTHOUGH THERE'S STILL
REQUIRING SOME IN SOME CASES A
FACIAL COVERING AND THEY'RE
RECOMMENDING ALL THE THINGS
THAT WE'RE DOING. AS IT RELATES
TO HAND WASHING- THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION- OUR GUIDANCE IS
ADVISORY- AND BUT WE HAVE BEEN
IN COMMUNICATION WITH EVERYONE
OF THE COUNTY SUPERINTENDENTS
WE'VE HELD NUMEROUS. WEB CALLS-
WE'RE WE'VE HOSTED A THOUSAND
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ALL AT ONCE
WE'VE ENCOURAGE EVERYONE TO DO
THE SAME THING WE'VE EVEN
CONVENE COUNTY HEALTH OFFICERS.
WITH COUNTY SUPERINTENDENTS
THAT'S BEEN DONE BEFORE BUT WE
DO IT BECAUSE WE RECOGNIZE. YOU
CAN TIMES. WHAT THEY'RE MIXED
MESSAGE. AND IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
US TO ALIGN OUR MESSAGES AS
BEST AS POSSIBLE WE'RE GONNA
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH YOU
REGIONAL- COLLABORATIONS WITH.
COUNTY HEALTH OFFICERS IN THEIR
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENTS TO
PROVIDE THE BEST INFORMATION
THAT WE CAN IN THE MOST
CONSISTENT CLEAR INFORMATION
THAT WE CAN- TO OUR
CONSTITUENTS ARE OUR PARENTS
OUR STUDENTS AND OUR EDUCATORS.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SUPERINTENDENT. PLEASE
LET THE LEGISLATURE KNOW IF
THERE'S ANYTHING WE CAN BE
HELPFUL WITH. IF THERE'S
ANYTHING WE CAN TO BE HELPFUL
WHAT THE BUDGET THAT THE
LEGISLATURE BOUGHT FOR IT IS
VERY HELPFUL- I THINK THE FACT
THAT IT RESTORES THE CUTS- IS
IMPORTANT. I DISTRICTS HAVE
BEEN REALLY CLEAR THAT THEY
NEED ADDITIONAL REVENUE FOR PP
RIGHT NOW OUR SCHOOLS. I'M
GRATEFUL TO THE GOVERNOR A
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES
FOR PROVIDING PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT FOR SIXTY
DAYS. BUT THAT AS AN ONGOING
COST THIS IS A PLACE WHERE
SCHOOLS ARE GOING TO NEED
SUPPORT FROM THE STATE AND FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. AS WELL
AS- AS YOU KNOW FROM YOUR CHAIR
BEING CO CHAIR ON OUR JUST ON
OUR- CLOSING THE DIGITAL DIVIDE
GROUP- THERE CONTINUES TO BE A
GREAT NEED. OF FOR DIVERT
COMPUTING DEVICES IN HOT SPOTS
FOR STUDENTS AND SO THESE ARE
THE PLACES WHERE WE BELIEVE THE
STATE HAS THE ABILITY. THE
STATE'S MADE FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS AVAILABLE FOR INTERNET
AND THAT'S INCREDIBLE. WE ALSO
NEED THE STATE TO USE ITS
BUYING POWER TO HELP PURCHASE
LOW COST COMPUTING DEVICES AND
HOT SPOTS FOR OUR STUDENTS. AND
TO HELP THE SCHOOL DISTRICT
WITH THE COST OF PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT. PERFECT I
MADE A LIST. I MADE A LIST
THANK THANK YOU SENATOR THANK
YOU MISTER KALRA THANK THIS IS
SURE THANK YOU SUPERINTENDENT
BUT THURMOND AND I APPRECIATE
THE WORK YOU IN YOUR DEPARTMENT
HAVE BEEN DOING- ONE
COLLABORATION WITH OUR
LEGISLATIVE LEADERSHIP- AND THE
LAST PORTION OF WHAT YOU JUST
MENTIONED. IT WAS PART OF WHAT
I WAS IN ASSN TERMS OF.
DISTANCE LEARNING AS WELL AS
LEARNING LOSS AND WE KNOW THAT-
THE GAP EVEN BEING IN SILICON
VALLEY. AND SAN JOSE WE SEE
SUCH A DISPARITY IN BEING ABLE
TO GET THE RIGHT EQUIPMENT
INTERNET ACCESS WHAT HAVE YOU
TO SO MANY FAMILIES- AND IN
PARTS OF SAN JOSE AND BEYOND.
AND SO AS WE GO INTO THE NEXT
YEAR WE KNOW. ASSUME THAT
ALTHOUGH WE WANT OUR STUDENTS
BACK IN THE CLASSROOM AND
DISTANCE LEARNING AND THOSE
TOOLS ARE NOW GOING TO BE PART
OF THE NEW NORMAL IN THE
INTERNET AND IN TEACHERS AND
EDUCATORS INTERACTING WITH OUR
STUDENTS AND SO SPECIFIC TO THE
LEARNING LOSS OF THOSE ARE
STILL TRYING TO CATCH UP AND
GET THAT EQUIPMENT I KNOW THE
GOVERNOR'S SPOKEN A LOT. ON
THAT OF IN TERMS OF CERTAIN
POPULATIONS THAT ARE GONNA BE
FURTHER BEHIND AS I JUST DOES
ANY THOUGHTS YOU HAVE ON THAT
IN TERMS OF NOT JUST REGION I
DO A DIGITAL DIVIDE THAT KIND
OF THIS NEW NORMAL OF A
CORPORATE IN DISTANCE LEARNING
BUT WHAT WHAT YOUR THOUGHTS
MIGHT BE IN TERMS OF HELPING
THOSE STUDENTS THAT ARE PART OF
FAR. FALLING FURTHER BY.
THROUGH THIS. ON THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALL
THE QUESTION WE HAD A CHANCE TO
MEET WITH SOME STUDENTS IN YOUR
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT TWO WERE WE
LIKE TO RE CONNECT YOU WITH
THEY WERE SO IMPRESSIVE THAT
THEY WANTED TO JOIN OUR EFFORTS
IN RAISING MONEY- FOR COMPUTING
DEVICES- VERY PROUD OF YOU YOUR
STUDENTS AND ALL OF OUR
STUDENTS WE BELIEVE THAT WE
HAVE TO ACCELERATE LEARNING
AND- IN SO IN THAT RESPECT
FIRST IT STARTS WITH TEACHERS
ASSESSING WERE STUDENT ENTERS
INTO THEY NEED SUPPORTS TO HELP
THEM TO REALLY ENTER N GRADE
LEVEL- TEACHERS ARE REALLY THE
BEST LEADERS TO HELP MAKE THOSE
INTERVENTIONS. BUT WE CAN
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL SUPPORTS IN
RICHMOND PROGRAMS TO HELP
PROVIDE SUPPORTS TO OUR
STUDENTS LATER THIS WEEK WILL
BE MEETING WITH A NUMBER OF OUR
PARTNERS WHO RELEASED DATA THAT
SHOWED THERE IS A WIDE
DISPARITY IN THE EXPERIENCE OF
AFRICAN AMERICAN LATINO- ASIAN
STUDENTS LOW INCOME STUDENTS
WHOSE EXPERIENCE IN DISTANCE
LEARNING WAS VERY BUMPY AND
THEY DON'T ALWAYS GET ALL THE
THINGS THAT THEY NEEDED AND SO
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION WILL BE
DOING IS PROVIDING MORE
TRAINING ON HOW TO MAKE SURE
THAT DISTANCE LEARNING LOOKS
THE SAME NOT THAT ONE SIZE
SHOULD FIT ALL. BUT THERE
SHOULD BE CERTAIN STANDARDS AND
BASICS THAT CAN BE EXPECTED AND
ABOUT HOW DISTANCE LEARNING IS
PROVIDED LET'S JUST FACE T OUR
WHOLE ENTIRE NATION MOVING TO
DISTANCE LEARNING OVERNIGHT
WITH NO TRAINING WITH NO
ABILITY TO DO THIS AND SO I'M
GRATEFUL FOR WHAT ARE EDGY
YEARS HAVE DONE ON VERY SHORT
NOTICE IN THE MOST URGENT OF
SITUATIONS BUT AS WE GO FORWARD
WE KNOW NOW THAT WE NEED TO BE
ALWAYS THINKING ABOUT WHAT WE
CALL CONTINUITY OF LEARNING
EVEN HEAR A LOT ABOUT IT. IN
THE NEXT PANEL AND ARE ARE
CHEAP DEPUTY PRINTED IT DA
STEPHANIE CRACKS IN IS ALSO OF
IF YOU WANT TO HEAR MORE ABOUT
OUR PLANS AROUND CONTINUITY
LEARN BUT WE KNOW THAT WE
ASSESS THE NEED WILL PUT A BIT
IN SOME WORK FOR ALL STUDENTS
FOR. OUR SHEET IN GAS THAT
EXISTS HOW WE TOLERATE LEARNING
SUPPORT OUR STUDENTS GOING
FORWARD WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO DO
EVERYTHING A DIFFERENT WAY WE
HAVE TO MEASURE LEARNING IN
DIFFERENT WAYS. WE CAN'T JUST
SPOKE ON THE MATTER OF TIME.
THAT SOMEONE IS IN IT IN A
DISTANCE LEARNING MODEL EVEN
SIT IN SEAT TIME. BUT WE HAVE
TO MAKE SURE THAT DISTANCE
LEARNING MEANS THAT STUDENTS
GET ACCESS TO LIVE INSTRUCTION.
AS WELL AS TO INSTRUCTION THAT
COULD BE DIRECTED TO A WEBSITE.
AND THEY'RE GONNA HELP TO
CREATE SOME PRACTICES SOME BEST
PRACTICES. AROUND HOW THAT
DISTANCE LEARNING- GETS
DELIVERED AND AS YOU INDICATED
CONTINUE TO WORK TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE CLOSE THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE. SO OUR STUDENTS HAVE
THE TOOLS TO CONNECT THEM TO
THEIR EDUCATORS AND HAD THE
MOST SUCCESS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING
MORE IN THE NEXT WITH THE NEXT
PANEL AS WELL THANK YOU. MY
BIGGEST REGRET A LOT OF OTHER.
MANY MEMBERS MUCH COMMENT
SAYING THEN. MISS SMITH
COMMENTS. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU MISTER
SUPERINTENDENT FOR JOINING US
TODAY I KNOW YOU AND I SHARE A
BACKGROUND OF HAVING SERVED ON
A SCHOOL BOARD AND- NOT. HAVING
TO MAKE DECISIONS NEARLY AS
CHALLENGING AS THE ONES THAT
ARE LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCIES
NOW FACE. I SAW PICULET CONCERN
ABOUT THE ON GOING ISSUE A
LIABILITY ON AND I THINK WELL
WE HAD VERY ROBUST
CONVERSATIONS AT THE STATE
LEVEL ABOUT PROVIDING GUIDANCE.
TO THE BEST THAT WE CAN IN A
CHANGING INFORMATION
ENVIRONMENT. COULD YOU SPEAK TO
WHAT ELSE WE MIGHT BE ABLE TO
DO. MY TO DO HELP ASSURE THESE
ELLIE A IS THAT THE DECISIONS
THAT THEY'RE MAKING ARE GOING
TO BE BACKED UP AND OUT WHAT
LEVEL. IF THE CD AND THE STATE
LEVEL GUIDANCE IS ADVISORY AND
WHAT THEY'RE ALSO OVERLAYING
WITH THAT IS INFORMATION FROM
THE- STATE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH AND COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. WHAT POINT DO WE
ASK THEM TO. INDICATE THAT RISK
YOU KNOW THIS IS IT IS AN
INCREDIBLY CHALLENGING TIME ALL
OF THE DISTRICT I REPRESENT A
DONE A REALLY ROBUST JOB OF
ENGAGING PARENTS THEY'VE DONE
PARENTS SURVEYS AND THE RESULTS
ARE MIXED YOU KNOW TO THE POINT
THAT MS GREEN REYES PARENTS ARE
ALL IN VERY DIFFERENT PLACES
SUMMER UNIQUELY UNCOMFORTABLE
WITH. STILL BACK TO CLASSROOMS
SUMMER NOT COMFORTABLE WITH
STUDENTS ATTENDING WITH FACE
COVERINGS SOME WOULD RATHER YOU
KNOW THEIR CHILD CONTINUE TO
HAVE ONLY AN ONLINE EARNING A
LEARNING OPTIONS I WOULD RATHER
HAVE THEIR CHILD BACK IN CLASS
FULL TIME- IN THE DAYTIME
LEARNING ENVIRONMENT AND GIVEN
ALL OF THOSE CONSTRAINTS WHAT
PARENT COMMUNITIES ARE
EXPECTING. AND GUIDANCE TO THE
BEST OF OUR ABILITY I REALLYAM
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT LIABILITY
FOR DISTRICTS AND IF YOU COULD
SPEAK TO WHAT WE MIGHT BE ABLE
TO DO EITHER AT THE LEGISLATIVE
LEVEL OR HOW WE CAN ASSIST YOU
WITH THE DEPARTMENT TO KIND OF
MITIGATE THAT TO THE EXTENT
POSSIBLE I'D APPRECIATE THAT.
REMEMBER SMITH THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION YOU KNOW I COME TO
YOU AS A PUBLIC SERVANT LIKE
YOU SOMEONE WHO'S WORKING
EDUCATION- I I'M I'M NOT- YOU
KNOW I DON'T WORK IN THE RISK
POOL SO I DON'T KNOW HOW TO
SPEAK IN TERMS OF. YOU KNOW
WHAT THE LIABILITY FOLKS SAY-
BUT I DO KNOW. THAT THIS
GUIDANCE SPEAKS TO THE MOST.
SAFE WAYS. THAT WE CAN SUPPORT
OUR STUDENTS RETURNED TO
CAMPUS. BASED ON THE SCIENCE
THAT WE CURRENTLY HAVE. WILL
CONTINUE TO MONITOR THAT AND AS
NEEDED CHANGE IT. I CAN TELL
YOU THAT THERE HAVE BEEN SOME.
EDUCATION LEADERS WHO BEGUN THE
CONVERSATION TO LOOK AT.
QUESTIONS AROUND A RISK
MANAGEMENT. AND I'D BE HAPPY TO
CONNECT YOU IN ANY MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE. WHO ARE
INTERESTED IN JOINING THOSE
CONVERSATIONS. THERE ARE OTHER
AGENCIES THAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT. HAVE THE
ABILITY TO SPEAK TO THOSE AND
WE WANT TO ENGAGE THEM WILL BE
CONVENING THEM. IN
CONVERSATION. BECAUSE I THINK
IT'S SOMETHING THAT WARRANTS A
QUESTION. BUT WE UNDERSTAND
THAT MANY PEOPLE HAVE FEARS
WHEN THE WHEN THE US DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION SAID THAT WE COULD
PROVIDE. AS A NATION DISTANCE
LEARNING TO STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES. THERE ARE MANY
PEOPLE WHO HAVE QUESTIONS.
QUESTIONS ABOUT LIABILITY SO
MUCH SO THAT SOME OF THAT.
VISION TO DO IT. DIRECT WOULD
NOT ADVISE THAT. STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES AND WE WOULD SAY
THAT THAT IS NOT THE DIRECTION
TO GO WE THINK IT'S BETTER TO
ASK THE QUESTIONS TO FACE THEM
HEAD ON TOGETHER BUT TO PROVIDE
THE BEST POSSIBLE AND MOST
SAFETYTHAT WE CAN PROVIDE FOR
STUDENTS IN THE BEST QUALITY
EDUCATION WE'RE HAPPY TO
CONNECT YOU TO THOSE
CONVERSATIONS ARE TAKING PLACE
ABOUT RISK MANAGEMENT- BUT IN
THE MEANTIME WE WILL CONTINUE.
TO UPDATE OUR GUIDANCE THE BEST
INFORMATION WE HAVE BASED ON
SCIENCE AND HEALTH STANDARDS
ABOUT HOW WE CAN BEST KEEP OUR
STUDENTS AND STAFF SAFE WHEN
OUR SCHOOLS WE OPEN. IN THE
FALL. THANK YOU MISTER
SUPERINTENDENT MISTER CHAIR IF
I MIGHT I ALSO HAVE A QUESTION
FOR DOCTOR MCNAMARA. THANK YOU
DOCTOR MCNAMARA- I APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS EARLIER AND I
KNOW WHILE WE'RE- ALL
TENTATIVELY EXCITED THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WAS ABLE TO PASS A
BUDGET THAT DID NOT HAVE-
EXTREME CUTS. TO EDUCATION WE
ALL KNOW THAT EDUCATION HAS NOT
BEEN FULLY RESTORED TO WHERE WE
SHOULD HAVE BEEN- PRE RECESSION
IN THE CUTS WE ALSO STAND FOR
THOSE NUMBER OF YEARS SO WE-
ALREADY WERE STILL OPERATING AT
A DEFICIT AND STILL ONE OF THE-
LOWEST. OF PER PUPIL FUNDED
STATES IN THE UNITED STATES.
THAT HAS NOT GONE AWAY NOW WE
JUST FACES GREATER CHALLENGE.
SO IT TO YOU AND PERHAPS AND TO
THE MEMBERS OF ACCESS. HAVE
THERE BEEN MODELS DEVELOPED ON
WHAT AN ADDITION WELL
INVESTMENT TAKE TO ADEQUATELY
MEET. THE CHALLENGES IN THE
GUIDELINES THAT ARE BEING
PLACED IN FRONT OF. BJ'S NOW
FOR. IF YOU IN INDIA GO AS- HOW
MUCH A DISH. CLASSIFIED STAFF
YOU WOULD NEED- SUPPORT FOR THE
CLEANING AND FOR THE MOVEMENT
OF CHILDREN IN AND OUT OF THESE
ADOPTED LEARNING ENVIRONMENTS.
WELL I CAN SPEAK FOR MY SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN PARTICULAR IN GREAT
DETAIL- WE RUN ABOUT A SEVENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLAR BUDGET AND
WE HAVE BEEN DEFICIT SPENDING
ACROSS YEARS. AND SUFFERING
FROM DECLINING ENROLMENT SO
WHAT MAKES THAT INCREDIBLY
CHALLENGING. IS THAT THERE IS A
THERE'S OFTEN A SENSE IN A
BROADER RANGE OF CIRCLES. THAT
SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE BEEN
RESTORED AND WELL FUNDED- BUT
WHAT IT ACTUALLY FEELS LIKE IN
MY ENVIRONMENT IS THAT I HAVE.
BEEN REALLY SUFFERING JUST TO
KEEP UP- EVERY YEAR WE'VE BEEN
DEFICIT SPENDING AND REDUCING
OUR ENDING FUND BALANCE
ANNUALLY- SO THE CHALLENGES I
FACE AS A RESULT OF HAVING
FEWER STUDENTS- AND RIGHT
SIZING THE BUDGET EVERY YEAR-
COMBINED. WITH RISING COSTS IN
SPECIAL EDUCATION AND RISING
COSTS IN PERSON STIRS FUNDING
THAT WE HAVE TO DO IT FEELS
THAT WE HAVE JUST BARELY BEEN
ABLE TO TREAD WATER. AND IN MY
CASE WE HAVE- MOVED FROM
POSITIVE TO A QUALIFIED BUDGET
WHICH IS VERY CONCERNING. AND
THAT WAS BEFORE THIS PARTICULAR
PANDEMIC- SO NOW I AM VERY
WORRIED THAT I'M FACING- TRACK
YOUR RIGHT AS MY BUDGET AT THE
SAME TIME I'M TRYING TO REALLY
ADD- WITH IT NEEDS THAT WE
HAVE. I KNOW THAT YOU DISTRICT
DOES NOT REPRESENT ALL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS- BUT I DO KNOW THAT
MONEY FEELS INCREDIBLY
CONSTRAINED- AS IT IS AND THE
ADDITIONAL COSTS ARE JUST ONE
MORE. I DON'T KNOW WHERE I MEAN
I FIND THE MONEY KIND OF SIT.
AND THAT IS LIKELY JUST A GETS
TOLL IN THE PERSON THAT WE HAVE
SINCE THE BUDGET ARE. FIVE PER
TO. NOW THANK. THANK YOU MISS
SMITH STONE GIVE US ABOUT.
SHOULD BE READ. THIS IS NOT
WORKING WITH FROM. TRY AGAIN.
THE TOPIC. IT IS ON SO. TRY TRY
THAT ONE. THE SUPERINTENDENT
THURMAN I HAVE A QUESTION. CAN
A- HI SO I THINK YOU HIM SO MY
NUMBER THE FACT THAT HE'S
CONVENE WITH SEVEN OF MICE
SUPERINTENDENTS FROM MY COUNTY
SAN WE OFTEN TALK ABOUT MODOC
COUNTY. BECAUSE THEY HAVE NO
CASES ZERO CASES IN MODOC
COUNTY. SO THERE IS DEFINITELY
SOME CONCERNS IN REGARDS TO
PLANS THAT THEY'RE PUTTING
TOGETHER. AND I THINK THE
BIGGEST THING IS WILL SIGN ONE.
WILL BE THEY WILL SIGN OFF
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICER OR WILL
YOUR OFFICE SIGN OFF BECAUSE IN
A LOT OF IS SOME OF OUR SCHOOLS
ARE FIFTEEN STUDENTS PER
CLASSROOM NOW. AND WHAT IS IT
WHAT WOULD THAT LOOK LIKE FOR
THE MORE RULE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
AND I ALSO HAVE CONCERNS IN
REGARDS TO. SOME OF OUR KIDS.
ARE NOT BEEN ACCOUNTED FOR
PHYSICALLY BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
COMING TO SCHOOL AND WE DON'T
HAVE EYES ON THEM. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSIONS IN REGARDS TO
PARTNERING POSSIBLY WITH LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT OR- HOW DID
START TO DO SOME. YOU KNOW WELL
CHILD CHECK. IN THOSE REMOTE
AREAS BECAUSE I KNOW THAT I
KNOW FOR A FACT THAT KIDS
AREN'T BEING ACCOUNTED FOR.
SEVEN DOLLY WE'RE HAPPY TO
ADDRESS FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU
FOR SETTING UP THE MEETING WITH
THE SUPERINTENDENTS IN YOUR
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT AND WE'RE
HAPPY TO CONTINUE THAT
CONVERSATION AS IT RELATES TO
STUDENTS THAT YOU MENTION
WHO'VE NOT CHECKED IN THIS IS
AN ISSUE THAT'S BEEN ONGOING SO
WHY I'D GET IN THE COALITION OF
COUNSELING GROUP SCHOOL COUNCIL
SCHOOL I CALL JUST ASK SOCIAL
IS ANOTHER'S THE- WORK TO GET.
THERE WITH YOU IT IS IN YOUR-
DID YOU OUT REACHES. WHO HAVE
NOT YET CHECKED IN YET MAYBE
THEY'RE LOOKING FOR BASIC NEEDS
MOVE IT HAD TO MOVE DURING THE
PANDEMIC. AND SO WE'RE HAPPY TO
WORK WITH YOUR OFFICE OFF LINE.
ABOUT HOW TO MAKE THOSE
CONNECTIONS TO SUPPORT THOSE
PARTICULAR STUDENTS. THE OTHER
THING I WANT TO SAY IS THAT YOU
HAVE A GREAT CAP FOR INTENDED-
IN IT KNOW THAT THERE ARE
DIFFERENT DYNAMICS IN. THE IN
IN MODOC COUNTY AND IN OTHER
PLACES- BUT WHAT I. ABOUT YOUR
CASE YOU PRINT. THE LOCAL. IT'S
A THAT. DAY MAINLY. CASE WITH
US. THEY RECKON. THAT THEY'RE
ALL KINDS OF NEEDS LOCALLY AND
STATEWIDE. AND WE'VE BEEN A
REALLY GOOD COMMUNICATION. AT
THE END OF THE DAY THE COUNTY
HEALTH OFFICER IN THE COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT WILL WORK
TOGETHER- AROUND COMMUNICATE.
PLANS FOR WHAT RE OPENING WILL
LOOK LIKE EVERYONE OF OUR ONE
THOUSAND SCHOOL DISTRICTS WILL
MAKE THEIR OWN DECISIONS ABOUT
THE TIMING. ABOUT WHEN IT WILL
BE OPEN. MANNER IN THE FIELD TO
DO THAT BUT WE TRY TO DO IS
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE.
TECHNICAL SUPPORT. GUIDED IN
QUESTIONS. WHAT DO QUESTIONS ON
HOW THAT RE OPENING CAN ASAP
AND THE MOST STIFF CONNECTIONS
WE'RE HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOU
AND YOUR TEAM. ON HOW THAT
HAPPENS IN MODOC ME ARE AGAIN.
IN YOUR FAMILY DID. AND THE
FORWARD TO BEING IN TOUCH WITH
YOU OFF LINE. THANK YOU. GREAT
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISSED ALL
THAT IS A REAL CHAU FACE. OR
TALK ABOUT CONNECTIVITY THEY'RE
CERTAINLY HAVING THE DEVICE
CERTAINLY HAVING A HOT SPOT OR
SOMETHING TO. CONNECT THE
DEVICE WITH THERE'S ALSO
GETTING KIDS TO CHECK AND
GETTING HIS TO RE ENGAGE IN
SCHOOLS BEEN VERY DIFFICULT-
TO. SOME OF THE TEACHERS I KNOW
SO THAT AS MANY AS 60% PLUS
OTHER STUDENTS HAVE NOT CHECKED
BACK IN. IT THAT THEIR BEAGLE
OUT. RIGHT RIGHT A- AND MARTIN
SAID HEY I'M GONNA BE NO MATTER
WHAT NOW YEAH I MADE IT BACK.
OR ANOTHER SO TO IRAQ IN THE WE
DON'T. SAID OTHERS ARE ALL.
GREAT AND- DESERT THINGS
DISTRICTS TO HAVE TO TACKLE AS
WE HAD IN THE NEXT YEAR HOW DO
THEY RE ENGAGE AND CHECK ON
THAT. THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
CHILDREN AS WELL. SO WITH THAT-
I WANT TO THANK DR GIL CHAVEZ.
OUR SUPERINTENDENT MISTER
THURMAN THANK YOU- DAVE SPIRO.
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION DOCTOR
KATIE MCNAMARA SUPERINTENDENT
FROM THE SOUTH BAY. AND OF
COURSE CAROL GREEN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PTA THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION. WE'RE
NOW GOING TO MOVE ON THE PANEL
FOR TO. PANEL NUMBER TWO SO
LET'S MOVE TO OUR SECOND PANEL
WE WILL BE ADDRESSING TEACHING
AND LEARNING IN THE NEXT SCHOOL
YEAR A REMINDER THAT WE WILL BE
LOOKING- WE WILL BE HOLDING OUR
QUESTIONS UNTIL THE END OF THE
PANEL OUR FIRST SPEAKER WILL
BE- AT THE WORLD FAMOUS DR
LINDA DARLING HAMMOND SHE IS
PRESIDENT OF THE STATE
EDUCATION AND SHE IS JOINING
US- VIA REMOTE VIDEO FROM PALO
ALTO AGAIN SO SHE HEADS UP THE
CALIFORNIA STATE BOARD OF
EDUCATION. WHICH SETS GENERALLY
THE POLICIES FOR THE- FOR
SCHOOLS ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ARE GOOD TO SEE YOU
A DOCTOR AND YOU MAY PROCEED
WHEN READY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. SURE O'DONNELL MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
INVITING ME TO BE PART OF THIS
IMPORTANT HEARING. AS THE
PANDEMIC CONTINUES WE BEGIN TO
THINK ABOUT HOW TO RE OPEN
SCHOOLS IT'S CLEAR THAT PICKING
UP WHERE WE LEFT OFF AND
RETURNING TO BUSINESS AS USUAL.
IT WILL WILL NOT BE POSSIBLE
WILL NEED TO ADDRESS THE DEEP
SEEDED INEQUALITIES THAT LONG
PLAGUED EDUCATION IN THE STAE.
I WILL ALSO NEED TO THINK OF
SCHOOL IN DEEPLY DIFFERENT
WAYS. TEACHING AND LEARNING
WILL HAVE TO BE ORGANIZED IN
WAYS THAT ARE GOVERNED BY
PURPOSE NOT BY PLACE. AND WE
WILL SEE A WIDE RANGE OF
ARRANGEMENTS FOR HOW ADULTS AND
CHILDREN WORK WITH ONE ANOTHER
SOMETIMES A BRICK AND MORTAR
CLASSROOMS. AND OTHER TIMES
ACROSS CYBERSPACE IN VARIOUS
FORMS OF DISTANCE LEARNING.
I'LL EMPHASISE FOR THINGS IN MY
TESTIMONY TODAY WHICH ARE-
ELABORATED IN MORE DETAIL IN MY
WRITTEN STATEMENT. OF THAT
TEACHING AND LEARNING SHOULD BE
DESIGNED TO BE CONTINUOUS AND
SUPPORTED BY TECHNOLOGY.
AUTHENTIC AND FOCUSED ON
LEARNING BURN. IN ARMED USEFUL
FOR US. AND IT. WELL AND I KNOW.
THESE DAYS OUTLINED IN A
LEGISLATIVE AGENDA WERE TO BE
BY THE STATE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION THE STATE BOARD AND
THE C. C. E. TO PROVIDE FURTHER
GUARDED GUIDANCE AND SUPPORT TO
LOCAL DISTRICTS. FIRST
CONTINUOUS TEACHING AND
LEARNING SUPPORTER BY
TECHNOLOGY IN THE RIGHT WAYS.
IT'S CLEAR THAT TECHNOLOGY
SUPPORTED LEARNING WILL BE PART
OF OUR EDUCATIONAL FUTURE AND
THAT ALL CHILDREN MUST BE
PROVIDED WITH ACCESS. AFTER
SCHOOLS RE OPEN THEY WILL
LIKELY CLOSE AGAIN FOR PERIODS
OF TIME NEXT YEAR ONE INFECTION
RATES FULLER. SOME SCHOOLS MAY
REOPEN WITH SCHEDULES THE BLIND
DISTANCE LEARNING WAS SOCIAL
DISTANCING ONSITE. SOMETIMES
FOR DIFFERENT GROUPS OF
CHILDREN FOR EXAMPLE THE
YOUNGER CHILDREN MAY BE IN
SCHOOL FULL TIME OLDER ONES ARE
STILL LEARNING HOME. ANY
INTEREST ON. TIMES FOR THE SAY
GROUPS OF CHILDREN FOR EXAMPLE
IN SCHOOL LEARNING ON MONDAYS
AND WEDNESDAYS WITH DISTANCE
LEARNING ON TUESDAYS AND
THURSDAYS EVEN ONE SCHOOLS
REOPENED CHILDREN WILL NEED TO
STAY HOME IF THEY ARE OTHERS
THEIR HOUSEHOLD HAVE BEEN
EXPOSED TO THE VIRUS SO THEY'LL
HAVE TO BE ABLE TO PLUG INTO
JUSTIN'S FLOORING AT ANY TIME
AND I WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT
POINT I'VE DONE STUDIES
INTERNATIONALLY OF RE OPENING
SCHOOLS AROUND THE WORLD AND
IT'S CLEAR THAT THE TESTING
TRACKING AND QUARANTINING. IS
EQUALLY IMPORTANT AS THE JUSTIN
SAYING AND USE OF MASKS- IN ONE
EXAMPLE OF THAT IS THE
EXPERIENCE IN FRANCE RECENTLY
WHERE THEY- USE ALL OF THE
SOCIAL DISTANCING AND ALL THE
REST OF IT BUT WITHIN A FEW
DAYS OF OPENING SCHOOL THEY HAD
TO CLOSE SCHOOLS AGAIN. BECAUSE
THEY DIDN'T HAVE ADEQUATE
TESTING TRACKING AND
QUARANTINING IN PLACE AND THEY
HAD SEVENTY CASES POP UP WITHIN
A FEW DAYS. THIS MEANS THAT
EACH DISTRICT SHOULD HAVE AN
INSTRUCTIONAL CONTINUITY PLAN
FOR SEAMLESS CUT NEW CONTINUITY
OF THE CURRICULUM AND
INSTRUCTION WHEREVER STUDENTS
ARE LOCATED. INCLUDING PLANS
FOR HOW ENGLISH LEARNERS AND
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES WELL
ACCESS LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES.
THE NUMBER OF COUNTY OFFICES
AND DISTRICTS OF ALREADY DONE
THE SECOND AS MODELS FOR UP.
SHOULD BE A NEXT. OF THE
FEDERAL FUNDS THAT ARE
ALLOCATED FOR LEARNING LOS IF
WE ARE TO AVOID FURTHER
EXACERBATING DISRUPTIONS. THE
ONLY TO THOSE POTENTIAL LOSSES
OF LEARNING TIME. THERE ARE
MANY STRONG CURRICULAR MODELS
INCLUDING STRATEGIES FOR
SERVING ENGLISH LEARNERS AND
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES.
DEVELOPED BY DISTRICTS AND
COUNTY OFFICES THAT WE WILL
CERTAINLY MAKE AVAILABLE. IN
GUIDANCE AND TOOL KITS FOR
DISTANCE AND WANTED LEARNING.
THE REALITIES OF THESE COMING
MONTHS ALSO MEAN WE MUST CLOSE
THE DIGITAL DIVIDE- AS A
SUPERINTENDENT THURMOND NOTED.
THERE WERE MORE THAN A MILLION
STUDENTS ON ACTIVE WHEN THE
PANDEMIC BEGAN WE'VE CLOSE THIS
DIVIDE. BY MORE THAN HAPPY. BUT
AT LEAST HUNDRED THOUSAND
STUDENTS ARE STILL ON. BUT IT
WOULD COST HELP US THAN 10% OF
THE MONEY WE EXPECT TO ALLOCATE
TO SCHOOLS. FROM THE FEDERAL
ANSWERS FUNDS AND IN MY VIEW IT
SHOULD BE AN ABSOLUTE PRIORITY
IN OUR FIRST USE OF THE FUNDS.
THE TECHNOLOGY TOLD ME TO BE IS
NOT TO REPLACE TEACHERS BUT TO
ENABLE. HIS FACE TO FACE LIVE
CONNECTIONS WHICH GIVES AND-
WHEN NOT CLASSROOM TOGETHER. AS
WELL AS TO PROVIDE STUDENTS
NECESSARY TOOLS FOR LEARNING-
AND TO PROVIDE FAMILIES THE
TOOLS TO BE ABLE TO ACCESS TELL
HEALTH. BENEFITS AND EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES. MAKE NO MISTAKE
ABOUT IT THE DISPARATE HEALTH
EDUCATION AND EMPLOYMENT
IMPACTS OF COVER NINETEEN. ON
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. ARE
DEEPLY EXACERBATED BY OUR
FAILURE TO TAKE CARE OF THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE WHICH SHIP IN A
RADIC HATED YEARS AGO AND MUST
BE ERADICATED NOW. THE SAME AS
FACED TO FACE INTERACTIONS. TO
ESTABLISH HUMAN CONTACT TO
ALLOW CHILDREN TO BE A
DISCUSSION WITH THEIR TEACHERS
AND PEERS. TO PROVIDE A TRUE
LEARNING ENVIRONMENT FOR
DEMONSTRATING IDEAS CHECKING
FOR UNDERSTANDING AND SEEING
HOW CHILDREN ARE THINKING AND
WHAT THEY UNDERSTAND. WHEN THIS
IS LEARNING IS NECESSARY THEY
SHOULD BE A DAILY EXPECTATIONS.
FOR AT LEAST ONE HOUR A DAY AND
THEN MANY OF COMMUNITIES TODAY-
DEPENDING ON THE AGE LEVEL OF
THE STUDENTS IS FROM ONE TO
FOUR HOURS A DAY. I WHETHER
IT'S FOR ELEMENTARY CLASSROOM
MEETINGS AND STORY TIME OR FOR
DEBATES AND DISCUSSIONS ABOUT
LITERATURE HISTORY AND
PARAMETRIC EQUATIONS. MANY
CALIFORNIA DISTRICTS OF ALREADY.
SUCCESSFUL STRATEGIES LIKE THIS
USING A RANGE OF WEB BASED
TOOLS WITH HIGH ENGAGEMENT OF
STUDENTS AND THEY'RE INNOVATING
IN CREATIVE WAYS. IN ADDITION
TO THEIR WELL DESIGNED
CURRICULUM LONG BEACH HAS EVEN
FIGURED OUT HOW TO HAVE
TEACHERS WHO ARE EXPERTS. IN
CERTAIN AREAS OF THE CURRICULUM
TEACHER ONLINE TO ANY STUDENTS
WHO WANT TO ENGAGE A PARTICULAR
TOPIC. AS TO ANY TEACHERS WHO
WANT TO LEARN STRATEGIES FOR
TEACHING AT. MORE THAN TWO
THOUSAND STUDENTS AND MANY
TEACHERS ARE TUNING IN FOR SOME
OF SESSIONS. WHICH ARE LINKED
TO SPECIFIC CURRICULUM REELS OF.
IN THE DISTRICT. MORE TEACHERS
WILL BE ENTERING GAME IN THESE
TECH SUPPORTER DEMO. LESSONS
WHEN SCHOOL BACK IN SESSION SO
THE THEY CAN OFFER. PATIENTS
TECHNOLOGIES ORDER THEN INCOME.
QUESTION WELL TAKING. OF THE
ARE. TO USE A BILL T. X. AND
STUDENTS. TO LAW. THE SEVEN
POINT TO MAKE IS THAT OFFENSE
X. INST. THAT IT WAS TEACHES
STUDENTS TO LEARN. IS THE-
DURING THESE LAW FEW THE
SCHOOLS THAT HAVE SIX. MOTIVE
STE DOING IN WAR. EVEN MORE
GOING HAS BEEN DISRUPT. AND
EVEN IN VERY HIGH NEED TO. HAVE
HAD A PLAN FOR CONTINUOUS
INSTRUCTION A LONG RUNNING
CONTINUUM EACH CONTENT AREA AND
THEY'VE BEEN CONNECTING LESSONS
TO REAL WORLD APPLICATIONS.
TEACHING STUDENTS THE SKILLS
THAT WILL ALLOW THEM TO BECOME
INDEPENDENT LEARNING. THROUGH A
SKILL FOR BLEND OF SYNCHRONOUS
APPROACHES TO UNDERSTANDING
IDEAS FOLLOWING UP ON EIGHTEEN
FOR THIS TIME TO ENGAGE IN
INDIVIDUAL AND COLLECTIVE
RESEARCH PROBLEM SOLVING A
WRITING. WITH TEACHER CHECK INS
PROJECT BASED IMPROV PROBLEM
BASED LEARNING APPROACHES HAVE
BEEN FLOURISHING IN DISTRICTS
RANGING FROM SAN DIEGO FOR TEN
IN ANAHEIM TO LOOK BUSY RICHMAN
AND UPLAND. AND MANY MANY.
OTHERS WHEN SCHOOL RESUMES THI
OF WORK SHOULD CONTINUE IT IS.
ADAPT TO BLUNDER LEARNING
MODELS SAN DIEGO COUNTY HAS
DEVELOPED A SET OF MODULES
ORGANIZING THESE KINDS OF
PROJECTS FOR DISTANCE A BLENDED
LEARNING. GROUNDING IN A
PERFORMANCE ASSESSMENTS THAT
STUDENTS COMPLETE AS PART OF
THEIR WORK. THE STATE CAN PLAY
A ROLE IN CURATING PEDAGOGICAL
RESOURCES FOR THIS KIND OF
LEARNING TO SUPPORT THE
DEVELOPMENT OF SKILLS. ACROSS
SUBJECT AREAS AND STUDENT
GROUPS INCLUDING ENGLISH
LEARNERS AND STUDENTS WITH
LEARNING DIFFERENCES. ENSURING
THAT THESE PEDAGOGIES ARE USED
TO TEACH STUDENTS COGNITIVE
STRATEGIES THAT ENABLE THEM TO
BECOME A SELF GUIDED AN
INDEPENDENT LEARNERS. AND IN MY
WRITTEN TESTIMONY OR PROVIDE A
NUMBER OF OTHER RESOURCES FOR
THIS KIND OF WORK. EVIDENCE
SHOWS THAT TEACHING STUDENTS
HOW THEIR STRATEGIES ABOUT HOW
TO LEARN PAYS OFF A SPECIALLY
FOR STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES.
AND MEANINGFUL APPLICATIONS OF
WEARING THEIR REQUIRE ORAL AND
WRITTEN COMMUNICATION STRENGTH
IN ENGLISH LEARNERS
PROFICIENCIES. IN ADDITION TO
SKILLFUL TEACHING A REGULAR AND
BLENDED CLASSROOM SETTING%
SCHOOLS WILL WANT TO EXPLORE
EXPANDED LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES
THAT MAY INCLUDE INTENSIVE
LITERACY OR MATH INSTRUCTION
AND SMALL GROUPS. WITHIN MULTI
TIERED SYSTEMS OF SUPPORT AND
WITH AN EXPANDED LEARNING TIME
THAT MAY BE CREATED BY SUMMER
SCHOOL ADDITIONAL TIME AFTER
SCHOOL ARE RETHINKINGSCHEDULES
THROUGHOUT THE SCHOOL YEAR. AND
THERE ARE NUMBER OF CURRICULUM
AND INSTRUCTIONAL APPROACHES WE
CAN MAKE AVAILABLE THAT CAN BE
USED TO A SMALL GROUP
INSTRUCTION TO EFFECTIVELY
PRODUCE LEARNING GAINS THAT WE
SHOULD BE PREPARED TO SUPPORT
WHAT THE FUNDS THAT ARE SPENT
ON LEARNING LOS. THIRD
FORMATIVE ASSESSMENTS THAT
SUPPORT GROWTH. RATHER THAN- OF
LEAVING IT TO CHANCE ARE WE
NEED TO USE THOUGHTFUL
DIAGNOSTIC ASSESSMENTS TO
EVALUATE WHAT STUDENTS KNOW
REMEMBER AND ARE READY TO LEARN
NEXT. OF THESE ARE DIFFERENT
THAN THE STANDARDIZED TESTS
THAT ARE WIDELY USED FOR
ACCOUNTABILITY. CALIFORNIA HAS
APPROVED A SET OF DIAGNOSTIC
AND FORMATIVE ASSESSMENTS THAT
ARE ALIGNED WITH COMMON CORE
STANDARDS THAT OFFER TOOLS FOR
ASSESSMENT. IN ENGLISH LANGUAGE
ARTS AND MATH ALONG THE GREAT
SPEND CONTINUING FROM K. TWELVE
WE WILL SOON BE ISSUING
GUIDANCE ON THE USE OF THESE
ASSESSMENTS. TO SUPPORT AN
INFORMAL LEARNING. UP WE ARE
ALSO FORTUNATE AS A STATE TO
HAVE THE ASSETS OF THE SMARTER
BALANCED CONSORTIUM- THEIR
INTEREST MONTHS THAT HAVE BEEN
RECENTLY EXPANDED. SO THEY CAN
BE USED IN DEMISE GLAZER PRETTY
AREAS OF THE CURRICULUM OR AS A
FULL FLEDGED ASSESSMENT. AND
DESTRUCTION AND NAPA FOR HOW TO
USE THESE TOOLS TO THAT
CONSTRUCTION FALL. NOTED ABOUT
HOW TO USE THESE TO. WILL BE A-
I KEEP MY- IS THE- IN THE WE
NOT IDENTIFY. STUDENTS AND LOW
THEM OF FOR DIFFERENT AND THAT
IS I IN A WAY THAT STATEMENT
BECAUSE WE HAVE A LOT OF
EVIDENCE ONE THE ONE STUDENTS
TAKE ONE STIGMATIZING LABELS-
AND ARE RELEGATED TO SORT OF
TEST PREP INSTRUCTION THEIR
ACHIEVEMENT ULTIMATELY IS LESS
THAN WHAT THE TEACHERS CAN
PINPOINT EXACTLY WHAT THEY NEED
TO NEXT. GIVE THEM THE
OPPORTUNITY SOARED THAT SKILL
WITH FEEDBACK AND CONTINUALLY
ITERATE AROUND MOVING THEM
FORWARD IN A LEARN PROGRESSION
AND FINALLY WE NEED TO
INTEGRATE SOCIAL EMOTIONAL
ENACT LEARNING ONCE THE BILL
HAS RE OPENED THE TO TAKES. THE
SOCIAL MOST. I THIS IS A
MORNING WE THAT WELL AS IMPACTS
LEARNING THESE AFFECT CAN BE.
BY STRAW TRUST YOUR- AND OP TO
DEVELOP SOCIAL ABOUT LEARNING
SKILLS. RECOGNIZE ND TALK
ABOUT THE X. THAT EMOTION.
LEARNING STE FOR CA ONCE AND
SOLVING ACCESS HEALTH. AND MY
HEALTH RESOURCES. LIKE
MINNESOTA AND A NUMBER OF OTHER
STATES CALIFORNIA SHOULD
PROVIDE REGULAR RESOURCES.
ELEMENTS OF. FOR A TO THE
SKILLS AND SAYS WORKS. AS WELL
AS CO WE AND REFERENCE. THAT
ENABLE STUDENTS TO COPE WITH
THE MANY CHALLENGES THEY ARE
EXPERIENCING. WE SHOULD ALSO
ENCOURAGE SCHOOLS TO CREATE
MORE RELATION BASED- STRUCTURES
LIKE LOOPING AND ADVISORY
SYSTEMS SCHOOLS THAT HAVE DONE
THIS ARE EXPERIENCING GREATER
SUCCESS WAS STUDENTS WERE OF A
WIDE RANGE OF NEEDS. AND IT IS
IMPORTANT- THAT WE CREATE THE
STRUCTURES WITHIN WHICH
TEACHERS CAN CARE OF ACTIVELY
FOR THE STUDENTS. FOR ALL THE
WORK RESCUE OUR SCHOOLS TODAY
RESOURCES ARE CURRENT RISK YOUR
AND WE WILL NEED IS THE MORE
EYES. AS AS IT WILL SET ASIDE
FUNDING FOR PROFESSIONAL
LEARNING AS THE PHONE FUNDING
MASTER IN VERY SICK HOPEFUL TO
HEAR THAT ARRIVE. WE SHOULD
PRESS. OR FOR FAMILY EDUCATION.
FOR LEARNING THE WRIST VERSUS
FOR. LEARNING THESE TO CONTINUE
AS TACKLE NOTES I'M TO ANSWER
FOR THE QUESTIONS. SEE WHEN YOU
MIGHT HAVE NEVER DONE THAT
RIGHT SO THANK YOU ARE WITH
THAT- WE'RE GOING TO DO IT GO
TO JAMIE ONLY A MIDDLE SCHOOL
TEACHER- FROM THE EMPIRE UNION
SCHOOL DISTRICT WHO IS
REPRESENTING THE EQUITY
COALITION- WITH US TODAY MISS
ONLY A FEW OF SHE'S HERE
ACTUALLY SHE WAS GOING TO YOUR
CONVERTS. BUT SHE IS HERE YEAH
ANIMALS SURE A MIDDLE SCHOOL
TEACHER MAY PROCEED ONE THANK
YOU THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING.
O'DONNELL IN MEMBERS. I AM
JAMIE ONLY A MIDDLE SCHOOL
TEACHER. IN A SMALL CENTRAL
VALLEY DISTRICT AND A TEACH
PLUS POLICY FELLOW. I'M ALSO
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
EQUITY COALITION. THANK YOU FOR
THE INVITATION TO SHARE MY
STUDENTS EXPERIENCES DURING
COVERT NINETEEN. THE STATE
KNOWS THEM AS WAS LEARNERS. AND
SOCIO ECONOMICALLY
DISADVANTAGED. I KNOW THEM AS
CLAUDIA. YOU'RE RIGHT THOUGH.
AND THE WEEKS. I'M HERE TO
ENSURE THAT THEY DO NOT BECOME
ANOTHER STATISTIC. IN A
CONTRIBUTOR TO THE ACHIEVEMENT
GAP. OR TO REMAIN INVISIBLE. I
TEACH ENGLISH LANGUAGE
DEVELOPMENT TITLE ONE SCHOOL.
95% OF MY FAMILY. LIVES THE
POVERTY LINE. THE MOST. G. FOR
BY IN THE HOME. CHILDREN WHO
WERE SEPARATED FROM THEIR
FAMILIES. I LONG TERM ENGLISH
LANGUAGE LEARNERS WHO COME TO
ME AFTER MULTIPLE YEARS OF
HAVING BEEN FELLED BY A PUBLIC
SCHOOL SYSTEM. WHEN SCHOOL IS
CLOSED COMMENT FROM MY STUDENTS
TO WATCH YOUNGER SIBLINGS WHILE
THE PARENTS WORK MULTIPLE JOBS.
NEVER THE LESS THEY ARE
RESILIENT. HARD WORKING AND
HUNGRY TO LEARN. MY STUDENTS
FIGHT A SILENT BATTLE AGAINST
INEQUITY EVERY DAY DISTANCE
LEARNING HAS MADE THIS BATTLE
SO MUCH HARDER. SCHOOL CLOSED
IN MARCH 60% OF MY STUDENTS
IMMEDIATELY DROPPED OFF THE
RADAR MY DISTRICT REQUIRE
TEACHERS TO PROVIDE PACKETS
FROM MARCH TO ME. TEACHERS ALSO
HAVE THE OPTION TO POST
ASSIGNMENTS ELECTRONICALLY IN
ADDITION I CALLED MESSAGE
STUDENTS CONSTANTLY AND DROP A
BOOKS ON THE PORCHES I EVEN
ROWS WHAT DO LOUIS THEM SLEEP
AT ONE O'CLOCK IN THE AFTERNOON
TO TALK TO HIM THROUGH A WINDOW.
I WAS SURPRISED THAT CLAUDIA A
TALKATIVE AND ENGAGE STUDENT IN
MY CLASS STILL HAD MEMBERS
RESPONDED TO ME DESPITE MY
MULTIPLE VOICE MAILS AND
HARASSING LOOKING AT. SUPPORT
OF MESSAGES WHEN SHE FINALLY
ANSWERED THE PHONE SHE SHARED
THAT SHE HAD NEITHER ACCESS TO
A DEVICE NOR WIFI AT THE
BEGINNING OF MAY REMOTE
INSTRUCTION BEGAN IN MY
DISTRICT FAMILIES COULD PICK UP
ONE DEVICE FOR FAMILY FROM
SCHOOL SITES. IMPOSSIBLE FOR
CLAUDIA BECAUSE HER MOM AND
SISTER WORK TWELVE HOUR SHIFTS
IN A PACKING PLANT AND SHE
CARES FOR HER BABY NIECE. SHE
SAID. I HEARD A RUMOR FROM SOME
FRIENDS THAT THERE WAS SCHOOL
BUT I WASN'T SURE I COULD
PARTICIPATE BECAUSE I DON'T
HAVE MY BOOK OR WIFI. AM I
GOING TO GET ENOUGH. THAT SAME
EVENING I DROVE TO HER TRAILER
PARK- WITH A SCHOOL LAPTOP AND
FREE INTERNET PROVIDERS FLYERS
TRANSLATED IN SCHOOL. IN
SPANISH. WHEN I FOLLOWED UP
WITH CLAUDIA LATER THAT WEEK
HER MOTHER WAS OVERWHELMED BY
THE INFORMATION AND HAD STILL
NOT SET UP THE FREE WIFI
SERVICE. I TO CALL MYSELF AND I
WAS NEVER EVER ABLE TO CONNECT
WITH THE HUMAN BEING. FORGET
THE RIGHT HELP DESPITE MULTIPLE
ATTEMPTS. IMAGINE WHAT THIS
EXPERIENCE WAS LIKE FOR
CLAUDIA'S MOTHER. OTHER PARENTS
WHO HAVE LOST JOBS DUE TO KOBE
NINETEEN WERE DENIED FREE
INTERNET ACCESS BECAUSE THEY
ALREADY HAVE AN ACCOUNT WELL
OTHERS LOST PHONE SERVICE.
CLAUDIA SPENT MUCH OF HER
CHILDHOOD HIDING IN A HOUSE-
HOUSE IN MEXICO WHERE CARTEL
GUN BATTLES RAGED OUTSIDE. SHE
WANTS TO SPARE OTHERS FROM
GOING THROUGH THE SAME **** MY
GRADUATING FROM COLLEGE WITH A
CRIMINOLOGY DEGREE AND BECOMING
A DRUG ENFORCEMENT AGENTS.
BEFORE MARCH CLAUDIA WAS
WRITING FIVE PARAGRAPH ESSAYS
NOW. SHE CAN ONLY SPEAK IN
HALTING ENGLISH. THERE WILL BE
NO SUMMER SCHOOL. CLAUDIO INTO
MY CLASSROOM IN AUGUST HAVING
NOT HEARD. SPOKEN RED WRITTEN
ENGLISH FOR FIVE MONTHS.
UNFORTUNATELY HER EXPERIENCE IS
FAR TOO COMMON STUDENTS LIKE
CLAUDIA NEED AND DESERVE SO
MUCH MORE THAN THE CRISIS
SCHOOLING THEY'VE RECEIVED
SINCE MARCH. ACCESS TO QUALITY
DISTANCE LEARNING HAS BEEN
INCREDIBLY IN EVEN THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA WE NEED LEADERSHIP
FROM THE STATE TO ENSURE THAT
WE DO BETTER MOVING FORWARD AND
PUT NECESSARY SAFEGUARDS IN
PLACE SO THAT OUR MOST
VULNERABLE STUDENTS GET ACCESS
TO INSTRUCTION. OBJECTIVE
ACCOMMODATION. AND SUPPORT WE
URGE POLICYMAKERS TO ACT
INTENTIONALLY LEARNING FROM THE
EXPERIENCES OF EDUCATORS
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES.
SPECIFICALLY WE RECOMMEND THIS
STATE CREATE A FRAMEWORK FOR
INSTRUCTIONAL CONTINUITY AS WE
RETURN TO SCHOOL WE MUST
REQUIRE DELAYS TO ADOPT PLANS
THAT EVALUATE ALL STUDENTS TO
DETERMINE HOW MUCH LEARNING
LASSEN TRAUMA THEY EXPERIENCED
DURING SCHOOL CLOSURES. INSURE
A FULL CURRICULUM OF
SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR QUALITY
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER IN SCHOOL
OR BY DISTANCE LEARNING WITH
ACCOMMODATIONS FOR ENGLISH
LEARNERS SPECIAL EDUCATION
STUDENTS. AND STUDENTS
ACADEMICALLY BEHIND. JACK
STUDENTS ATTENDANCE AND LEVEL
OF EDUCATE LEVEL OF ENGAGEMENT
IN EDUCATION DALY. PROVIDE LIVE
OR SYNCHRONOUS DISTANCE
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES BETWEEN
TEACHERS AND ALL STUDENTS.
FINALLY HELP FAMILIES TO
SUPPORT THEIR CHILDREN IN
DISTANCE LEARNING IN THE
LANGUAGES THAT THEIR PARENTS
SPEAK. I'M ASKING YOU TO GIVE
CLAUDIA AN OPPORTUNITY. TO
LEARN TO USE OUR PASSION AND
SKILLS TO IMPACT THE WORLD TO
BE SEEN AS AN ASSET NOT A
DEFICIT. TO LIVE A LIFE OF
FREEDOM. RATHER ONE SPENT IN
CAPTIVITY YOU HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HELP OUR ENGLISH
ENGLISH LEARNERS NOT ONLY
ACCLIMATE BUT TO EXCEL AND
BECOME CONTRIBUTING MEMBERS OF
OUR COMMUNITY YOU WILL BE THE
CHAMPIONS OF CHANGE BY ENSURING
ALL STUDENTS ARE GUARANTEED
THEIR CIVIL RIGHTS OF A
MEANINGFUL OPPORTUNITY TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE PUBLIC
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAM. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR-
YOUR TESTIMONY A VERY REAL
WORLD NO DOUBT SO THANK YOU
WITH THAT WE'RE GOING TO GO ON
TO OUR NEXT SPEAKER OUR NEXT
SPEAKER IS FROM A LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT. I
BELIEVE SHE IS THAT SHE CHIEF
ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT OFFICER.
MAKE CORRECT ENTITLED VERIFY OF
THE CROWD AND CRACKED- HER NAME
IS ALLISON YOSHIMOTO TOWERING
AND AGAIN SHE IS WITH THE LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT. THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE TODAY YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN
READY YOU'RE KIDDING. THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN
O'DONNELL. SENATOR LEYVA AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME THIS MORNING. MY NAME
IS ALLISON YOSHIMOTO TERRY THE
CHIEF ACADEMIC OFFICER OF THE
LOS ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT. I HAVE BEEN ASKED TO
SHARE THE SPENDING ABOUT THE
DISTRICTS EFFORTS TO BRIDGE THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE. UP UNTIL THREE
MONTHS AGO STUDENTS ENTERED
SCHOOL GROUNDS. HAND IN HAND
LAUGHING ARMS AROUND EACH OTHER
GREETING THEIR FRIENDS. AND FOR
THE LAST TWELVE WEEKS THE ONLY
WAY A STUDENT COULD GET ACCESS
TO LIVE INSTRUCTION. SERVICES
AND SUPPORT. LET ALONE THEIR
TEACHERS AND THEIR PEERS WAS
THROUGH A DEVICE CONNECTED TO
THE INTERNET. IN A BRICK AND
MORTAR SETTING WHEN IT CAN A
GARDENER TEACHERS THAT
KINDERGARTEN TEACHER SAYS ONE
TWO THREE EYES ON ME. THAT'S
HOW THE ESTABLISH A CONNECTION.
IN A DISTANCE LEARNING SETTING
THE CONNECTION CANNOT EXIST
WITHOUT A DEVICE AND THAT
INTERNET IT'S A PORTAL IF YOU
WILL. TO THE TEACHER THEIR P.
WELL COMMUNITY. WE TOOK BOLD
STEPS TO ENSURE THAT EVERY
STUDENT IN LOS ANGELES UNIFIED
HAD ACCESS TO COMPUTING DEVICE.
PICTURING OVER A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY THOUSAND DEVICES.OUR
TEAM WORKS TO AUGMENT EACH
SCHOOL'S INVENTORY. WE PROVIDED
LTE ENABLED THE HOTS L. L. T.
E. IN ABLE TO TABLETS AND HOT
SPOT. AT NO COST TO OVER A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND LOW INCOME STUDENTS
WHO NEEDED INTERNET ACCESS AT
HOME. IN LATE MAY TWENTY TWENTY
WE AMENDED OUR ORIGINAL
AGREEMENT WITH VERIZON TO OFFER
OTHER SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN THE
STATE A SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCED
PRICE FOR WIRELESS INTERNET
ACCESS SO THAT STUDENTS COULD
STAY CONNECTED. TO THEIR SCHOOL
FAMILIES. LOS ANGELES UNIFIED
HAS SPENT OVER A HUNDRED
MILLION TO PAY FOR ALL OF THE
DEVICES AND HOT SPOTS. AND WE
CALL OF THE STATE TO HELP
ADDRESS THE CHALLENGES OF
SUSTAINING THESE EFFORTS GOING
FORWARD. NOT INCLUDED IN A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS WAS THE
CLASS IS THE COST OF FUNDING I
HOPE THIS CAUGHT WIND FOR
FAMILIES AND EDUCATORS. SIX
DAYS A WEEK TWELVE HOURS PER
DAY TO ENSURE DEVICES TURN ON
HOT SPOTS WORK. STUDENTS ARE
ABLE TO GET THEIR USER NAMES
AND PASSWORDS ARE Q. R. CODES.
AND STUDENTS KNOW HOW TO ACCESS
THEIR LEARNING PLATFORM. ALSO
NOT INCLUDED IN THE HUNDRED
MILLION IS THE COST TO RUN A
SECOND HOTLINE TO ENSURE MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS ARE
AVAILABLE TO STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES AND EDUCATORS. MANY
OVERWHELMED BY THE CIRCUMSTANCE
AND CONCERNED ABOUT THE
LEARNING GAPS WIDENING. AND THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE. ALSO NOT
INCLUDED AS THE COULD COST OF
PROVIDING QUALITY PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT TO HELP OUR
EDUCATORS MASTER DIGITAL
CONTENT PEDAGOGY. BASICALLY HOW
TO TEACH ONLINE AND TECHNOLOGY
TOOLS TO SUCCESSFULLY ENSURE
LEARNING FROM A DISTANCE. WE
ARE INVESTING OVER THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS IRAQI FEDERAL
CARES ACT DOLLARS DISTRICT IN
THE QUALITY OF OUR DISTANCE
LEARNING EFFORTS AND TO SUPPORT
OUR EDUCATORS DURING THE
TRANSITION TO REMOTE TEACHING
AND LEARNING. AND NEARLY ALL OF
OUR TEACHERS COMPLETED TEN
HOURS OF TRAINING. IN THE
BASICS OF REMOTE TEACHING. AT
APPROXIMATELY 50% MORE SIGNED
UP FOR AN ADDITIONAL THIRTY
HOURS OF PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT. AND FINALLY NOT
INCLUDED IN THAT FIGURE. ARE
THE NECESSARY BECAUSE OF THE
COST NECESSARY FOR DATA SYSTEMS
DIGITAL CONTENT AND
COMMUNICATION TOOLS. ALL
TOGETHER IN LA UNIFIED WE USE
MORE THAN FOUR HUNDRED.
INSTRUCTIONAL APPLICATIONS SUCH
AS CLASSROOM DOJO SCHOOLOGY AND
ZOOM CURRENTLY BEING USED BY
OUR SCHOOLS. AND THE USAGE OF
THESE VERY IS MEANINGFUL ACROSS
MEANINGFULLY DIFFERENT ACROSS
GRADE LEVELS. AND OUR ABILITY
TO MEASURE STUDENT
PARTICIPATION AND GIVE TEACHERS
AND FAMILIES THE ABILITY TO
PROGRESS MONITOR STUDENT
PARTICIPATION CONTINUES TO BE
AN ONGOING CHALLENGE. IN THESE
NEW TIMES PROTECTIVE PERSONAL
PROTECT PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT LIKE THE ONE THAT
KEEPS FALLING OFF MY FACE. CAN
HELP KEEP A VIRUS AWAY. AND THE
DEVICE INTERNET AND A WELL
PREPARED EDUCATOR CAN PROTECT
AGAINST A LIFETIME OF A
LITERACY INTERVENTION AND
RELIANCE AND PUBLIC WELFARE.
THIS IS A CIVIL RIGHT EQUITY
ISSUE. WE WERE ABLE TO MAKE AN
EMERGENCY APPROPRIATION OF A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS. I'M
HERE TODAY TO ASK FOR A LONG
TERM SUSTAINABLE SOLUTION TO BE
ABLE TO MAINTAIN THAT
CONNECTION OVER YEARS AND OVER
DECADES. A STUDENT IN EVERY
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL SHOULD BE
GIVEN THE SAME BASIC EQUIPMENT
JUST AS EVERY STUDENTS ENTITLED
TO WALK THROUGH A CLASSROOM
DOOR. HAVE A TEXTBOOK. HAVE A
SUPPLY BOX OF PENCILS AND
CRAYONS. THAT'S HOW BASIC A
DEVICE AND INTERNET SHOULD BE
AND IF WE TRULY BELIEVE IN
EARLY EDUCATION AN
INTERGENERATIONAL
INTERGENERATIONAL FAMILY
ENGAGEMENT THIS OPPORTUNITY
SHOULD BE EXPANDED TO PRE K.
AND ADULT EDUCATION. TO EQUIP
EVERY STUDENT ACROSS THE STATE
WITH THE DEVICE AND INTERNET
THE ANNUAL COST WOULD BE ABOUT
SIX HUNDRED OR SEVEN HUNDRED
THOUSAND MILLION WE ESTIMATE.
AND EVERYTHING ELSE I MENTIONED
THE TECHNICAL SUPPORT THE
TRAINING THE TOOLS THE TRACKING
MEAN FOR OUT PARTICIPATION. WAS
WELL BEYOND THE DIGITAL DIVIDE
TO FOCUS ON WHAT WE MIGHT CALL
THE PARTICIPATORY DIVIDE. A LOS
FROM ACCESS SIMPLY ACCESS TO
HOW TO USE THAT ACCESS TO BE
CITY CLEAN GAUGED COLLAGEN
CAREER MINDED. AND TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
SO AS SUCH. WE URGE LEGISLATURE
AND THE STATE SUPERINTENDENT
DIGITAL DIVIDE TASK FORCE TO
DEVELOP A COMPREHENSIVE
STRATEGY TO ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES. FOR THE LONG TERM AND
FIRST TO SUSTAINABLE FUTURE. SO
THAT WE CAN ALL GET BACK TO THE
BUSINESS OF TEACHING AND
LEARNING. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU TO ALL
THE PRESENTERS ALL JUST MAKE A
FEW COMMENTS- I JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT AGAIN FOR MISS LINDA.
DARLING HAMMOND THE NEED TO
LOOK AT LIABILITY AS AN ISSUE I
KNOW IT'S BEEN BROUGHT UP BY
MISS SMITH TO THE OTHER PANEL
WITH THAT IS A SIGNIFICANT
ISSUE. I KNOW IS- YOU ENGAGE
WITH OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH I HOPE YOU YOU
BRING THAT UP BECAUSE- YOU
HIGHLIGHTED LEARNING WHICH I
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE. BUT
LEARNING CAN HAPPEN IF SCHOOLS
ARE GONNA BE OVER RUN WITH
LAWSUITS THOUGH THEY WILL
FINANCIALLY CRIPPLE. A SCHOOL
THE TECHNOLOGY- BROUGHT UP BY
A- NUMBER OF PEOPLE TODAY. WHAT
WE REALLY NEED IS A CONSISTENT
FUNDING SOURCES ONE AND
TECHNOLOGY AND THE
CONNECTIVITY- WE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA EMERGING
TECHNOLOGIES. I DON'T SEE MUCH.
GOING ON THERE. STATEWIDE THEN
WE ALSO PASSED A BILL- MAYBE
FIVE YEARS AGO OR SO MY BEEN
YOUR HUSBAND SO I DON'T KNOW
THAT BUT- IT HAD TO DO WITH AN
URBAN. AND RURAL. AND URBAN
RURAL ACCESS TO GETTING ONLINE
WE NEED TO TAKE A LOOK AT THAT
PROGRAM AND SEE IF IT NEEDS TO
BE ENHANCED. SO THEY CAN
ADEQUATELY FUND- SUCH AN EFFORT
AND I THIN THAT. WE NEED ABOUT
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS ON
AN ONGOING BASIS. TO FUND-
TECHNOLOGY AND ACCESS ACROSS
THE STATE. SOMETHING THAT
HASN'T BEEN BROUGHT UP I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU WANT TO COMMENT ON
THIS MISTER ALI HAMID OR ANYONE
REALLY ON THE PANEL. THAT'S
SPORTS WE NEED TO TAKE A LOOK
SPORTS WEAVER INCOME PATIENT
ASCII. THAT'S NOW SUPPORT PRO.
WELL. TE RESTARTED HELD OFF OF
WHAT HAPPENS DURING THE SO. DO
THEY PRACTICE DO THEY NOT
PRACTICE. THAT'S WHERE WE DO
NEED SOME CONSISTENCY ACROSS
THE STATE BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT
TO HAVE ONE SCHOOL DISTRICT
PRACTICING AND ANOTHER NOT
PRACTICING BECAUSE THAT GETS
INTO. SOME OF OUR MORE
COMPETITIVENESS ISSUES- I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU WANTED TO COMMENT
ON JUST SPORTS ALONE OR ANY OF.
THE TOPICS I JUST HIGHLIGHTED.
THANK YOU. I HATE TO BE THE
DISPOSITIVO VOICE ON SPORTS BUT
WE DID LOOK AT- INTERNATIONAL
NORMS AND STANDARDS IN SCHOOLS
IN COUNTRIES THAT HAVE GONE
BACK TO SCHOOL AND- TYPICALLY
THEY VERY MUCH ENCOURAGE KIDS
TO GO OUTSIDE AND HAVE RECESS
PARTICULARLY IN SMALL GROUPS
AND TO PLAY- AND NON CONTACT
SPORTS ARE TYPICALLY ENCOURAGE
BUT CONTACT SPORTS ARE NOT- AND
I AM SHAKING IN MY BOOTS TO BE
THE ONE TO SAY THAT- BUT IT IS
PRETTY CONSTANT ACROSS COUNTRY
IS THE OTHER THING. THAT IT IS
DID TYPICALLY JUST BRIDGE IS
OUR CROSS SCHOOL SPORTS BECAUSE
OF THE DIFFICULTIES IN TESTING
TRACKING AND MANAGING CONTACT.
GREAT THANK YOU AS OUR
CONVERSATIONS ARE GOING TO HAVE
TO CONTINUE TO HAVE BECAUSE I
KNOW IF YOU'RE- GETTING CALLS
LIKE I AM FROM SOME OF THE
FOLKS OUT THERE THAT IS THAT IS
A CONCERN OF PARENTS AND- AND
AGAIN I UNDERSTAND THE CONCERNS
THAT. WE ALL HAVE AND THAT IS
HEALTH CONCERNS- BUT AGAIN
THOSE DISCUSSIONS WILL HAVE TO
CONTINUE WITH THAT ARE THERE
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THAT HAVE QUESTIONS. GREAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CENTERS
LIKE CHAIR- FIRST I WANT TO
THANK MISS ONLY WHAT AN AMAZING
TEACHER YOU ARE AND ANY CHILD
THAT GOES TO YOUR- CLASSROOM
WHETHER IN PURCHASE PERSON OR
VIRTUALLY IS VERY LUCKY TO HAVE
YOU. SO THANK YOU SO MUCH. I
HAVE ONE QUESTION. AND I WILL
LET- IS- DARLING HAMMOND OR MS
YOSHIMOTO TELL WE DECIDE WHO
WANTS TO ANSWER IT. WOULD BE
HOUSE- A VERSION OF THE BUDGET
OUR VERSION OF THE BUDGET YES
IF THE LEGISLATURE DID. WHAT
ISSUES RELATED TO RE OPENING
THE SCHOOLS WERE NOT ADDRESSED
IN THATBUDGET. THAT WE NEED TO
LOOK AT SURE. I HAVE NOT HAD
ENOUGH. PLEASE TELL US WHERE
YOU WENT OVER THERE WE GO
YOU'RE ON NOW. YOU'RE ON. I'VE
HAD NOT HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO
FULLY REVIEW THE BUDGET- IN ITS
COMPLETENESS SO I'M NOT
ENTIRELY SURE BUT WHEN I SAW AN
EARLIER VERSION IT WAS UNCLEAR
WHERE THE DIGITAL DIVIDE WAS
GOING TO BE ADDRESSED- I WILL
BE GLAD TO GET BACK TO YOU WITH
THE FULLER ANSWER AFTER REVIEW
THE BUDGET. THE GREAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU SENATOR
OTHER QUESTIONS MISS SMITH. AND
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- I TO
SHARE JUST THAT THE GRATITUDE
FOR MISS ONLY- AND YOUR PASSION
AS A TEACHER AND YOUR
COMMITMENT TO YOUR STUDENTS AND
THANK YOU FOR THAT EXEMPLARY
WORK AND THANK YOU FOR REALLY.
VERY CLEARLY PAINTING A
PORTRAIT OF JUST HOW STEEP MANY
OF THESE BARRIERS ARE THAT OUR
OUR STUDENTS FACE DAY IN DAY
OUT PANDEMIC NOT WITHSTANDING
FOR THOSE CHILDREN THAT YOU
TEACH TO JUST TO MAKE IT TO
SCHOOL EVERY DAY AND THEN IN A
NORMAL ENVIRONMENT IS A STRETCH
AND IN THESE TIMES- AN
EXTRAORDINARY STRETCHED I THANK
YOU FOR THAT AND I THANK YOU
FOR DOING EVERYTHING THAT YOU
COULD. TO CLOSE THAT GAP WE
APPRECIATE THAT I'M FOR MS
YOSHIMOTO FROM- LA UNIFIED I
ALSO APPRECIATE THE EXTENT TO
WHICH YOU DELINEATED THE VERY
REAL COST OF IMPLEMENTING I
DISTANCE LEARNING WHAT SCALE
ACROSS THE STATE AND THE
BARRIERS THAT STILL EXIST- AND
THEN MY QUESTIONS FOR DAR HIM A
I. THAT YOU I REALLY HAVE HAVE
LEAN INTO THE SIGNIFICANT IN
THE CHANGE IN PEDAGOGY AROUND
NOW MOTIVATING AND INSTRUCTING
STUDENTS TO BE- SELF MOTIVATED
AND TO BE DUE TO BE ABLE TO
MANEUVER MORSE WRECKED AND
LEARNING BUT IT ALSO OCCURS TO
ME THAT THAT A MISSING PIECE OF
THIS MIGHT BE. THE TEN THAT WE
CAN PROVIDE. PARENTS TO ASSIST
THIS MOMENT I'M WONDERING IF
ANYTHING INTO. FOR THAT WE ABLE
TO PUSH OUT. IT STATE WIDE AND
PERHAPS EVEN THROUGH SOME OF
OUR NONPROFIT PARTNERS AND
AFFILIATES. TO ENGAGE OUR OUR
PARENTS IN THIS PARTNERSHIP.
THERE ARE SO MANY GOOD
RESOURCES BOTH FOR PARENTS AND
FOR EDUCATORS- WITHIN OUR
STATE- ONE THAT'S BEING MORE
FULLY DEVELOPED AS WIDE OPEN
SCHOOL- ONE OF THE THINGS WE
WANT DISTRICTS TO DO IS DEVELOP
IN THESE INSTRUCTIONAL
CONTINUITY PLANS. ACCESS OF FOR
BOTH PARENTS AND EDUCATORS AND
KIDS. TO ALL OF THE MATERIALS
THAT WILL BE USED SO THAT THEY
CAN TOGETHER- BECAUSE IT NOW IS
THAT PARENTS AND- TEACHERS ARE
TEACHING KIDS TOGETHER-
TOGETHER UNDERSTAND- WHAT'S
AVAILABE TO THEM- SO IN THE
GUIDANCE THAT IS. BEING
DEVELOPED FOR DISTANCE A
BLENDED LEARNING WE WILL BE-
IDENTIFYING WAYS THAT PARENTS
CAN ALSO LEARN HOW TO
SUPPORTERS STUDENTS- THERE'S
SOME WONDERFUL ITEMS ALSO. OF
PERRANCE OF. OF STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES PARENTS OF
STUDENTS AT DIFFERENT AGE
LEVELS. AND THE- MATERIALS
OFTEN CONNECT WE MAY WANT TO
BEGIN TO BE OFFERING.
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES TO PARENTS
TEACHERS GATHER. AT THE SAME IT.
THIS IS WHERE ARMENIAN. AND
WILL TO CONTINUE IN DISTANCE
LEARNING- OR WHERE THERE ARE
YOU KNOW KIND OF LONG TERM-
POSSIBILITIES THAT THAT WILL BE
A MAJOR FORM OF LEARNING SO I'M
GLAD YOU ASKED THAT QUESTION
IT'S A REALLY IMPORTANT ONE.
THANK YOU. THREE OF MISTER
MCCARTY THANK YOU AT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND I APOLOGIZE
FOR MISSING MOST OF THE
PRESENTATION AS ONE OF THE
FOLLOW UP ON THIS QUESTION THAT
CENTER LEYVA APPS BUT MAYBE THE
OTHER SIDE OF THE COIN BUDGET.
OUR BUDGET- FOR LINDA DARLING
HAMMOND WAS ESSENTIALLY THE ONE
THAT WE ANNOUNCE TEN DAYS AGO
WHICH BASICALLY- WOULD REJECT
THE CUTS TO L. CFF IN OUR
SCHOOLS AND BASICALLY FULLY
FUND OUR SCHOOLS WITH THE ONE
TIME MONEY. THAT WE GET THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT- GRANTED WE
DO WE HAVE THAT THAT INITIAL
WOULD DEFERRALS FOR THE NEXT
YEAR BUT FOR THIS YEAR. ROUGHLY
KEEP SCHOOL FUNDING WHOLE. SO
REALLY THE QUESTION IS YOU YOU
SAW WAS IN THE GOVERNOR'S NEWLY
REVISE I KNOW THIS IS DIFFICULT
DECISION FOR YOU BECAUSE YOU
ARE. KIND OF THE GOVERNOR'S
TEAM AND DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
HAS A DIFFERENT JOB. BUT DO YOU
HONESTLY THINK THAT IF WE HAD
TO ACCEPT WHAT'S IN THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE WHAT'S MY
ARE SITTING THERE STILL PUSHING
THEIR NEGOTIATIONS TODAY. WHICH
IF WE DON'T GET THE FEDERAL
FUNDS WOULD HAVE THESE. HUGE
CUTS TO OUR PUBLIC SCHOOLS THAT
THEY COULD DO. ALL WHICH WE
SPENT THE LAST TWO HOURS
TALKING ABOUT HE SENSUALLY.
SCHOOLS ARE GONNA BE DOING
MORE. THEY'RE NOT GOING TO BE
DOING LAST WHAT THEY'VE DONE
BEFORE. WITH DISTANCE LEARNING
WHAT SEPARATION ALL THIS PAST
WE'RE ASKING OUR- BY. A
TEACHERS TO DO. TO DO REALLY.
REALITY IF WE HAD TWO X. WHAT
WAS THE GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE.
THAT ARE SCHOOL DISTRICTS ONE
THOUSAND OF THEM ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. COULD PULL IT OFF
AND ACHIEVE WHAT. THE
SUPERINTENDENT IN YOU OUTLINED
WITH NEEDED TO BE DONE. FOR OUR
KIDS THIS COMING YEAR. WELL I
THINK EVERYBODY IS VERY ARE
PUSHING VERY HARD FOR THE
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL RESOURCES
THAT NEED TO BE THERE AS I
UNDERSTOOD THE MAY REVISE IT
TRIGGERED BACK IN. AS SOON AS
THOSE FEDERAL FUNDS ARRIVED
THE- ADDITIONAL- FUNDS NEEDED
TO KEEP US WHOLE- I KNOW THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE IS WORKING
HARD WITH FOLKS IN WASHINGTON
TO GET THAT- ADDITIONAL MONEY
ALLOCATED. BUT WE ALL KNOW THAT
EVEN WHEN THAT HAPPENS- THERE
ARE GOING TO BE ONGOING
CHALLENGES OF SCHOOLS. SO WE'RE
GOING TO BE NEEDING TO PLAN FOR
RECOVERY ACTS- YOU KNOW.
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR- THIS IS A
BIGGER- HITS TO. A STATE
REVENUES THEN THE GREAT
RECESSION WAS- IT'S- A TERRIBLE
SITUATION TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
BE. FISCALLY SOLVENT AND TO
START SCHOOL PLEASE DAYS. IT'S
ONE OF THE REASONS I THINK
THAT. UP YEAH DISTRICTS ARE
GOING TO MAKE THESE DECISIONS
ABOUT WHETHER TO BE- IT SINCE.
THERE'S GOING TO BE IN IN PLACE
IN BROKEN MORTAR. CLASS AND I
AM WHY IT'S SO IMPORTANT THAT
WE- ORGANIZE BOTH THE DID YOU
RESEARCH FOR EVERY SINGLE
FEATURING KID. AND WHY WE NEED
TO ORGANIZE THE- SCHOOL
RESOURCES IN THE SENSE OF
INTEGRATED STUDENT SUPPORTS
THAT ARE GOING TO BE NEEDED.
IRRESPECTIVE OF WHETHER WE'RE
IN R OUT OF BRICK AND MORTAR
AT VARIOUS POINTS IN THE YEAR.
BUT I GUESS WHAT I'M TRYING TO
GET IS TO THE BUDGET QUESTION
THAT THAT THE CENTER ASKED TO
IS IT IF WE DON'T GET THE
FEDERAL FUNDS. THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET WOULD HAVE THESE
AUTOMATIC CUTS AND WE WOULD.
FIND SCHOOLS AND HAVE TO GO AND
GO THROUGH A DEFERRAL SO
ESSENTIALLY SCHOOLS WOULD GET
FUNDED. IF WE DIDN'T GET THE
FEDERAL FUNDS DO YOU THINK THAT
THE SCHOOL COULD PULL IT OFF
THEN IT CANNOT AND BASICALLY.
WHERE ARE CAN ATTEND TRYING
HERE. AND WHAT'S TO. IN ABOUT.
DISTRICT JULIE IS MORE WHAT
THEY CURRENTLY DO AND THEY WILL
BEGIN LAST MY SO HOW WOULD THAT
WORK IF WE ARE SAID OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. LESS. I THINK THERE
IS. NO DOUBT THAT FEWER
DISTRICTS WOULD BE ABLE TO
OFFER BRICK AND MORTAR-
TEACHING AND LEARNING IN
PHYSICAL CLASSROOMS- IF THERE
IS NOT AS MUCH MONEY AVAILABLE
THE AMOUNTS OF RESOURCE
AVAILABLE IS GOING TO BE
RELATED TO THE EXTENT TO WHICH-
FOUGHT IN CLASSROOM BRICK AND
MORTAR INSTRUCTION CAN OCCUR.
THANK YOU I THINK THE ANSWER IS
THAT WE KNOW THAT WE CAN'T THAT
AS SOON MARK SCHOOL DISTRICTS
CAN DO MORE WITH LESS AND
THAT'S WHY. THE SEND THE
ASSEMBLY ADOPTED A BUDGET
YESTERDAY WHICH WOULD SAY
FEDERAL MONEY OR NO FEDERAL
MONEY WE CAN'T UNDER FUNDERS
SCHOOLS BECAUSE- ONE IT'S NOT
GONNA WORK WILL RASKIN THE DO
INTO WE NEED OUR SCHOOLS BE
FUND ALSO. FAMILIES CAN GO BACK
TO WORK AND WE CAN HAVE SCHOOLS
THAT ARE WORKING IN. SIX
MILLION KIDS COULD HAVE A
FUNCTIONAL- HOUSEHOLD SO THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ADD- MISTER
MCCARTY APPRECIATE YOUR PASSION
AND YOUR SUPPORT FOR BUDGET.
THAT SUPPORTS ALL THE THINGS
WERE DEMANDING OF OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND I JUST WANNA MAKE
NOTE OF THE FACT THAT. THE
STRONG HIM AS PRESIDENT OF THE
STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION REALLY
DOESN'T HAVE A- A ROLE IN THE
BUDGET PROCESS- BUT REACTS TO
IT. AND I THINK THE FACT OF THE
MATTER IS WHETHER OR NOT WE
HAVE MORE MONEY OR LESS MANY
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE GOING. TO
HAVE TO DO MORE WHETHER THEY
HAVE MORE OR THEY HAVE LOST
BECAUSE THESE ARE DIFFICULT
TIMES AND WE ALL HAVE. CAN WE
CAN'T JUST SAY WELL WE DON'T
HAVE THE MONEY WE'RE NOT GONNA
REMARKS. AND YOU WOULDN'T
SUPPORT AT. BUT THESE ARE TOUGH
TIMES AND WE ALL NEED A WHOLE
HECK. WELL STAY SIX FEET APART.
RIGHT AND WE IT WORK THIS OUT.
SO WITH THAT MISTER ALI DID YOU
HAVE A QUESTION. NOW THERE ARE
NO MORE QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. I WITH THAT THANK
YOU TO OUR PANEL MISTER LANG
HAMMOND. I THANK YOU JAMIE
ONLY. WHEN OUR GREAT MIDDLE
SCHOOL TEACHERS A GREAT
EXAMPLE. AND ALISON YOSHIMOTO
TOWER YOU FROM A LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT THANK
YOU ALL. FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
I'M GOING TO MOVE OR THIRD
PANEL. OUR THIRD PANEL- IT OF
THE DAY FOCUSES ON STUDENTS
SUPPORTS. THAT WILL NEED TO BE
IN PLACE WHEN SCHOOL RE OPENS
IN THE FALL. A REMINDER THAT WE
WILL BE HOLDING OUR QUESTIONS
UNTIL THE END OF THE PANEL
OFFERS SPEAKERS ANTHONY FLOORS
ALVAREZ STUDENT MANUAL ARTS
HIGH SCHOOL. IN LOS ANGELES
ANTHONY WILL BE JOINING US BY
TELEPHONE. BY TELEPHONE- IN
ANTHONY ARE YOU THERE YOU MAY
PROCEED WHEN READY. IF YOU ARE
THERE. WE'LL GIVE ANTHONY FOR
AS OUR AS- OUR STUDENTS- MANUAL
ARTS HIGH SCHOOL A MINUTE OR
TWO TO COME ONLINE IF NOT WE'LL
PROCEED OUR NEXT. THIS.
OUR
PHONES WERE DOWN SO THIS MAY BE
A REFLECTION OF THAT BECAUSE
THEY MAY STILL BE DOWN. THIS IS
YOUR MODERATOR SIR I DO NOT
SHOW HIM IN THE QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. OKAY THANK YOU. BOB WHY
DON'T WE MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT
WITNESS- ON JACK IS OUR NEXT
SPEAKER IS JENNIFER PACK WITH
THE PARTNERSHIP FOR CHILDREN
AND YOUTH. MISS PACKAGE HERE
WITH US IN THE- IN THE ROOM.
AND YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN READY
THANK HIM FOR BEING HERE TODAY
MISS JENNIFER PACK. GOOD
MORNING THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
I'M REALLY EXCITED TO BE HERE
TO TALK TO YOU A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE ROLE OF OUR AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS IN CALIFORNIA.
DURING THE COVERT ENVIRONMENT
AND IN THE RE OPENING OF
SCHOOL- MY ORGANIZATION THE
PARTNERSHIP FOR CHILDREN AND
YOUTH. REPRESENTS THE
CALIFORNIA AFTER SCHOOL
ADVOCACY ALLIANCE WHICH IS OUR
MANY AFTER SCHOOL PROVIDERS
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
ACTUALLY GONNA TAKE THIS OFF IF
THAT'S OKAY FOR SPEAKING. OUR
AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS HAVE
ALWAYS BEEN A CRITICAL
COMPONENT OF OUR EDUCATION
SYSTEM. BUT IN THIS NEW
ENVIRONMENT WHERE OUT OF SCHOOL
TIME IS LITERALLY ALL THE TIME.
THERE'S BEEN A BRIGHT LIGHT
SHONE ON HOW IMPORTANT THESE
PROGRAMS REALLY ARE FOR OUR
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES. SINCE
OUR SCHOOL BUILDINGS CLOSE DOWN
OUR AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS HAVE
BEEN PERFORMING A WIDE RANGE OF
SERVICES DEPENDING ON THE NEEDS
OF THEIR SCHOOL COMMUNITY.
THEY'VE BEEN PROVIDING VIRTUAL
IN RICHMOND ACTIVITIES THEY'VE
BEEN SUPPORTING MEAL
DISTRIBUTION SOME HAVE PROVIDED
SUPERVISION TO THE CHILDREN OF
ESSENTIAL WORKERS. MANY HAVE
BEEN CHECKING IN WITH KIDS
REGULARLY TO SEE HOW THEY'RE
DOING AND WHAT THEY'RE NEEDING.
AARON SACRAMENTO FOR EXAMPLE
THE CHIP THE SACRAMENTO CHINESE
COMMUNITY SERVICE CENTER HAS
BEEN PROVIDING TWO HOURS OF
VIRTUAL IN RICHMOND EVERY
SINGLE DAY. IT INCLUDES
PHYSICAL ACTIVITY STEAM
LITERACY SOCIAL EMOTIONAL
LEARNING AND NUTRITION LESSONS
IN LOS ANGELES A GROUP CALLED
WHAT CRAFT RANGERS DEVELOPED AN
ONLINE LEARNING PLATFORM. THAT
CAN BE ACCESSED THROUGH CELL
PHONES AND IT HAS ENRICHED AND
ACTIVITIES FOR KIDS AND SUPPORT
RESOURCES FOR FAMILIES WHICH IS
REACHING SEVEN THOUSAND
FAMILIES ACROSS THAT REGION.
THERE ARE MANY MORE EXAMPLES OF
THIS KIND OF CREATIVITY AND
COMMITMENT THAT I DON'T HAVE
TIME TO GO INTO TODAY. BUT ONE
THING THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
TO EMPHASIZE ABOUT THESE
PROGRAMS IS THAT THE STAFF
TYPICALLY COME FROM THE SAME
COMMUNITIES AS THE STUDENTS
THEY SERVE. SO THEY HAVE
RELATIONSHIPS. WITH THE KIDS
AND THE FAMILIES. THAT MAKES
THEM EXCEPTIONALLY VALUABLE IN
THIS CONTEXT AND ESPECIALLY
AROUND THIS VERY REAL CHALLENGE
OF CONNECTING WITH DISCONNECTED
KIDS. AS WE THINK ABOUT HOW TO
RE OPEN IN THE NEW SCHOOL YEAR
WITH DRAMATICALLY ADJUSTED
SCHOOL SCHEDULES AND THE NEED
FOR SMALLER GROUPS AND PHYSICAL
DISTANCE THING AND INTENSE
NEEDS FOR SOCIAL CONNECTION. WE
HAVE TO LEAN ON OUR AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS IN A VERY BIG
WAY. WITH CLASS TIME
POTENTIALLY HAPPENING AND SHIPS
ARE AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS CAN
ALSO OPERATE IN SHIFTS. AND
PROGRAMS CAN USE THAT TIME TO
HELP KIDS COMPLETE CLASS WORK
OR WITH HOMEWORK ASSIGNMENTS TO
DO ENRICHMENT ACTIVITIES.
INCLUDING PHYSICAL ACTIVITY AND
FOCUS ON SOCIAL AND EMOTIONAL
NEEDS. EVERY SCHOOL CASE
MANAGER. OR SO I LEADERSHIP
TEAM AND A MEMBER OF THE AFTER
SCHOOL TEAM TO HELP INFORM
WHAT'S GOING ON WITH INDIVIDUAL
KIDS AND DEVELOP PLANS FOR
SUPPORT. I SUGGEST THIS BECAUSE
MANY OF OUR AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS ALREADY FUNCTION LIKE
COMMUNITY SCHOOLS GIVEN THEIR
RELATIONSHIPS WITH OTHER
COMMUNITY AGENCIES AND THE
FAMILIES. CURRENTLY WE FUND
PROGRAMS FOR A THREE HOUR UNIT
OF SERVICE SO IF PROGRAMS ARE
CALLED UPON TO SUPPORT KIDS
THROUGHOUT THE DAY. WE HAVE TO
CONSIDER HOW ADDITIONAL HOURS
ARE GOING TO BE PAID FOR.
IDEALLY WE WOULD BE INCREASING
OUR INVESTMENT IN THE AFTER
SCHOOL EDUCATION AND SAFETY
PROGRAM TO MAKE THIS POSSIBLE
WE ALSO NEED TO MAKE SURE
THERE'S ONGOING OPERATIONAL
FLEXIBILITY TO ENSURE PROGRAMS
CAN BE RESPONSIVE TO THE NEEDS
OF EACH SCHOOL COMMUNITY AND
THE SCHEDULE THEY DECIDE UPON.
ON TOP OF ADDITIONAL HOURS WE
ALSO NEED TO CONSIDER THE
SUPPLIES EQUIPMENT AND TRAINING
NEEDED FOR THIS WORK FORCE IN
ORDER TO KEEP THEMSELVES AND
KIDS SAFE. HOWEVER THE GOVERNOR
HAS PROPOSED A ONE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR CUT TO THE ASUS
PROGRAM. WHICH IN A NORMAL YEAR
WOULD MEAN MORE THAN SIXTY
THOUSAND STUDENTS WOULD LOSE
THEIR AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAM. BUT
IN THIS CONTEXT WITH COSTS
GOING UP AND NEEDS BEING SO
INTENSE WE COULD LOSE A WHOLE
LOT MORE THAN THAT. AND LET'S
BE CLEAR ABOUT WHICH KIDS WOULD
LOSE OUT NINE OUT OF TEN
CHILDREN SERVED BY THE ASUS
PROGRAM OUR CHILDREN OF COLOR.
30% ARE ENGLISH LANGUAGE
LEARNERS. AND 25% OF
CALIFORNIA'S HOMELESS STUDENTS
ARE SERVED BY THESE PROGRAMS.
THE FAMILIES OF THESE CHILDREN
ARE THE ONES WHO HAVE BEEN
HARDEST HIT BY THE IMPACTS OF
CODE. AND THEY NEED THEIR AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS AND THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS PRESERVED. THE
GOVERNOR STATED IN HIS REMARKS
ON THE MAY REVISED THAT WE NEED
TO INVEST IN STRATEGIES TO
MITIGATE LEARNING LOSSES. TAKE
CARE OF THE SOCIAL EMOTIONAL
NEEDS OF OUR KIDS. AND GET THE
ECONOMY MOVING SAFELY. OUR
AFTER SCHOOL SYSTEM IN
CALIFORNIA DOES ALL OF THESE
THINGS AND WE SHOULD BE GROWING
THIS INVESTMENT RATHER THAN
TEARING IT DOWN. AS YOU ALL
KNOW VERY WELL THE ASUS PROGRAM
IS INCREDIBLY COST EFFICIENT WE
PAY OUR PROVIDERS. EIGHT
DOLLARS AN EIGHTY EIGHT CENTS
PER CHILD PER DAY. WHICH IS
BARELY ENOUGH TO PAY STAFF THE
MINIMUM WAGE. WE ARE
EXCEPTIONALLY GRATEFUL TO THE
LEGISLATURE FOR REJECTING THIS
PROPOSED CUT. WHICH JUST MAKES
NO SENSE WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHAT
WE ARE FACING IN THE COMING
YEAR WE NEED ALL THE SKILLED
CARING ADULTS WE CAN FIND TO
TAKE CARE OF OUR KIDS AS WE
FACE INTENSIFIED NEEDS AND
ADJUSTED SCHEDULES WE NEED TO
LEAN ON OUR COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS ARE CITY PARK AND
REC PROGRAMS ARE LIBRARIES. AND
MORE THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU MISS PAC.
GREAT JOB OF DESCRIBING WHAT
AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS DO THEY
JUST DON'T KEEP KIDS BUSY WHICH
IS IMPORTANT AS AFTER SCHOOL
HOURS BECAUSE YOU KNOW WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN KIDS ARE BUSY
RIGHT BUT THEY PROVIDE ACADEMIC
SUPPORT FOOD MANY OF THE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS ASUS PROGRAMS.
ALSO HAVE- HAVE THAT PROVIDE
SOME REAL ARE PART OF THE
SUMMER MEALS PROGRAMS WHICH WAS
EXPANDED TO THE COVERT NINETEEN
SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PASSIONATE- DEFENSE AND OFFENSE
PROGRAMS THANK YOU. WITH THAT
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO- JARED
CALL WITH THE CALIFORNIA FOOD
POLICY ADVOCATES AND HE IS WITH
US IN THE HEARING ROOM AREAS.
MR CALL YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN
READY THANK YOU TERRA DONALD
AND- MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
REALLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
TODAY MY TESTIMONY IS FOCUSED
ON THE IMPACT OF COVER NINETEEN
ON CHILD HUNGER. AND SCHOOL THE
TRIP- GERALD ON APPRECIATED
YOUR COMMENTS- IN YOUR OPENING
REMARKS ABOUT THE MODERN DAY
SUPER LINES THAT WERE SEEN AS
SCHOOLS OF REALLY- REALLY
STEPPED UP TO THE PLATE- ALONG
WITH FOOD BANKS BUT BUT SCHOOLS
GOING ABOVE AND BEYOND- TO MEET
THE INCREASE NEED I'LL TRY TO
BE BRIEF IN MY DESCRIPTION OF
SORT OF THE PROBLEM AND FOCUS
ON THREE PARTICULAR
OPPORTUNITIES THAT WE- WOULD
LIKE TO SEIZE OVER THE NEXT FEW
WEEKS AND MONTHS. TO ENSURE
THAT STUDENTS HAVE ADEQUATE
NUTRITION NOT JUST OVER THE
SUMMER BUT- WHEN SCHOOLS
REOPENED SO I'LL JUST START
WITH ONE I THINK VERY
COMPELLING TO STICK ABOUT
OVERNIGHT THE IMPACT ON FOOD.
THAT THAT IS THAT A NASH SURVEY
SHOW THAT ONE SIX MOTHERS WITH
CHILDREN UNDER TWELVE REPORTED.
QUOTE THE CHIP IN MY HOUSEHOLD
NOT EATING IT OFF BECAUSE WE
JUST COULDN'T AFFORD IT FOOD.
ONE IN SIX MOTHERS WITH KIDS
UNDER TWELVE ACROSS THE COUNTRY
REPORTING KIDS ARE RESET NO
THIS WAS A CRITICAL ROLE
NOURISHED STUDENTS AND THAT
EVEN BEFORE HIT 6% OF OUR
STUDENTS REPLIED ON FREE REDUCE.
MEALS AND WE DO EXPECT THOSE
NUMBERS ARE RIGHT WILL BE TO
SELL ON THE IT'S IN A- SCHOOL
ME. WELL DOT. THIRTY IN AND AS
WE THE SPEAKERS TODAY STUDENTS
FROM INCOME HOW AND STE OF
COLOR FACE US OPPORTUNITY GAPS
AND ACHIEVEMENT GAPS AND
CLOSING THOSE GAPS REQUIRES-
EQUITY AND DISTRIBUTION OF
RESOURCES INCLUDING THINGS LIKE
SCHOOL MEALS SO AND WE'VE ALSO
HEARD ABOUT THE PHYSICAL STRAIN
THAT DISTRICTS ARE FEELING AND
SCHOOL NUTRITION PROGRAMS I
THINK IN. IN PARTICULAR GIVEN-
THE CAUGHT THE TERRIBLE
COMBINATION OF INCREASED COST
DUE TO NEW OPERATIONAL-
IMPERATIVES AND THE DECREASE
REVENUES DUE TO FEWER MEALS
BEING SERVED BUT- IN ORDER TO
PREVENT- HUNGER AMONG
CALIFORNIA KIDS WE MUST
ADEQUATELY FUND THE PROVISION
OF MEALS AND ENSURE THAT
CHILDREN CAN READILY ACCESS
THOSE MEALS. GIVEN OUT ALL A
MOVE ON TO THE THREE
OPPORTUNITIES WE SEE A
CALIFORNIA FOOD POLICY
ADVOCATES AND AMONG OUR ANTI
HUNGER PARTNERS. THE FIRST IS
TO PAIR- EXTENDED FEDERAL
FLEXIBILITY EASE- WITH YOU
STATE POLICY- AS THE CHAIR
MENTIONED- THERE WAS A LOT OF
FLEXIBILITY OFFERED BY THE USDA%
THE US DEPARTMENT OF
AGRICULTURE- TO GRANT WAIVERS
THAT ENABLE ELEAZAR TO SERVE
MEALS IN THAT GRAB AND GO
STYLE- AND THEN EARLY IN IN MID
MARCH- GOVERNOR NEWSOME ISSUED
EXECUTIVE ORDER AND TWENTY SIX
TWENTY. WHICH TO STAND STATE
EDUCATION FUNDING DURING THE
COVERED RELATED SCHOOL CLOSURES
AND ALSO SUPPORTED THE
CONTINUED MEAL SERVICE. SINCE
THEN AS I SAID WE SEEN IT
SCHOOLS TO THE INCREDIBLE WORK
OF OFFERING FREE SCHOOL MEALS
TO CHILDREN IN THE HELLO THIS
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY. NOW
USDA RECENTLY EXTENDED A LOT OF
THOSE KEY WAIVERS THROUGH
AUGUST THIRTIETH BUT THERE
REMAINS NO FEDERAL OR STATE
POLICY GUARANTEEING ACCESS TO
MEALS FOR STUDENTS DURING THE
SUMMER. IN A TYPICAL YEAR WE DO
ALWAYS SEE FOOD INSECURITY
AMONG LOW INCOME KIDS SPIKE
DURING THE SUMMER SUMMER
FEEDING PROGRAMS I DO
INCREDIBLE WORK BUT ARE ONLY
ABLE TO REACH IN A TYPICAL YEAR
ABOUT FIFTEEN PERCENT. OF
CHILDREN IN NEED AND WE DO
EXPECT THIS YEAR TO BE WORSE.
AT ALL THAT SAID WE CERTAINLY
THANK THE LEGISLATURE FOR
INCLUDING AND THEIR BUDGET
PROPOSAL HUNDRED AND TWELVE
POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS IN
FEDERAL DISCRETIONARY FUNDING
TO SUPPORT MAIL SERVICE IN
MARIN WE STRONGLY URGE THE
ADMINISTRATIVE. TO INCLUDE THAT
VERSION IN THEIR FINAL BUDGET
WERE ALSO CALLING FOR A
CONTINUE EXPECTED. OF MEALS OR
DURING THE SUMMER SO THAT KIDS
CAN A GARY. ACTS TO THAT MY
NEEDED NUTRITION DURING THE
SUMMER MONTHS. THAT'S OUR FIRST
OPPORTUNITY OUR SECOND IS-
PANDEMIC EBT. OR P. B. T. HAS
ALL REFER TO IT IN MY REMARKS
OF PVC IS A NEW BUT TEMPORARY
FEDERAL PROGRAM TO HELP. I'M
LEASE PURCHASE FOOD- THAT THEY-
WHAT SCHOOLS ARE CLOSED DURING
COVER NINETEEN IT'S INTENDED TO
HELP REPLACE THOSE LOST MEALS
AT SCHOOLS THAT KIDS ARE
ACCESSING DURING SCHOOL
CLOSURES. SO KIDS ARE ELIGIBLE
FOR P. B. T. IF THEY'RE
ELIGIBLE FOR FREE OR REDUCED
PRICE MEALS WHICH MEANS THEY'RE
ALSO ELIGIBLE REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS WHICH IS
OBVIOUSLY VERY IMPORTANT IN OUR
IMMIGRANT RICH STATE. BUT THE
DEADLINE TO APPLY FOR P. B. T.
FOR FAMILIES IS JUST THE END OF
THIS MONTH IS COMING UP IN JUST
TWO WEEKS ON JUNE THIRTIETH. SO
WE'RE CALLING ON ELEAZAR IN CD
TO HELP. BY CONDUCTING TARGETED
OUTREACH TO FAMILIES LIVING IN
THOUGH THEY NEED TO APPLY AND
ALSO WE'RE CALLING ON FEDERAL
LEADERS TO EXTEND AND EXPAND
PBC THROUGH THE COURSE OF THE
CRISIS AND WE WOULD INVITE. AND
URGE THE STATE LEGISLATURE AND
ADMINISTRATION TO DO JUST THE
SAME IN CALLING ON FEDERAL
LEADERS TO EXTEND AND EXPAND
PBT WHICH IS ONE OF THE MOST
PROMISING SOLUTIONS TO THIS
HUNGER SPECTER ODD TO THE
SCHOOL CLOSURES. AND THE THIRD
OPPORTUNITIES TO REALLY
MAXIMIZE UPTAKE OF WHAT'S
CALLED THE COMMUNITY
ELIGIBILITY PROVISION OR C. E.
P. C. E. P. IS A FEDERALLY
AUTHORIZED OPTION FOR PROVIDING
TWO MEALS FREE OF CHARGE TO ALL
STUDENTS EACH DAY. WITHOUT THE
NEED TO FILL OUT AN APPLICATION.
A WE HAVE MANY SCHOOLS TO BE LA.
TO TAKE UP SEE P. THIS. YEAR
BECAUSE IT'S TIED TO- STUDENT
NEED. AND THAT'S YOUR OF
STUDENTS ARE ACCESSING PROGRAMS
LIKE HOW FRESH AND MEDICARE
WHICH WE KNOW WE'RE SPIKING
RIGHT NOW DUE TO THE ECONOMIC
DOWNTURN. SO THE DEADLINE FOR
SCHOOLS TO APPLY TO OPERATE C.
P. HAS BEEN EXTENDED BY USDA TO
AUGUST THIRTY FIRST. AND SO WE
REALLY REALLY ARE URGING
SCHOOLS TO SEIZE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO MAXIMIZE THE
REACH OF SCHOOL MEALS WHICH
ALSO DRAWS DOWN ENHANCED
FEDERAL FUNDING. SO WE'RE
RECOMMENDING THAT CD E. ISSUE-
GUIDANCE STRONGLY ENCOURAGING
ELEAZAR TO APPLY FOR C. P. THIS
YEAR BEFORE THAT AUGUST THIRTY
FIRST DEADLINE. AND PROVIDE
TARGETED TECHNICAL ASSISTANT.
DELEGATES TO ENSURE THE
BROADEST POSSIBLE UP TAKE. TO
FEED OUR KIDS AND AGAIN
MAXIMIZE THAT FEDERAL FUNDING
DRIVE DOWN. AND THAT CONCLUDES
MY TESTIMONY AND I'M THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
AND HAPPY TO QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU THINK AND I'M SURE AND I'M
WELCOME COMING UP AND I'LL PAY
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
RECOGNIZE WHAT IS AN GOING OFF
THEIR SCHOOLS AND FOOD. THE
FACT AS I ALLUDED TO EARLIER
THAT YOU WILL SEE LINES OF
CARS- WITH KIDS IN THEM. LINING
UP TO RECEIVE FOOD BECAUSE-
THEY DON'T HAVE THE MEANS TO
PURCHASERS THEY CAN OBTAIN FOR.
AND IT'S RATHER TRAGIC TO SEE
THAT SIDE BUT IT IS REAL IT IS
HAPPENING IN THE STATE. TO DAY-
AND I WANT TO COMPLIMENT. THE
SUPER HAD A PUBLIC INSTRUCTION
HIS OFFICE WAS VERY- VERY
EFFECTIVE IN SIGNING UP
DISTRICTS FOR THE SUMMER MEALS
PROGRAM SOME LAGGED. AND THEIR
PARTICIPATION BUT WERE ABLE TO
GET SIGNED UP IN A VERY.
EXPEDITIOUS FASHION I MEAN I
THINK ON THE TUNE OF LIKE SEVEN
HUNDRED. IN A VERY QUICK MANNER
SO CONGRATULATIONS- TO THE- TO
THE SUPERINTENDENT'S OFFICE FOR
THE FINE WORK THEY DID. AND I
JUST DO WANNA WORKING WE TALK
ABOUT ASUS PROBABLY YOUR YOUR
YOUR YOUR BIGGEST CHAMPION IS
IN THIS ROOM IT'S MISTER
MCCARTY. WHO CHAIRS BUDGET SUB
TO IS DONE A GREAT JOB. OF
DEFENDING THE PROGRAM AND ALSO
GOING ON OFFENSE TO ENSURE THAT
THIS BODY. BOTH BODIES NOT
RESTORE FUNDING. TO THE ASUS
PROGRAM AS HAS- THE GOOD
SENATOR TO MY RIGHT. SO WITH
THAT- IT. IS ANTHONY FLORES
ALVAREZ ON THE PHONE. HEARING I
CAN HEAR YOU. YOUR LIFE. HI
THANK YOU I CAN I BEGIN YOU MAY
YOU MAY BEGIN. GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIRAND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THIS
IMPORTANT OPPORTUNITY I'M HERE
REPRESENTING NOT ONLY THE
AMERICAN CIVIL LIBERTIES UNION
OF CALIFORNIA THE COUNTER
STUDENTS STATEWIDE. TODAY I
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT ONE CONCERN
HAS ONLY BEEN EXACERBATED BY
CALLED THE NINETEEN STUDENT
MENTAL HEALTH. STUDENTS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA ARE CURRENTLY
NAVIGATING WAYS OF DEALING WITH
THE GLOBAL HEALTH PANDEMICS
UNLIKE ANYTHING THEY HAVE EVER
FACED BEFORE. WHILE SOME
STUDENTS HAVE THE RESOURCES TO
PERSEVERE THROUGH THE
CIRCUMSTANCES COUNTLESS OTHERS
HAVE LOST ACCESS TO THE ONLY
SUPPORT SYSTEM THEY HAD.
ASSEMBLY ONYX. THE SHIP LIKE ON
THESE ISSUES THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA MOBILIZE GOODNESS
FROM OVER THIRTY FIVE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
THE COMPLETE A SURVEY ABOUT THE
IMPACT OF CALL THE NINETEEN ON
THE MANTLE OF BEING. AFTER
COMPILING ALL THE DATA FINDINGS
FROM THE STUDY THERE ARE THREE
KEY FINDINGS THAT I WOULD LIKE
TO SHARE WITH YOU TODAY. FIRST
I THREE TOWNS THAT IN ADDITION
TO THE 24% OF STUDENTS.
REPORTED SEEING MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES FOR COVER NINETEEN.
27% OF STUDENTS WHO WERE NOT
PREVIOUSLY RECEIVING MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES. FEEL LIKE THEY
NEED THEM NOW. THIS FINDING
MEANS THAT MORE THAN HALF OF
CALIFORNIA'S STUDENTS COULD
REQUIRE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
ONE SCHOOLS RE OPENED. ALSO
FOUND THAT DESPITE 61% OF
STUDENTS REPORTING POSITIVE
MENTAL BEINGS BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC. OVER 51% OF STUDENTS
NOW BELIEVE THEIR MENTAL BEING
PASSED SIGNIFICANTLY WORSENED.
THIS FINDING SUPPORT THE
CONCLUSION THAT SCHOOLS SHOULD
INCREASE ACCESS TO MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES. YOU CAN MORE
THAN HALF OF CALIFORNIA'S
STUDENTS WELCOME BACK TO SCHOOL
WITH SIGNIFICANT REDUCTION TO
THEIR MENTAL WELL BEING.
FINALLY WHEN AFTER SURE THE
REASONS WHY THEY FEEL STRESSED
OUR URVEY FOUND THAT THE
MAJORITY OF STUDENTS REPORTED
SIMILAR REASONS. FOR EXAMPLE
SOME STUDENTS STATED THAT THEY
ARE STRUGGLING BECAUSE OF THE
NEGATIVE ENVIRONMENT THAT
EXISTS IN THE VERY HOME.
THEY'RE CURRENTLY COMBINED TO.
PRINCETON IN ONE SITTING ON
WORDS QUOTE I LOVE TO GET AWAY
FROM HOME AND GO TO SCHOOL FOR
WATER TO GET ANY ISSUES. AND
NOTHING GOING PARTNER. EASY TO
HANDLE THE CONFLICTING EMOTIONS
AND CALL. ANOTHER STUDENT SAID
WELL. I AN EXTROVERT WHO DEPEND
ON SCHOOL AND FRIEND AS MY OWN
SUPPORT SYSTEM. MY HOME IS NOT
AND I ON BY. BASICALLY OF MY CO
SKILLS HAVE BEEN TAKE FROM ME
TO THE POINTING THAT BECOME A-
MENTALLY ILL. AND QUIRK.
HOWEVER THE MOST COMMON REASON
STUDENTS ARE STRESSING DURING
THIS PANDEMIC AGAIN BECAUSE THE
BOUNCING BASS SOME THIS WILL
WORK WITH OTHER RESPONSIBILITY.
WE EXPECT OUR STUDENTS TO EXCEL
ACADEMICALLY COMPLETE
ASSIGNMENTS ON TIME AND GO
ABOVE AND BEYOND HOME. WITHOUT
EVER CONSIDERING THE SOME
STUDENTS OF THE NINE CLASSES.
SOME OF WHICH ARE COLLEGE LEVEL
THREE CONTINUALLY UPLOADING NEW
ASSIGNMENTS AND EXACT.
SIMULTANEOUSLY THE STUDENTS
HAVE TO DEAL WITH NOT IN THE
GLOBAL HEALTH PANDEMICS
ACCOUNTING FEELINGS OF BOREDOM.
STRESS ANXIETY AND THE P. THAT
WE HEAVILY ON THEIR MENTAL AND
PHYSICAL HEALTH. UNFORTUNATELY
THAT IS WHEN THE STUDENTS
CORNET GOOD SCENARIO IN ONLY
WORRY ABOUT SCHOOL WORK AND IT
WILL BE. IMAGINE STUDENT LIVING
IN A SMALL STUDIO PART. WITH
THE SAP EIGHT HAVING A FOCUS ON
DOING PILES OF ONLINE
ASSIGNMENTS AND EXAMS FOR UP TO
NINE DIFFERENT COURSES AT A
TIME. WHAT TIME OKAY WE HAVE
CARE FOR THE SICK AND ARE GOOD.
STUDENT WILL HAVE TO ABOUT
COUNTY CLUBS EXAM PREP. CALL
ESSAYS AND THE- OF THE CALL
DIDN'T PROCESS. MORE IN MORE WE
FEASTED HAVE TO DO SCHOOL. OVER
SUSTAINING THEIR MENTALBE.
THAT IS WHY IT IS IMPAIRED.
THAT YOU TAKE INTO A THE
INDIVIDUAL. THAT CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS FACE DAILY AS YOU MAKE
YOUR DIFFICULT DECISIONS ON
REOPENING SCHOOLS. TO
FACILITATE THAT PROCESS WE ASK
OUR STUDENTS TO SAY WHAT THEY
WOULD LIKE TO SEE CHANGE AND
THEIR SCHOOLS NEXT YEAR. THE
VAST MAJORITY TOUCH ON THE SAME
THING. THEY WANT SCHOOLS TO
HAVE A STUDENT MENTAL HEALTH.
STUDENTS ARE TIRED OF HAVING TO
FIGHT WITH THE ONLY COUNTER THE
MUST ATTEND TO OVER A HUNDRED
STUDENTS EVERY WEEK. TO SOLVE
THIS. SCHOOL DISTRICTS
STATEWIDE SHOULD REPLACEPOLICE
OFFICERS WITH SCHOOL COUNSELORS
PSYCHOLOGISTS AND NURSES.
BECAUSE TODAY IF YOU HAVE
SUPPORT IN THE BLACK LIVES
MATTER MOVEMENT IN RECORD
NUMBERS BECAUSE THE HAN COURT
AND POLICE BRUTALITY THIS TO
US. ALLOWING POLICE OFFICERS ON
A SCHOOL CAMPUS IT. NOT ONLY
MAKE SOME STUDENTS AFRAID OF
ATTENDING SCHOOL BUT ALSO
CALLED UNNECESSARY STRESS AND
WORRY THE SCHOOL ENVIRONMENT.
AFTER ALL OUR SCHOOLS OUR
COMMUNITY AND LIFELINE.
PROVIDING A SAFE ENVIRONMENT
WITH MORE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES AND LASTLY WE THINK.
WE'LL BE ABLE TO BUILD THE
FOUNDATION FROM WHICH ALL
STUDENTS CAN RECOVER FROM THIS
PANDEMIC AND ADEQUATELY SIXTY.
THANK YOU IN. THAT CONCLUDES MY
TESTIMONY. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERGE. ALSO OF YOU BUT DO WE
HAVE QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
IS REGARDING NO. ONE QUICK
QUESTION YEAH DECIMATED IN A
PINE ABOUT THE MINIMUM WAGE
INCREASES TO AND HOW THAT PLAYS
INTO THIS AS WELL A LITTLE BIT
MORE PRESS. SURE AT THE START
OF THIS BUDGET SEASON BEFORE
COVERT HIT- THE AFTER SCHOOL
COMMUNITY WAS BACK WITH AN
ADDITIONAL BUDGET INCREASE
REQUEST TO JUST HELP OUR
PROGRAMS KEEP PACE WITH THE
MINIMUM WAGE WHICH IS SET TO GO
UP AGAIN IN JANUARY AND SO.
WE'VE BEEN VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
HOW THE PROGRAMS WILL STAY
AFLOAT GIVEN A CUT OR EVEN
REMAINING FLAT GOING TO YOUR
EARLIER POINT ABOUT ADDITIONAL
SERVICES BEING REQUIRED- WITH
THE SAME AMOUNT OF RESOURCES
AND GIVEN THAT WERE BARELY
PAYING STAFF MINIMUM WAGE NOW
IT'S UNCLEAR TO US HOW WE WILL
CONTINUE TO MAINTAIN THIS WORK
FORCE AT THE LEVEL THAT WE HAVE
IT NOW- SO THAT. THAT'S AN
UNRESOLVED QUESTION. YEAH AND
JUST- I CONCUR WITH FIRST I
WOULD WHEN I WANT TO PAY THESE
WORKERS POVERTY WAGES AS MY
KIDS SAY IN THEIR LITTLE AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAM HERE THEY STATE
THAT SOME OTHER STAFF TO WORK
AT STARBUCKS YES THEY MAKE
MORE. THAN SERVING OUR KIDS AND
SO WHAT WE VALUE MARK.
CAPPUCCINO LATTE WHATEVER OUR
KIDS AFTER SCHOOL SO I THINK
THAT'S A BIGGER QUESTION BUT- I
THINK THE POINT IS THAT IF YOU
DON'T REALIZE THIS. IS JUST
THAT MATH PLAYS OUT AND YOU
SIR. FOR YOUR KIDS. THAT'S
RIGHT AMOUNT OF MONEY JUST
SERVE YOUR KIT SO THAT WE WANT
TO DO BY NOT ESPECIALLY WHEN WE
TRY TO GET PEOPLE BACK TO WORK
SO THAT'S WHY. ARE BUDGET DOES
IS IN A BUDGET HEARING TODAY
BUT OUR BUDGET. SAID THAT WE
WANT TO REJECT REGARDLESS OF
THAT TRIGGERS ARE NOT. THE
CATEGORICAL CUTS TO ASUS
BECAUSE- IT WOULD WE NEED IT
MORE THAN EVER NOW AND THEN THE
REALITY CHECK IS WE WOULD SERVE
FEWER KIDS. RIGHT HAD TO MAKE
THE REDUCTIONS PLUS. THE
MINIMUM WAGE WE NEED ACTUALLY
AN INCREASE TO JUST.
ACKNOWLEDGE THE MINIMUM WAGE
INCREASE. RIGHT RIGHT. AND IF I
MAY REFER BACK TO THE NEED FOR
OPERATIONAL FLEXIBILITY FOR THE
PROGRAMS SO CURRENTLY THE EIGHT
DOLLARS AN EIGHTY EIGHT CENTS
IS LIKE I SAID IT'S BASED ON A
THREE HOUR UNIT OF SERVICE- YOU
KNOW LIKE MANY OTHER THINGS
THERE'S AN EXECUTIVE ORDER IN
PLACE RIGHT NOW THAT. ALLOWED
THE PROGRAMS TO WORK DIFFERENT
HOURS- NOT HAVE TO TAKE
ATTENDANCE AT CENTER OVER THE
LAST FEW MONTHS BECAUSE OF THE
SITUATION. THAT OPERATIONAL
FLEXIBILITY IS GOING TO
CONTINUE TO BE NEEDED IN AN
ONGOING WAY. AND SO ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WERE REALLY HOPING
FOR. IS THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION CAN HAVE. SOME MORE
AUTHORITY IN AN ONGOING WAY
AROUND LOOKING AT THAT DAILY
RATE. HOURS OF OPERATION AT
CETERA SO THERE CAN BE A LOT OF
FLEXIBILITY IN THE SYSTEM IN
THE COMING YEAR TO BE ABLE TO
SERVE A SCHOOL COMMUNITIES
NEEDS WITH THE HOURS OF
SERVICE. BUT IT REALLY NEEDS
AND THAT COULD END UP SERVING
SLIGHTLY FEWER KIDS THAN WERE
SERVING NOW. BUT I THINK WITH
WE DO THAT IN A TARGETED WAY.
IT'S BETTER THAN LOSING A HUGE
AMOUNT OF OUR WORK FORCE WHICH
IS WHAT WILL HAPPEN YEAH YOU
LOOKING IN. TO PROPOSALS
CHANGES TO LET'S TURN THIS
YEAR. YES IN FACT WE HAVE PUT
FORWARD SOME BUDGET TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE AROUND THIS- THAT
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT IT WITH YOUR STAFF- WE
HAVE SOME SPECIFIC SUGGESTIONS
THAT WE'VE PUT TOGETHER ON HOW
THAT FLEXIBILITY COULD BE
BENEFICIAL. OKAY THANK YOU ALL
FOLLOW UP ON THAT TOO. THANK
YOU THANK YOU INSTALLING. I'M
MR CALL SO YOU SPOKE ABOUT THE
P. M. EDT PANDEMIC WHAT WAS THE
DEADLINE ON THAT FOR. THIRTIETH
FOR FAMILIES TO APPLY- SOME
FAMILIES HAVE ALREADY RECEIVED
THEIR CARDS AUTOMATICALLY
BECAUSE THEY ARE ENROLLED IN
ANOTHER MEANS TESTED PROGRAM
BUT FAMILIES WHO ARE NOT HAVE
TO APPLYTO VERY SHORT ONLINE
APPLICATION- AND WE CAN SHOW
THAT YOU ARE ALL IF THAT'S
THAT'S HELPFUL BUT- YEAH WE
REALLY TO. ENCOURAGE ELLIE A
STATE TO REACH OUT THERE THE
TRUSTED MESSENGERS TO THEIR
STUDENTS TO THEIR TO THEIR
FAMILIES- ABOUT WHAT THIS
PROGRAM IS AND HOW SIMPLE IT IS
TO APPLY AND ACCESS THAT IT'S
THREE HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE
DOLLARS IN FOOD BENEFITS PER
CHILD. OKAY SO HOW ARE YOU
DOING THAT TARGETED OUTREACH
RIGHT NOW WITH LIKE THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IS THAT SOMETHING
THAT YOU'RE JUST EMAILING TO
THE COUNTY SEAT THAT'S YEAH
THAT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT THAT
WE'VE BEEN DIRECTLY INVOLVED IN
WE WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
AND CD TO GET THE SYSTEM SET UP
AND RUNNING- BUT THERE'S AN
ONLINE APPLICATION I WAS
ACTUALLY SET UP BY- CODE FOR
AMERICA. THAT NONPROFIT- AND SO
WE WORK WITH WE JUST REALLY
FEEL LIKE ELEAZER AGAIN THE
BEST MESSENGER AND THEY KNOW
WHERE I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT MINE KNOW ABOUT IT BECAUSE
I HAVEN'T HEARD DOT WHAT WE GOT
SOME MATERIALS THAT WERE HAPPY
TO SHARE OUT IN TERMS OF
GENERAL INFORMATION OUT HM.
OKAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS
SMITH. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AT THE IT ALL A OUR OUR
PANELISTS TO. THE COMMENTS FROM
EACH OF YOU- REGARDING JUST
THAT THE INFRASTRUCTURAL
SUPPORTS THAT HAVE TO BE IN
PLACE. FOR KIDS TO THRIVE. A
SAFE ENVIRONMENT AFTER SCHOOL
IN SUPPORT WITH WITH HOMEWORK
AND ENRICHMENT ACTIVITIES AND-
FOOD. IT IS ELEMENTAL. THAT OUR
CHILDREN EAT IN ORDER TO BE
ABLE. TO LEARN AND SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR ADVOCACY IN YOU
BEING HERE TODAY. AND I
SPECIFICALLY WANTED TO. CALL
OUT MISTER FLORES ALVAREZ I
THINK HIS LEADERSHIP AS A
STUDENT- DOUBT IS AN AMBITIOUS
UNDERTAKING TO ADVOCATE ON
BEHALF OF YOUR PEERS AND WE
APPRECIATE YOU. AND IT SHOULD
ALSO BE MENTIONED THAT THESE
ARE STUDENTS. ASKING FOR THIS
HELP WHAT MR FLOORS OVER AS
POINTS TO. IS THAT IN MOST OF
OUR HIGH SCHOOLS WE REMAIN AND
WE CYCLE AFTER CYCLE REMAIN
PERSISTENTLY UNDERSTAFFED. WITH
SUPPORTS FOR THESE YOUNG PEOPLE
WHEN IT COMES TO THEIR MENTAL
HEALTH NOT ENOUGH PSYCHOLOGISTS
NOT ENOUGH NURSE THERE'S NOT
ENOUGH SOCIAL WORKERS AND WHEN
WE DO HAVE COUNSELORS.
TYPICALLY THAT RATIO IS ONE
COUNSELOR TO SEVERAL HUNDRED
STUDENTS. AND BY NO MEANS
CANNOT COUNSELOR DO AN ADEQUATE
JOB OF PROVIDING FOR THOSE-CHILDREN'S MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS.
LET ALONE WELL DEVELOPED
ACADEMIC SUPPORT THAT THEY NEED
IN PLACE TO FINISH THEIR
ACADEMIC CAREERS SO. AT SOME
POINT AS A STATE WE HAVE GOT TO
GET SERIOUS ABOUT THIS BUT
AGAIN IT GOES BACK TO FUNDING
WHEN YOU ARE IN NEED BOB I'M-
IN THE- STATES IN PER PUPIL
SPENDING. HOW DO YOU AFFORD
THESE REALLY CRITICAL SUPPORT
SO. I THANK YOU MISTER FLOOR
OVER AS FREE ADVOCATE I HOPE
YOU KEEP UP AND I LOVE TO HERE
IN LET. SOMEDAY THANK YOU SEE.
THE SCENE OF COMMENT WHAT WE'LL
DO WE WILL GO TO PUBLIC READ A
PIECE HERE IT'S NOT A STANDARD
PUBLIC COMMENT- WE ASSETS FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT WE ASK THAT
SPEAKERS IDENTIFY YOURSELF AND
YOUR ORGANIZATION TO LIMIT YOUR
REMARKS TO NO MORE THAN ONE
MINUTE SO WHEN YOU'RE CALLED
UPON YOU STATE YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION IF YOU'RE WITHIN
ORGANIZATION STATE THAT
ORGANIZATION IF YOU'RE AN
INDIVIDUAL MAYBE A TEACHER
PARENT WHATEVER HOME EVER- YOU
MAY STATE THAT AND THEN MAKE
YOUR REMARKS FOR MORE NO MORE
THAN ONE MINUTE. YOUR
APPROPRIATE REMARKS- BECAUSE IF
YOU GO MORE THAN ONE MINUTE WE
WILL CUT YOU OFF- AND IF YOU'RE
REMARKS ARE INAPPROPRIATE
BECAUSE OFF IMMEDIATELY AND THE
MODERATOR WILL DO THAT. FOR
YOUR FROM THE ROOM ALL FOR MOVE
TO PUBLIC COMMENT. THE COMMENT
YOU ARE IN THE ROOM I SEE ONE
STANDING OVER THERE. SO THERE'S
TWO. OKAY OTHERS TO FOLKS WHO
ARE GONNA IN THE ROOM WE'RE
GOING TO COME OUT PUBLICLY. SO
WHY DON'T WE TAKE THEIR PUBLIC
COMMENT- RIGHT NOW THOSE TWO
INDIVIDUALS IN THE ROOM PLEASE
DON'T TOUCH THE MIKE AS YOU GO
UP. WHICH IS YOU CAN JUST LEAN
TOWARDS THE MICROPHONE. THANK
YOU. HELLO MY NAME'S DAN
MCKINNON AND I'M HERE TO
ADVOCATE FOR. FIVE AND SIX YEAR
OLDS WHO I'VE BEEN TEACHING FOR
THE LAST TWELVE YEARS AS A
KINDERGARTEN TEACHER. IN PUBLIC
SCHOOLS. WHAT WE'RE HEARING A
LOT- FROM THE STATE ABOUT THE
SCIENCE AND I WANT TO SAY A
LITTLE BIT OF SCIENCE AS WELL.
THE SCIENCE IS THAT THE CARDIO
VASCULAR SYSTEM OF THE FIVE AND
SIX YEAR OLD IS NOT FULLY
DEVELOPED THE SCIENCES THAT.
FACIAL COVERINGS PROLONGED USE
OF FACIAL COVERINGS- RESTRICT
THE AIR FLOW AND- BECAUSE FOR
REDUCE OXYGEN LEVELS IN THE
BLOOD. AND THE SCIENCES ALSO
COMING IN AND YOU CAN CHECK THE
WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION ON
THIS ONE THAT A SYMPTOMATIC
CARRIERS DO NOT. SPREAD THIS
DISEASE. SO ON BEHALF OF THE
FIVE AND SIX YEAR OLDS IS SOME
DAY WE'LL RELY ON HAVING A
FULLY DEVELOPED PHYSICAL BODY
THEY CAN GET TO THE POINT
HOPEFULLY SOME DAY- BEING FULLY
FUNCTIONING ADULTS- I'D LIKE TO
ADVOCATE FOR THEM THAT WE DON'T
WEAR FACIAL COVER WE DON'T ASK
HIM TO WEAR FACIAL COVERINGS IN
SCHOOL THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMENTS DO WE HAVE
ANOTHER. PUBLIC THERE YOU GOT
TO GET UP HERE AND I'M NOT
GONNA. CUTTING ME OFF SO USE ME
IF I IF YOU LIKE COME UP TO THE
MICROPHONE STATE YOUR NAME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'M HERE. I
CAN I GET A MINUTE I HEARD. SO
YOUR MINUTE HAS ON OUR ELECTED
THAT'S GREAT I'M COLLECTING MY
THOUGHTS. THAT'S OFTEN HOW THE
HUMAN BRAIN WORKS THAT WAS MY
HUSBAND HE'S A KINDERGARTEN
TEACHER HE'S A CREDENTIAL
PUBLIC SCHOOL TEACHER MY NAME
IS ANDREA HAD STRONG. AND I'M
REALLY AT A LOSS THAT THIS IS
WHERE WE ARE IN CALIFORNIA I
REALLY AM. AND THIS IS HOW I'M
USING MY MINUTE. DO YOU WISH TO
COMMENT THIS IS MY COMMENT
STANDING HERE YOU SEE IT ON MY
SHIRT MAKE FORMAL LIBEL AGAIN
MY HUSBAND SHIRT SAID NO I
DON'T WANT A FLU SHOT. I KNOW
YOU'RE GOING TO MANDATE THE
COVERT SHOT LIKE THEY DID IN
COLORADO YOU THINK WE DON'T
KNOW WHAT THIS IS ABOUT. WE
KNOW WHAT THIS IS ABOUT. WE ALL
KNOW WHAT THIS IS ABOUT. YOU
PATRICK O'DONNELL SHAMELESSLY
PROMOTING YOUR HPV VACCINE ON
YOUR FACEBOOK YOU THINK THE
PARENTS DON'T KNOW. BECAUSE WE
KNOW. WE KNOW WHAT THIS IS
ABOUT. PEOPLE ARRESTED LAST
SEPTEMBER SAYING NO WE DON'T
WANT MANDATORY SHOCKS. AND YOU
ON A LEASH THIS YEAR THANK YOU
FOR SURE. THANK YOU YOUR MINUTE
IS UP THANK YOU. IT IS
APPRECIATED WITH THAT WILL MOVE.
TO THE REMOTE VIDEO TESTIMONY
STATIONS IS THERE ANYONE
WISHING TO SPEAK AT EITHER OF
OUR VIDEO TESTIMONY STATIONS.
I
DON'T SEE A ANYONE COMING UP ON
THE SCREEN SO WHEN WE GO TO THE
PHONE WILL NOW GO TO THE PHONE
LINE THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR THE
HEARING AS 877-692-8957 I'LL
GIVE YOU THE ACCESS CODE HERE
IT'S ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR
TWO ZERO TWO. IT'S ALSO POSTED
ON THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE. THE
MODERATOR WILL LET YOU IN WHEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN SO YOU WAIT
FOR THE MODERATOR. PLEASE TO BE
SURE TO ELIMINATE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE THIS INCLUDES
MUTING YOUR LIVE STREAM
BROADCAST AND YOUR SMART
DEVICES TO ENSURE- NO SOUND
DISTORTION ONCE YOU ARE PLACED
IN THE QUEUE YOU ALSO NEED TO
MUTE YOURSELF UNTIL. YOU ARE
CALLED BY THE MODERATOR TO
SPEAK. IF YOU ARE HAVING ANY
PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATED
PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN CALL THE
COMMITTEE. THAT'S 916-319-2087
MY STAFF THERE. WILL ASSIST YOU
OPERATOR ARE THERE ANY CALLERS
IN THE QUEUE. ISN'T GENERAL
PHONE LINES IF YOU WISH TO
QUEUE UP FOR ME DO SO BY
PRESSING ONE AT TEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE DO HAVE SEVERAL
WOULD OF ALREADY CUED UPWILL
FIRST GO TO OUR FIRST LINE
WHICH IS LINE NUMBER FORTY
SEVEN. FOUR SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI FORTY SEVEN GO AHEAD
YES CAN YOU HEAR ME YES GO
AHEAD PLEASE YES. THANK YOU. HI
MY NAME IS LEE YOU THEY'LL- AND
I'M THE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA ARTS EDUCATION
ASSOCIATION. I'M OFF ON MY ART
TEACHER HERE SACRAMENTO. ARE AT
THE- STANDS WITH THE OTHER.
THEY ARE ED OR- STAMPS YOU
TAKEN. AND THAT THEY ARE DENZEL
ALL. ARCHIE ACROSS THE STATE
ARE SPENDING TIME APPLY AND-
FOR THEIR STUDENTS FOR. NOT
KNOWING WHETHER THEY WILL BE
DOING IN CLASS CONSTRUCTION IF
LEARNING. OR A HYBRID OF THE
TWO. HONOR OUR COMMITMENT TO
OUR STATE BY AND THAT ALL COLOR.
TO AT ACCESS THE ARTS FROM TO
QUALIFY ART INSTRUCTOR. THE ART
CENTRAL PARK OF THE WELL EDGE.
AND MEET THE SOCIAL IN THE MOST
LEARNING THE US IN. AND VITAL
WAY. THANK YOU THANK YOU. TO
OUR NEXT CALL. WILL GROW LINE
NUMBER TWO SEVEN TWO YEAR LINE
IS A- GOOD MORNING ABOUT WITH
THE ASSOCIATION SCHOOL BUT BUT
THIS. RECOGNIZING THE STATE
RELEASED GUIDANCE OUR FOLK IS
AND- THE HOW HOW PRAYER THE OF
OUR IN STAFF COMMUNICATING
DEVELOP AND TRY. ARE YOU
PROCESS THESE ENSURE THAT AS
ELEAZAR TO MAKE MATHIS
PURCHASES A PEAK. THAT WE DON'T
THE MOST WE CREATED SHOW OF.
ENSURE THAT ARE. ARE DISTURBING
STUDENTS SPECIAL. IF YOU
CHILDREN ARE IN SUPPORT IN A
PATH UP. TO EDUCATIONAL RECOVER
AND WE MUST RECOGNIZE THAT AS
WE WILL SEE DIFFERENT
EDUCATIONAL MY THAT ARE HOW TO
EMPOWER CREEK. EQUITY AMHERST
TO ENSURE EVERY SOCIAL AND
WHICH CAN NEED ARE. THIS
REQUIRES LEADER AND WE YOU FOR
UP AND HAVING THE STYLE TODAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU. TO OUR
CALLER. HELLO NUMBER FOR NINE
FIVE NINE YOUR LINE IS A- THANK
YOU. MY NAME IS HOLLY MIGHT DIE
AND I AM THE OF THE NORTH COAST
SECTION OF THE CAL MEANS AND
YOU OF THE OR THE NBA. I'M HERE
REPRESENTING THE ANY AND CHEN
AND MARK THAN YOU TEACHER OF
THE CAL COKE OF. IN HUMBLE AND
MAR CAO ONE THING I'VE LEARNED
DURING THE THREE MONTHS THAT
STILL NEED THE SOCIAL A MOTION
LEARNING THAT AND ART INTO
PROVIDE THEY NEED THE
CONNECTION TO EACH OTHER AND
OPPORTUNITIES FOR COLLABORATION
WITH THEIR PEERS AND A PLACE
WHERE THEY CAN FEEL SAFE TO
EXPLORE THE UNKNOWN AND CREATE
MORE THEIR DISTANCE LEARNING OR
PERSON AND- THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ALREADY ACKNOWLEDGES
THAT MUSIC AND THE ARTS ARE
PART OF A WELL ROUNDED
EDUCATION I'M HERE TO ASK YOU
REMEMBER AND- YOU THAT. I WANNA
HEAR THAT WHEN I GO BACK TO
SCHOOL ENOUGH THAT MIGHT HURT
AND YOU'RE A THREE STUDENT WHAT
ARE COME AS AN ENTIRE CLASS OR
PART OF A POLL GROUP HAD AND
ALL AND THEN I NO PART THEIR
KERR. THANK YOU VERY THANK YOU.
FOR ALRP NUMBER NET NINE IS
OPEN. WE HAVE A FEDERAL AGENCY
TO CONSIDER ANYWAY FOR
FLEXIBILITY FOR MINUTES THE LAN
OF STEAM LEARNING. ACCORDINGLY
RECKON THE CAME IN THE LEAD
CONSIDERED. FOR ALL OF
FOLLOWING EQUITY THAT TO THE
QUICKLY FOR AUSTIN IN EVERY. IN
THE PARENTS AND THEIR HOME FOR
ANY WORK ON AND OR A AND WITH
TEACHERS. ACT TO DIGITAL TO AND-
BANDWIDTH ALL STUDENTS. HOWEVER
THERE SYNCHRONOUS A FEW
INTERACTION WITH HER. AND STAFF
WILL BE RECORDED. EVIDENCE
RIGID POP FOR I MEETING. AND
SUPPORT WITH ALL THE WERE STAFF
IN A TEN EVEN IF PROMOTE. AND
PROCEDURES TO COUPLE AND THE
ACTUAL OF STUDENT WORK AND FOR
IT. FROM THE DOING WITH NOT YOU
KNOW ENCOURAGE. WE KNOW THAT
WAS ANY LEARNING WHY. AND WE
URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO BALANCE
BACK. WITH MINIMUM SAFETY TO
AND THAT ALSO. INCLUDING
STUDENTS AND I PROBABLY MADE
AND LEARNERS COMMUNITIES OF.
FOR ME TRULY HAVE ACCESS TO A
CA BASE AT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MEMBERS THAT MISTER CARE
MEMBER THANK THANK YOU MISS TWO
X. SO OF YOUR PROPOSAL ARE VERY.
SOME OTHERS MAY REQUIRE ABOUT
FOR ACCOUNT RAY TEACHER SO WE
JUST NEED TO BE RE ON HOW MUCH
WE CAN ACCOUNT FOR WITHOUT TO
CREATING A SIGNIFICANTLY BIRDS
X. I WITH THAT TO OUR CALLER.
NO CALLER SOMEONE NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND- ONE ZERO ONE YOU
LINE IS A. THANK YOU MY NAY IS
ANTHONY I'M PRESIDENT ELECT FOR
THE TO GET ASSOCIATION. I'M
SPEAKING ADVOCATE FOR OUR TO OF
PART OF ALL ROUND EDUCATION AND
CONTINUE TO KEEP THE ARE. AS
YOUNG AS ALL THING. IN INCLUDE
CO THE NINETEEN. THE ARTS ARE
BY DURING THIS TIME OF IN
SEARCH AND THEIR BINDING FOR
STUDENTS IN COMMUNITY. PUBLIC
SCHOOL YOU EDUCATOR FOR THIRTY
TWO YEARS AND NOW. NOW AND
SCHOOL DISTRICT WITH ONCE. I
FEEL NO THE IMPORTANT OF ART
THAT YOU. THE ART OF THE- WAS
FIFTY. TO ENGAGE IN SCHOOL AND
STATE. TO THE CAN AND LEARN.
THE STUDENTS PRIDE WHEN
EXPRESSED. IN A GREAT SO MOST
LEARNING WITH. WE'RE IN PER AND
FIND JOY WHAT ACT ENGAGE IN THE
ARE TOPIC YOU. ONE STUDENTS
READ TO IT SHE WELL X. THEM IN
THE ARE. IF THE WAY BEING IN
INCREASE GOING TO. EVEN OUT OF
THE- AS TEACHERS WE KNOW THE
ARTS HELP. IN THE MIGHT LEARNER.
PLEASE KEEP ALL ARTS IN MY.
EDUCATION ADVOCATE FROM SAN
DIEGO. MY CHIEF CONCERN TODAY
IS THE LACK OF REPRESENTATION
THE DISABILITY COMMUNITY AT THE
HEARING. WE ARE THINK
LEGISLATORS MEDICATION LEADER
COME TOGETHER WITHOUT INCLUDING
DISABILITY RIGHT THAT THE CAT
TO WORK FOR THE TWELFTH. OF
CALIFORNIA SIX NINE STUDENT. IS
WITH PAYING A GREAT
DISAPPOINTMENT. I TO HAVE
CONCERNS THAT THE PD. DOT IF
AND WE'LL YIELD TO MY- VERY
DEPLOYMENT. FOR ON EIGHT.
AGREED HOW HANDLE DIDN'T NEED
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT PHYSICALLY
GET THAT OR YOU MAY NOT BE ABLE
WEAR A MASK. YOU DO A
MANIFESTATION OF THE BILL. WHAT
IS ANY EXCEPTION BE MADE IN
PROJECT. I'VE MADE MINUTES TO
READ THE DOC. YOU MAY NOW ONE
IF IT POSSIBLE TO OVERLOOK THE
EIGHTY EIGHT AND NINETY. EIGHT
REFUSING ACT COULD LEAD
STRICTER IN. TO WITH IEP YEAR
FIVE OF. THE FROM HELL GUY. AND
NOT IN THE AT THE- OF HOW THANK
YOU. IT IS NOW MAKING. TO OUR
NEXT. AND THE CALIFORNIA
EDUCATORS ASSOCIATION. MY FIRST
COMMENT TO SPECIFIC TO DISTANCE
LEARNING. PLEASE ENSURE
APPROPRIATE AND EFFECTIVE
INSTRUCTION AND PUT HIS
PROVIDED TO ENGLISH LEARNERS
BECAUSE THEY HAVE UNIQUE.
INSTRUCTIONAL NEEDS SUCH AS
LIFE DIRECT FACE TO FACE
INSTRUCTION BY THEIR TEACHERS.
VERY ESSENTIAL FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT OF ENGLISH LANGUAGE
PROFICIENCY. THE CARD SHOULD BE
IN PLACE WITH REGARDS TO
INSTRUCTIONAL MINUTES NECESSARY
TO PROTECT THE STUDENTS ACCESS
TO A PUBLIC EDUCATION AND
LASTLY ACCESS TO A BROAD
CURRICULUM SUCH AS MUSIC AND
ARTS EDUCATION SHOULD BE
PROVIDED WHETHER THROUGH
DISTANCE LEARNING OR IN PERSON
CLASSROOM INSTRUCTION. ARTS
EDUCATION SUPPORT THE- IN OUR
DEDICATION ABOARD OUR STUDENTS
ESPECIALLY- DURING THESE
CRITICAL TIME IT SUPPORTS THEIR
EMOTIONAL. THANK YOU WEALTHY
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT
CALLER. COLOURS LINE NUMBER
SEVENTY FOUR SEVEN FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS TO SORRY THE
COUNTY BE EVER HOPE CURRICULA
THE GEN DURING THE
UNPRECEDENTED BUT THE THOUGHT
AN IMPACT OF NINETEEN. INTEREST
REGARDING WERE ACROSS THE ROOM
NATION COUNTY BEING OF OUR HOPE
IS WORKING TO ADDRESS HEALTH
NEEDS OF THE COMMUNITY
INCLUDING OUR- I WOULD LIKE TO
COMMEND PANEL THAT INCLUDED
SCHOOL IN A MENTAL HEALTH PART
OF THE DISCUSSION ON REOPENING
PUBLIC. WE HAVE BEEN X. BY
SCHOOL BASED SERVICES.
EXCERPTED IN ANY UPPER. BOB
KELLY EIGHT ON GETTING BUT THE
WORK WE HAVE TO COLLABORATE A
PROVIDE MENTAL EIGHT COUNTY THE-
AND LET'S 3% OF CAL. PERJURING
DIRECTING DOLLARS OFF BUT THE
MAN ILLNESS OR STEP YOU. THEN
TRY WITH DIDN'T DURING THAT
PERIOD AND BY THE MOST TRAUMA
SHOULD BE TRAINED TO RECOGNIZE
THE FIND THAT OUR CHILDREN
PUBLIC BEAVER. WE HOPE TO
COOPERATE WITH LA AND ANOTHER
STEP. OUR WORK THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. NEXT CALLER BACK NEXT
KALRA COME FROM ONE NUMBER
NINETEEN ONE NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN HELLO I AM DARLENE ALKI
THEN I HAVE A SCIENCE DEGREE IN
CHILD AND ADOLESCENT
DEVELOPMENT AND A MASTER'S
DEGREE IN HUMAN DEVELOPMENT
SPECIALIZING IN EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION I URGE THE STATE TO
DO A STUDY ON THE IMPACT FUND
OF CALL THAT ON EDUCATION
MENTAL HEALTH AND THE VARIOUS
GROUPS OF CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES- THE CDC STATES THAT
KOBA NINETEEN FATALITY RATE FOR
CHILDREN UNDER NINETEEN IS ZERO
POINT 0% I BETTER
EPIDEMIOLOGISTS SAY IT'S
BECAUSE THERE'S- THEY'RE NOT AN
AT RISK GROUP- UPDATED CDC
GUIDANCE FROM JUNE THREE HAS NO
MENTION OF MASK. NO EXPECTATION
FOR SCHOOLS TO DO SCREENING AND
DIFFERENT SOCIAL DISTANCING
GUIDELINES SO THE CITY PA
CONCEDE GUIDANCE- NEEDS TO BE
REVISED- CAL OSHA ALSO SAYS
THAT- DOCTOR SHOULD APPROVED
THAT SOMEONE IS HEALTHY ENOUGH
TO WEAR A MASK ON BECAUSE IT
DECREASES OXYGEN LEVELS SO
SCHOOL LIABILITY COULD BE
REGARDING MASK- ALSO DIGITAL
DIVIDE AND SOCIAL EMOTIONAL
DEVELOPMENT WILL BE LESS OF AN
IT IF WE LET CHILDREN RETURNED
SCHOOL AS. WITH AN EMPHASIS ON
HAN WASHING AND THIS IS. WHICH
THE GUY TO BACK BY UNDER SIGN.
LOW INCOME COULD. AND THANK YOU.
NEXT CALLER GROWING NUMBER ONE
ONE HUNDRED AND SIXTY SEVEN ONE
SIX SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND HAPPY WITH
PUBLIC ADVOCATES AND A MEMBER
OF THE EQUITY COALITION
UNFORTUNATELY ADVISORY OPTIONAL
GUIDANCE AND LOCAL FLEXIBILITY
DOES NOT MEET THE STATE
CONSTITUTIONAL DUTY TO ENSURE A
QUALITY EDUCATION. PUBLIC
ADVOCATE THE ACLU AND OTHER IN
THIS DAY AND WHY INTERESTED
CALIFORNIA EXACTLY REINFORCED
LONGSTANDING SUPREME COURT
PRECEDENT THAT THE STATE HAS
THE SUPREME NOT ELIGIBLE DVD TO
ENSURE BASIC EQUALITY OF
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITY.
THERE'S NOT ENOUGH PROCEED TO
GET LEN GOOD ADVICE AND WATCH
THEM WHAT THE BODY NEEDS TO
ESTABLISH MINIMUM STANDARDS FOR
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF SCHOOL
AND FOR QUALITY OF LEARNING AND
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL SUPPORT
PROVIDED DURING THE SPEND THEM
THAT. WE ASK THAT YOU ADDRESS
THE MINIMUM STANDARDS THAT PART
IN THE EQUITY COALITION
PARTICIPATION INSTRUCTIONAL
QUALITY PACKAGING IN PROGRESS
AND HOLDING ELLIE IS
ACCOUNTABLE FOR REJECTING
LEARNING IN TRAUMA. WE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR ONGOING EFFORTS TO
PROTECT STUDENTS WHILE
PROVIDING THEM ACCESS. TO THE
QUALITY EDUCATION LEADERS ARE.
THANK YOU THAT'S COLOR. NEXT
WILL COME FROM LINE NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY NINE ONE SIX
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I THINK
WE COULD GET A HOLD ARAMBULA
THAT. I'D TO TRY TO ADVOCATES
THE- I WISH FOR YOU- ALL TO
WATCH THIS HEARING OVER AGAIN
AND COUNT THE NUMBER OF TIMES
THAT EACH OF THE WAR. THAT
TOUCHED YOUR MOM'S I COUNTED
THEM AND TWENTY BERMAN TO TOUCH
A SMALL BUDGET SEVENTY TWO ONE
A COMMON. DID YOU ARE COMMON ON
THE CLOCK. DID YOU WANT YEAH
I'M IN A THE HE HAS ROBERT TO I
THINK WHAT. PLEASE THAT WE
CANNOT X. EXPECT CHILDREN OR
TEACHERS TO WEAR MALL FOR SEVEN
OUR IN THE CAR CON. WHEN THE
ADULT IN THE ROOM AND GIVING AT
THE MANY CAUGHT DO IT
THEMSELVES- IT IS IT
UNREASONABLE TO THINK THAT
CHILDREN WOULD BE ABLE TO DO
THAT AND TEACHERS WOULD BE ABLE
TO KEEP THEM ON I'M- TALKING
ABOUT THAT AND- YES I WILL
THANK YOU FOR AND SHOULD NOT BE
MADE WEB OFTEN THANK YOU. TO
OUR NEXT CALLER. NEXT CALLER'S
LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY TWO ONE SEVEN TO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON-
MY NAME IS MATTHEW TRAMMELL
CHILDREN NOW AND I'M A MEMBER
OF THE EQUITY COALITION.
CHILDREN NOW THINK THE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE EMERGENCY
EDUCATION THAT YOU HAVE
RECEIVED OVER THE LAST THREE
MONTHS- AND WE ARE ESPECIALLY
WORRIED THAT THERE IS ADVOCATES
IN THE WAY- CALLING FOR
UNILATERAL FLEXIBILITY. WITH
RESPECT INSTRUCTIONAL DAYS THE
MINUTE I CALIFORNIA'S BOTH
BASIC MECHANISM TO ENSURE
STUDENTS HAVE ACCESS TO THEIR
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO A
PUBLIC EDUCATION- WE BELIEVE
STATE POLICYMAKERS NEED TO
INTERVENE AND ENSURE THAT THEIR
INSTRUCTIONAL CREEK GARDEN
MINIMUM STANDARDS BUT IN PLACE.
GOING INTO THE NEXT SCHOOL YEAR
THIS INCLUDES ENSURINGALL
STUDENTS HAVE ACCESS DEVICES
THEN WHY FIVE THAT ELEAZAR
ENGAGING STAKEHOLDERS ON PLANS
TO REOPEN SCHOOL. THAT THERE IS
INSURANCE IS IN PLACE BUT THERE
ARE CLEAR STRATEGY TO AFFECT.
LEARNING LAW AND TRAUMA AND A
COMMITMENT TO PROVIDE ACCESS TO
LOCAL CURRICULUM SYNCHRONISTIC
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES AND
EFFECTIVE ACCOMMODATION-
ESPECIALLY FOR ENGLISH LEARNERS
AND STUDENTS WITH SPECIAL
NEEDS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT CALLER. THANKS CALLER IS
WHY RUN ONE HUNDRED AND EIGHT
ONCE EIGHT YOUR LINE OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THAT CHAIRMAN MY IT'S
UNDER KEPT WATCH NUMBER OF THE
CANYON AND THE YOU'RE NOT
SCHOOL. I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR- AND HOLD THE THAT HEARING
AND ALL THANK COLLECTED BY FOR
THEIR PACKAGE THE STATE BUDGET
LATER TODAY CAN BE UNION. WILL
BE HOSTING A WORKSHOP ON THE
TOPIC OF RE OPENING IN OUR
SCHOOLS SO. WE APPRECIATE THE
ABUNDANCE OF GUIDING- BUT RE
OPENING REMAINS A QUESTION OF.
FUNDING FLEXIBILITY ON P. P. E.
FUNDING IT'S IMPORTANT BECAUSE
THAT WILL SET THE PARAMETERS.
OR HEALTH AND SAFETY ARE
ESTIMATE OF RE OPENING BECAUSE-
IT THAT IT WOULD RANGE ANYWHERE
BETWEEN 10220% OF OUR BUDGET.
IN NINETEEN TWELVE FUNDING AND
CUT. OF COLLECTED BILLION TOTAL
IMPORTANT OUR SCHOOLS BECAUSE
THE LOCAL CONTEXT CONDITIONS MY
REQUIRE CLOSING SCHOOLS AFTER.
RE OPENING TO MINIMIZE THE
SPREAD OF THE VIRUS TO ALLOW
FOR CONTINUITY. OF LEARNING.
FINALLY PP AND PLAN HER ON AND
FIFTEEN BOTH THE- AT PENSION
FOR. AND CURRENTLY MAKING THANK
YOU THANK YOU. TO OUR NEXT.
NEXT CALL OR WILL BE LINE FIFTY
FIVE FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU OUT MY IS MICHAEL
THAT'S FAR AND I'M THE
CALIFORNIA EDUCATE PETER
ASSOCIATE. I'M SPEAKING AS AN
ADVOCATE. FOR ARTS EDUCATION AS
PART OF A WELL ROUNDED.
EDUCATION OUTLINED BY BOTH
STATE AND FEDERAL POLICY AND
IT'S IT IS AN IMPORTANT ASPECT
DURING THIS TIME OF
UNCERTAINTY. AT THE CLUB AND
THE EDUCATE THE TITLE ONE HIGH
SCHOOL I SAW FIRSTHAND HOW
IMPORT ARTS WORK DURING AT A
TIME THAT WAS CHALLENGING ONLY
FOR STUDENTS AND THEIR
FAMILIES. BOB STUDENTS NEED AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ESCAPE ALL
EXPLORING MEANINGFUL ARTS
OPPORTUNITIES ACCORDING TO THE
ARTS EDUCATION AT THE CENTRAL
DOCUMENT MARKET YOU CATION
SUPPORT THE SOCIAL EMOTIONAL
WELL BEING OF STUDENTS WHETHER
THROUGH DISTANCE LEARNING OR IN
PERSON. MANY OF MY STUDENTS
ARRIVE DURING THIS TIME BECAUSE
OF THEIR CONNECTION TO THE ARTS
THERE ARE DEDICATED AND THE
ONGOING CONNECTION TO THEIR
PEERS SOME OF THEM EVEN MENTION
THAT BUT THE ONLINE CURRICULUM
WAS ONE OF THE GREAT MOMENTS OF
THEIR DAY AT A RECENT AT CHECK
IN. I DO TRANSITION THE NEXT
SCHOOL YEAR- IT IS IMPORTANT
REMEMBER THAT REGARDLESS OF
SYNCHRONOUS OR ASYNCHRONOUS
LEARNING STUDENTS ARE GOING TO
BE SEEKING A PLACE BUT IT'S A
BILL HERE AND ALSO PLACE WHERE
THEY CRIED. THANK YOU. TO OUR
NEXT CALLER. NEXT CALLER'S LINE
NUMBER. THREE EIGHT LINER OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS GAIL. JONES I'M
THAT I. PRESS OF THE- THEATERS
OKAY. AND ALSO- A VICE
PRESIDENT CALIFORNIA
EDUCATIONAL THEATER
ASSOCIATION. DETEST SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AT EACH YEAR AND I'M
A BAG AFTER MEMBER. I ECHO WHAT
EVERYBODY HAS SAID AND THANK
YOU FOR THE CARE OF OUR
TEACHERS AND OUR STAFF. AND OUR
STUDENTS. WE KNOW THAT THE
ARTS- REASON WHY KIDS THE ONLY.
WORLD THE REASON WHY THEY STAY
IN SCHOOL. STUDENTS ARE CRAVING
CONNECTIONS THEY FIND THOSE
CONNECTIONS IN THE ARTS WHETHER
TO DISTANCE LEARNING. OR IN
PERSON. WE KNOW THAT THE ARTS
ARE PART OF A WELL ROUNDED
EDUCATION SO WHEN YOU THINK OF
THE ARTS PLEASE INCLUDE THEATER
ARTS VISUAL ARTS MUSIC AND
DANCE. BROUGHT TO OUR STUDENTS.
KATE THROUGH EIGHT THROUGH
TWELVE. WE REALLY NEED THE ARE
TWO TEACHERS ARE VALIANTLY
CREATING CONTENT THAT LIKE
THEY'VE NEVER DONE BEFORE. SO I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CARE I AM A
TEACHER OF FORTY YEARS I AM THE
NEW HARD TO DETER AYE BUT- IT'S
TEACHER THAT. OUR NEXT CALLER.
THAT LINE NUMBER HUNDRED
SEVENTY SIX ONE SEVEN ZERO ONE
IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS LAURIE
AND I HAVE A MASTER'S IN JEWISH
EDUCATION I'M A PARENT AND THE
LOS ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT WHILE YOU'RE CREATING
A FAITH BASED THREE OPEN GOLF.
I WOULD LIKE YOU TO KEEP A FEW
THINGS IN MIND THE CDC STATES
THAT ALL BECAUSE THE NINETEEN
CATHOLIC CASES ARE ONLY ONE
POINT 7% YOU CHILDREN. OTHER
CHILDREN HAVE THE ONLY
POPULATION IN SCHOOL. THAT'S
SOMETHING TO KEEP IN MIND I
ALSO WANT TO SHARE THE CAL OSHA
STATES THAT CLOCK FACE
COVERINGS ARE NOT PROTECTED AND
DO. NOT PROTECT THE PERSON
WEARING AT. BACK WITH THE STATE
THAT BOY. CODE TRANCE. YOU
SHOULD NOT IT. WEARING A FACE
COVERING MAKES AWARE TOUCH OKAY
FREQUENT. DURING THE HEARING
NINETY TOUCH THE NOW MUST. AND
LEAVE THE ADULT. ALL WELL FOR
THE REQUIRE BATES COVER WILL BE
ACROSS FOR THE WHO ARE POPULAR
PARKER NINETEEN AMPS BY.
ALTHOUGH THEY CAN THAT AND
HEALTH ABOUT. THANK HUNDRED AND
BUT THE HIGH NINE. THANK YOU
OUR NEXT CALLER. COLOURS LINE
NUMBER HUNDRED AND THIRTY ONE
ONE THREE ONE YOUR IS OPEN. MY
NAME AT THE TOP THE LOCAL FROM
AND I CENTER FOR YOU LAW
REMEMBER. COALITION WE URGE YOU
TO PROTECT THE DIGNITY GET ME
ABOUT NEED STUDENT BY PUTTING
IN THE CLEARER THEY ARE ON. THE
CD. AND RAY THAN TO. BUT NOT GO
FAR FAR. ESPECIALLY ENSURE HELP
NEARLY THREE AND THOUSAND. BOB
YOU WHO ARE YOU CAN FOSTER CARE
IN THE JUVENILE DEATH SYSTEM.
AND IF YOU ARE HOMELESS I THIRD
OF THE THING TO STAY ON TRACK
GRADUATE. WE HOPE YOU WILL
REVIEW OUR WRITTEN COMMENT YES
THE PARTICULAR ATTENTION TO THE
FOR DIDN'T. TO SHARE. WHICH
ILLUSTRATE HOW CHALLENGING HAS
BEEN. BOB YOU BUT THEY
CONNECTED TO SCORE AND IT WE
ALL DO TELL THAT BACK AT THIS
SUPPORT WITHIN AND ALL YOU NEED
FROM THERE DISTRICT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. TO OUR NEXT CALLER.
NEXT CALLER'S FROM NUMBER
HUNDRED AND FOUR ONE THREE FOR
YOUR LINE IS A- HELLO MY NAME
IS MIKE MATTINGLY. FUNKY
FATHER'S ORGANIZATION
REPRESENTING FATHERS OF FUNK
EVERYWHERE. AND I WOULD JUST
LIKE TO ENCOURAGE YOU TO- ALLOW
SPORTS AGAIN BECAUSE THE- WHAT
KIDS DON'T GET THIS DISEASE.
FAMILY MY DAUGHTER'S
SCHOLARSHIP BECAUSE SHE CAN GET
HER HERE. MY SON PLAYS DRUMS IF
I GO BACK TO SCHOOL IF YOU
CAN'T GET IN TO PLAY DRUMS WITH
HIS CLASSMATES. ARE BOTH A
PIECE STUDENTS. THEY WILL BE
DOING SOMETHING ELSE. UNLESS
YOU GUYS OPEN UP THE SCHOOL.
BECAUSE WE DON'T NEED MATH. THE
STUDIES ARE CLEAR STOP IT GOING
WITH THE IMPERIAL MODEL THAT
WAS TURNED UPSIDE DOWN YOU GUYS
MADE IT HE GOT ARRESTED HE'S AN
IDIOT AND YOU GOT TO FOLLOW NOT
SYSTEM WHAT THE HELL YOU
BANKRUPT CALIFORNIA. NOW YOU
CAN CONTINUE TO DO THE SAME
THING. KIDS NOT WHEN YOU GET
THIS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
THANK YOU MAY BE OUT WELL THE-
TO OUR NEXT CALLER. CALLERS ONE
NUMBER TWENTY TWO TWO TWO DON'T
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS STEVEN
KEEP THAT NUMBER PRESS HERE
MUSIC AT FRESNO STATE SEE ME A
PROTECTION PRESIDENT AND
PARENTS OF CHILDREN WHO HAVE
DIRECTLY BENEFITTED FROM
INCLUSIVE ARTS EDUCATION. FOR
MANY CHILDREN ARTS EDUCATION IS
THERE WHY TO ATTEND SCHOOL.
STUDENTS NEED OUR DEDICATION OR
TO EXPRESS THEMSELVES OF THE
UNDERSTAND THE LARGER WORLD
AROUND THEM PARTICULARLY IN
THESE CHALLENGING TIMES. OUR
TEACHERS BUILT SPECIAL
RELATIONSHIPS WITH STUDENTS
REPORTING IN A CRAZY THING THAT
TO EXCEL IN THEIR ACADEMIC AND
SOCIAL SETTING. FOR THE CARE OF
A HIGH SCHOOL STUDENT I SEE
FIRSTHAND ABOUT THE NEED TO BE
CONNECTED TO MUSIC ON A DAILY
BASIS. IT EXPERIENCE IS GREATLY
ENHANCES FOCUS. MOTIVATION AND
DETERMINATION AND A DEPUTY FOR
OTHERS. BY WHITE THAT THE
PRINCIPAL BECAUSE YOUR POINT
MIDDLE SCHOOL WITH EIGHTY SIX
PERCENT. BELOW POVERTY RATE-
STUDENT POPULATION THAT EIGHT
HUNDRED SEVENTEEN KIDS. GET
THEIR ART PROGRAMS IN FUTURE
MINUTES GROWTH IN ACADEMIC
ACHIEVEMENT AND BEHAVIOR
MANAGEMENT GIVE ME THESE
BENEFITS ARE CLEAR WE ARE TO
SUCCEED MOVING PAST THE
PANDEMIC. IT'S ABSOLUTELY VITAL
THAT ALL CHILL RECEIVE ACTEDTO
A FULL CURRICULUM THANK YOU YOU
COULD ARGUE BATES INSTRUCTED.
THANK YOU TO OUR NEXT CALLER
THANK YOU. I AGREE. NEXT CALL
IS LINED ONE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FIVE ONE SEVEN FIVE
YEAR ONE. JEFF THANKS VERY
CALIFORNIA STATE THESPIANS
BOARD MEMBER AND HERE ARE. S.
MY HIGH SCHOOL CAMP CALIFORNIA
ARTS EDUCATION NEEDS TO BE PART
OF A WELL ROUNDED EDUCATION FOR
ALL STUDENTS TO PROVIDE AN
ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL DEVELOPMENT CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT EQUITABLE
OPPORTUNITIES STUDY AFTER STUDY
HAS SHOWN THAT INVOLVEMENT IN
THE ARTS IS ASSOCIATE WITH THE
STUDENTS GROWTH IN MATH READING
COGNITIVE ABILITY CRITICAL
THINKING OF VERBAL SKILLS. ARTS
LEARNING CAN ALSO IMPROVE
MOTIVATION CONCENTRATION
CONFIDENCE YOU CAN WORK IN
ADDITION PERFORMING ARTS
CLASSES PROVIDE TREMENDOUS
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
STUDENT LEADERSHIP CREATIVITY
COLLABORATION SKILL BUT ANY
EMPLOYER WILL FIND EXTREMELY
VALUABLE I'M NOT TALKING A
CONTEST COMPETITION TO WIN
AWARDS ARTS EDUCATION HELPS OUR
STUDENTS SUCCEED BE ON THE TEST
IF YOU KNOW MORE THAN HOW TO
SOME BUBBLES ON THE SCANTRON.
PROVIDES AN EDUCATION THAT
NURTURES AS IMPROVE STUDENT
PERFORMANCE ARTISTS ARE
COLLABORATIVE LEARNERS WAS
INDIVIDUAL WORKERS ONLY MADE
BETTER BY THE OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE TEAM BUT THE ART NEED
PHYSICAL SPACE TOOLS AND
MATERIALS PLEASE SUPPORT THOSE
NEEDS PHYSICAL THANK. YOU TOOLS
AND- TO A NEXT CALLER. NEXT
CALLER'S LINE NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY THREE ONE
SEVEN THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
I THANK YOU THE ABILITY OF ONE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL NURSES.
DURING THIS UNPRECEDENTED
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS MANY ABOUT
CHILDREN AND YOUTH ARE
EXPERIENCING GAPS IN THE ACCESS
TO ROUTINE PRIMARY AND
PREVENTIE HEALTH SERVICES AS
WELL AS NEW OR WORSENING
PHYSICAL AND MENTAL HEALTH
CONDITIONS. THEY WERE COOL IF
ANY AN I MET HEALTH NEEDS MUST
BE ASSESSED AND ADDRESSED.
SCHOOL HEALTH PROGRAMS-
CRITICAL TO THE SUCCESS ALLOW
STUDENTS. DOING THIS PANDEMIC
ALL SCHOOLS HAVE RISEN TO MEET
THE SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF
HEALTH. AND THE OTHER NEEDS OF
OUR STUDENTS AND FAMILIES SUCH
AS PROVIDING MEALS PARTNERING
WITH NON PROFITS TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS. PROVIDING ACCESS
TO HEALTH WE STILL RESOURCES AS
WELL AS ADDRESSING. SOME OF THE
NEEDS OF OUR SPECIALISTS. AS WE
MOVE REAL SCHOOLS THE GAP IN
PROVIDING COMPANY OF SERVICES
PROGRAMS AND POLICIES IS
CRITICALLY THINKING RIGHT AT
THE STATE LEVEL THANK YOU TO
OUR NEXT CALLER. THE CALLERS
LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY ONE ONE FIVE ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MISTER
CHAIRMAN THIS IS BRIAN RIVAS A
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
EDUCATION TRUST WHERE. WE'RE
ALSO A MEMBER OF THE EQUITY
COALITION WANTED TO CAUTION-
YOU IN THE LEGISLATURE IN
RESPONDING TO REQUESTS FOR
MAXIMUM FLEXIBILITY. OUR
CONCERN IS THAT IF YOU ALLOW
MAXIMUM FLEXIBILITY THAT'S
GOING TO TRANSLATE INTO LOW
INCOME STUDENTS STUDENTS OF
COLOR GETTING A WHOLE LOT LAST.
WE THINK THAT THE ROLE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD BE PLAIN IS
AN ESTABLISHED UNION UP HOLDING
MINIMUM STANDARDS FOR THINGS
LIKE ACCESS TO THE FULL
CURRICULUM. RIGOR AND
INSTRUCTIONAL MINUTES AND SEVEN
YEARS OLD UP TO MONITOR THESE
THINGS AND MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE FORCED IF YOU DON'T DO
THAT WERE WORRIED THAT WE'RE
GOING TO BE LEFT WORSE OFF
COMING OUT OF THE CRISIS. YEAH
WE'RE GOING TO SUBMIT
INEQUALITY IN OF THE SYSTEM
THAT'S GOING TO BE THERE FOR A
VERY LONG TIME SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. HOW GOOD A LINE
NUMBER THIRTY TWO THREE TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES HELLO THANK YOU I'M GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS SUSAN
THAT'S FINE WITH SPEAKER
PARENTS LOS ANGELES IN SHORT
EVERYTHING DR LINDA DARLING
HAMMOND SAID. WITH THE CABBIE
OUGHT THAT ESSENTIAL PARENT NOW
THE CENTRAL TEACHERS WOULD CARE
GIVERS MUST BE INCLUDED IN THE
DEVELOPMENT AND DEPLOYMENT OF.
EQUITABLE ACCEPTABLE QUALITY
CONTINUOUS LEARNING STRATEGIES
FOR ALL STUDENTS. OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU. TO OUR
NEXT CALLER. BUT ALL I NUMBER
SIXTY EIGHT SIX EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS JESSICA HOW FINE AND THE
PRESIDENT OF SOUTHWESTERN
SECTION OF CALIFORNIA MUSIC
EDUCATORS ASSOCIATION. THE
OVERWHELMING SENTIMENT I'M
HEARING TODAY SETTLED BACK TO
ENGAGEMENT AND EMOTIONAL
WELLNESS FOR STUDENTS I AM SO
EXCITED TO REMIND EVERYONE WE
HAVE THE TOOLS ALREADY AT OUR
DISPOSAL YOUR EXPERIENCE ART
AND MUSIC EDUCATORS. WE'RE HERE
WE'RE READY TO CONTINUE OUR
STANDARDS BASED LESSON
REGARDLESS OF THE WAY WE COME
BACK WELL THE FALL YOUR ART
MUSIC EDUCATORS KNOW HOW DO YOU
THEIR DISCIPLINE TO HELP
STUDENTS PROCESS SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL COMPONENT THE BILL
THROWN AT THEM THESE LAST SIX
MONTHS. WE'RE ALREADY IN YOUR
SCHOOL PREPARING STUDENTS FOR
THE PRESS LARA. ARTS RELATED
CAREERS AVAILABLE IN CALIFORNIA
AND WE HAVE TO KEEP THE BILL
ABILITY TO MEET WITH HUNDREDS
OF STUDENTS TODAY WE ALWAYS
WORK TOGETHER STUDENTS THE
SKILLS NEEDED TO CONNECT ALL TO
FEELING. PROCESS EMOTIONS
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT THE ART THE
ART YOU DO STRESS AND TRAUMA
WHICH MAKES FOR BETTER LEARNING
ALL AROUND. IT YOUR TO OUR NEXT
CALLER. CALLERS LINE NUMBER
HUNDRED AND THIRTY NINE ONE
NINE LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS KEN HùI I SERVICE CO
PRESIDENT FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CAMP EDUCATION ASSOCIATION WE
FOUND FOR THE GUARANTEE THAT
ALL STUDENTS HAVE EQUITABLE
ACCESS TO ARTS EDUCATION
INCLUDING DANCE. THEATER VISUAL
ARTS AND YOU BACK WHILE WE LOOK
AHEAD TO THE FALL AT THE TIME
TO RECONNECT WITH STUDENTS
ACROSS THE STATE WE KNOW THAT
EDUCATORS WILL RISE TO THE
CHALLENGE THROUGH INNOVATION.
WHETHER INTRODUCTION AND
PROVIDED SYNCHRONOUSLY OR
ASYNCHRONOUSLY SURE DIFFERENT
LEARNING HYBRID OR IN PERSON
MODEL. ARTS EDUCATION SUPPORT
CRITICAL SOCIAL AND EMOTIONAL
LEARNING SKILLS AND INSURANCE
OPPORTUNITY FOR STOCK FASHION
WITHIN NURTURING CLASSROOM LED
BY TRAINED EDUCATORS. IN THE
WORDS OF ONE OF MY STUDENTS.
THERE IS A COMMUNITY OF LOVE IN
OUR CAMP CLASSROOM WHERE
EVERYONE SUPPORT EACH OTHER
YEAH LAST WEEK EACH OF THAT.
INNER PEACE AND PASSED. LAST
AND WE RE OPEN CORTES ALL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER.
CALLER IS MY NUMBER ONE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY SEVEN ONE FIVE SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I COULD HEAR
ME OKAY YES PROCEED. THANK YOU
VERY PROVIDE LIKE TO REMIND YOU
GUYS OF OUR FIRST AMENDMENT
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT OF FREE
SPEECH I AM ACTUALLY APPALLED
AT HOW THE PEOPLE THAT HAVE OF
THE PEOPLE THAT HAVE YOU GUYS
IN YOUR SEATS RIGHT NOW IN PAIN
YOU ARE CUTTING OFF. YOUR
CONSTITUENTS. ISRAELI ALARMING
THANK YOU ALSO THE FACT THAT
YOU GUYS ARE EVEN. CONSIDERING
MANDATING AND LEGAL LIABILITY
VACCINE THAT NOT. OPEN SAFETY
THERE HAVE NEVER BEEN FACED.
MAXINESTUDIED FOR FACTORS OF
UNPACKED AND YOU GUYS ARE
WILLING TO DO THAT FOR OUR KIDS
THIS IS THIS IS HORRIBLE MY
KIDS WILL NOT BE RETURNING TO
SCHOOL IF THIS IS THE CASE AND
THE FAT THING IS THAT YOU GUYS
FORCED US TO PAY TAXES. AND YOU
HAVE ALLOWED ME TO LISTEN TO
THE OLDEST OF WHITE PEOPLE ARE
WRITING. AND THAT'S WHY PEOPLE
ARE GOING TO GET YOU RIGHT OUT
OF OFFICE. THIS IS HORRIBLE YOU
READY TO START LISTENING TO THE
PEOPLE THAT HAVE YOU GUYS BEEN
POWER. AND STOP CENSORING
PEOPLE THAT ARE. DO NOT AGREE
WITH THE WHAT YOU'RE SAYING.
THANK YOU VERY BAD THANK YOU
AND I JUST JUST TO BE CLEAR
THERE WAS NO. DISCUSSION ABOUT
AND DEMO FLYING. OR LIMITING
THE LIABILITY OF ANY DRUG
COMPANY HERE TODAY THAT THAT IS
NOT AT ALL. WE DID TALK ABOUT
VACCINES DAY THAT WAS NOT A
TOPIC TODAY. THAT SO I THINK
THERE WAS SOME MAYBE SOME
MISINFORMATION OUT THERE- BUT
YOU SOUND LIKE YOU MAKE A GREAT
CANDIDATE FOR THE STATE
ASSEMBLY WE LOVE TO HAVE YOU UP
HERE. YES STRONG OPINIONS AND
WE WELCOME THAT. A TO OUR NEXT
CALLER. OUR NEXT CALLER'S MY
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
EIGHT ONE SIX EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. WHICH GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS RYAN DUCKWORTH WHEN
I'M THE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA MUSIC EDUCATORS
ASSOCIATION SOUTH EASTERN
SECTION I REPRESENTS MUSIC
TEACHERS AND MORE IMPORTANTLY
MUSIC STUDENT TIMBRE MAYBE NOW
ORANGE RIVERSIDE COUNTY. AS WE
CONSIDER RETURNING TO SCHOOL IN
THE FALL THERE IS AN
APPROPRIATE FOCUS ON THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY OF STUDENTS AND
STAFF. BUT INCLUDED THAT MUST
BE THE SOCIAL AND EMOTIONAL
HEALTH OF OUR STUDENTS.
STANDARDS BASED ARTS CLASSES
ARE UNIQUELY SITUATED TO
PROVIDE FOR THOSE NEEDS AND
POWERFUL WAVES. MUSIC AND ARTS
EDUCATION ARE PART OF A WELL
ROUNDED EDUCATION AND MUST
REMAIN PART OF EVERY STUDENT'S
EDUCATIONAL EXPERIENCE BARTLETT
STOPS WILL BE OPEN. THE THREE
MONTHS OR THAT WHEN ALLOWED
MUSIC AND ARTS TEACHERS ARE
CAPABLE OF PROVIDING VIABLE IN
MEANINGFUL EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITY. MAINTAIN STUDENT
ACCESS TO ARTS AND MUSIC
EDUCATION WILL HELP DIMINISH
THE ACHIEVEMENT GAPS. AND THIS
IS ESPECIALLY CRITICAL IN OUR
STATE WHERE ARE COMMUTING
ENTERTAINMENT IF SUCH A LARGE
PORTION OF OUR US ECONOMY.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU AND I AGREE. OUR NEXT
CALLER IT WILL I NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND SIX ONE ZERO SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS MEGAN ASH LOCK AND I'M
CALLING TO ADVOCATE FOR MY
DAUGHTER. SHE'S FIVE YEARS OLD
WILL BE SIX AND JULY- ASKING TO
REQUIRE FACE MASK FOR A FIVE
YEAR OLD IS JUST- NOT
REALISTIC. WE WENT TO COSTCO
SHE TOUCH YOUR FACE ABOUT
TWENTY TIMES MORE THAN SHE
NORMALLY WORD- I'M JUST WORRIED
ABOUT HELP CHILDREN WILL
DEVELOP ANXIETY AND WORRY MORE
ABOUT WHAT THE DO'S AND DON'TS
AREN'T SCHOOL RATHER THAN
FOCUSING ON LEARNING- MY
DAUGHTER. HAD THE MOTHER AND
FATHER ARE BETTER TOGETHER
INVOLVED WITH BOTH A FULL TIME
JOB. AND WE HAVE NOTICED BUT
OUR DAUGHTER IS DEPRESSED AT
HOME AND HE'S STILL ACTIVE AND
DOING DOING UKULELE AND THEY'LL
DANCE CLASSES. AND SHE STILL
HAS PROBLEMS WITH DEPRESSION
BUT CAN ONLY IMAGINE OTHER
CHILDREN THAT DON'T HAVE. THE
RENTAL SUPPORT AT HOME AND WHAT
THESE THANK YOU GOING TO RIGHT
NOW SO THANK. YOU THANK YOU
YOUR COMMENTS ARE WELL TAKEN
AND I UNDERSTAND WHERE YOU'RE
COMING FROM I DO UNDERSTAND
THAT. THANK YOU. WELL I NUMBER
ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY THREE ONE
FIVE THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
RIGHT BACK. GOOD AFTERNOON AND
THANKS FOR TAKING MY COMMENT MY
NAME IS HEIR CHOICE I AM A
PARENT OF A COP COMING
KINDERGARTENERS I'M A SPECIAL
EDUCATION TEACHER I'M A SCHOOL
BOARD MEMBER IN OCEANSIDE
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT- FIRST
OF ALL I WANT TO SAY BUT I
REALLY LIKE. THE COMMITTEE TO
CONSIDER INTERNET AND WIFI
ACCESS GUARANTEED. TO ALL
STUDENTS ESPECIALLY STUDENTS ON
FREE AND REDUCED LUNCH. AND TO
CONSIDER LEGISLATIVE ACTION TO
DO SO A PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIP DOES NOT MEET THE
NEEDS OF OUR STUDENTS AND WILL
ALWAYS LACK OF FOLLOW THROUGH
THAT THAT WE THAT OUR STUDENTS
THAT SO WE ASK FOR MORE CLEAR
MANDATE. ON COASTAL PROTECTION
THAN MONEY TO MAKE IT A REALITY
BECAUSE IN GUIDANCE IS NOT
CLEAR THE MANDATORY OR
MANDATORY FOR DISTRICTS SERVING
OUR UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES.
THEY'RE THE ONES THAT SUFFER
AND THE WEALTHY DISTRICTS WILL
FORCE THE GAP WILL WIDEN WILL
LOOK BACK AND WONDER HOW DO WE
NOT REALIZE THAT THIS IS GOING
TO HAPPEN THANK YOU AGAIN.
THANK YOU TO OUR NEXT CALLER.
CALLERS ONE NUMBER TWENTY ONE
TO ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I AM
ASKING NEWMAN APPARENTLY SCHOOL
BOARD MEMBER OUR STUDENTS NEED
ALL SPORTS AND ALL ACTIVITIES
WITH LIMITED RESTRICTIONS AS A
PARENT YOU TEAM I AM FAR MORE
CONCERNED ABOUT OUR CALIFORNIA
STUDENT. BUT THEY'RE BEING PUT
THROUGH UNNECESSARY TRAUMA LIKE
SUICIDE ABUSE ADDICTION AND THE
QUESTION WHICH IS ALL
SKYROCKETED DUE TO THE SHUTDOWN
WITHOUT BASED ON SCIENCE.
FARMER CHILDREN HAVE DIED I
DIED EACH ONE AND ONE AND
NOTHING WAS DONE TO PROTECT OUR
KIDS THEN HOPE IT ISN'T NEARLY
AS DEADLY FOR CHILDREN NOW. WHY
CALIFORNIA DEPOSING UNNECESSARY
RESTRICTIVE GUIDELINES ON KIDS
WHEN CALIFORNIA LEADERSHIP
FAILED OR IGNORED. SOCIAL
DISTANCING IN PRISON.
CALIFORNIA REALLY CHILD THAT
ABUSERS DUE TO KOBE BUT PUT OUR
CHILDREN ON HEALTHCARE ASK OUR
GOVERNOR IS ALLOWED TO FORCE TO
THE PATIENT INTO UNINFECTED
NURSING HOMES. THAT WOULD KILL
FAR MORE I DO TOO CODED IN OUR
SCHOOL KIDS WELL THEY
ABSOLUTELY NEED ALL THEIR
ACTIVITIES BACK WITH LIMITED
RESTRAINT. AND IF WE DIDN'T DO
THAT. THANK YOU TO OUR NEXT
CALLER. COLOURS LINE ONE
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY FIVE ONE
EIGHT FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON. I WOULD LIKE
SOMEBODY TO TRANSLATE FOR ME
BECAUSE I'M GOING TO SPEAK
SPANISH MY NAME IS GOT THE MESA
TO IMPART A LEAN AND INTUITIVE
THE LITTLE DOCUMENT. IF THE I
KEEP UP A GLOVE BUT AS AN
INCLUDE OPEN OF THIS IS YOUR
LAST GAP IT DONE IN A TO Z.
CALLS IN A LITTLE BIT OF BY THE
THING I DON'T KNOW MESA AND I'M
IT'S NOT MAY IT MAY LEAD TO
TOTAL THANK GOODNESS THAT MA'AM
BUT UP AND IT LOOKS A LITTLE
FAMILIES THAT'S AND WILL A LOT
YEAH MEMBERS GET THEM PERCENT
THAT CAN LAND. ELECTRONICA TO
SOMEONE MONDAY NOT ON THE TIME
OF BE IN THE LOOKING HARD DISK
AT A MONTH ON A TWO IT IT
ALMOST GAVE GONNA MIGHT
WHENEVER GOT ON THE THAT COULD
NOT BE A. I WAS NOT A MAJOR.
FOCUS OF GREAT THAT THEY DID
WITH ME. THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO WORK ON THAT FOR YOU
TODAY AT THE END OF THE THIRTY
I HAVE AN INDIVIDUAL EDUCATION
PROGRAM IEP. FOR THE DEATH OF
MUSICAL IN THE CLASS. UP
WORKING OUT OF THE LAST SECTION
MEASURES BERKELEY. NOT A
FOOTBALL FIELD OFF THE YOU
CHECK IN THE LOCKER AT THIS. A
LOT OF FEATURES THAT ALLOW DAY
BOTH. YOU KNOW AND THANK YOU AN
ACTIVE THAT. YEAH I KNOW ABOUT
THIS I WORRY A MICHAEL THIS IS
A FACILITIES I COULD GET YOUR
AND BARB MAKE VERY DIFFICULT
FOR ME I WORRY ABOUT THE IS
WHAT BOB HI AND WALKED OVER HI
BILL. RIGHT I THINK I OF BACK
WHEN I. OUT HAVE TO CATCH UP
AND THE STANDARDS OF THE A HIGH
STUDENT HOUSE AND PUBLIC OUGHT
TO THE AND A FUTURE. EXPECT
RECOMMENDED BY TAKING THAT
CONCERN IF YOU COULD. BUT IF WE
AND I'LL THINK BUT IT THE
SCHOOLS THANK YOU THANK. TURNER
SCHOLAR. BUT A ONE WAY HUNDRED
AND FIFTY SO ONE FIVE OR ONE
OPEN. THAT AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
A ONE AND I AM A PATH FOR. AND
CORRECT MEMBER OF THE CAL.
EDUCATE PETER IF SAID. I AM
HERE TO ADVOCATE THE STUDENT
NOT CONTINUE CHECK ACCESS THE
ART. MY THEATER EXPERIENCE
INCLUSION AND EXPLORE
COMPRESSION WHAT COULD BE MORE
IMPORTANT AT THIS TIME WHAT
EVER FORM LEARNING IS
DELIBERATE THIS FALL DURING
ONLINE LEARNING MY TITLE ONE
HIGH SCHOOL SHAKESPEARE CLASS.
HAD A 90% ATTENDANCE RATE AS
STUDENTS RANGED FROM SPECIAL
EDUCATION TO ADVANCE PLACEMENT.
EXCAVATING THE WORLD TO
SHAKESPEARE AND COMPARING THEM
TO OUR PRESENT DAY ALLOWED FOR
KEY DISCOVERY DISCUSSION AND
PERFORMANCE WHAT SUCCESSFUL
VIRTUALLY DEFY YOU LEARNING
WHETHER IN PERSON OR ONLINE.
ALL OF THE ART THEATRE DANCE
MUSIC AND VISUAL ART BY
CONTINUE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER. WHAT DO I NUMBER
TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTEEN TWO
ONE EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
I'M PROCEED WITH EDUCATE
ADVOCATE WITH THEIR FAMILY THE
SPECIAL NEEDS KIDS. I'M CALLING
INDEPENDENT PUBLIC COMMENT. CUT
OUT BY LEGISLATION ADVOCATE
BEFORE HER MINUTE PUBLIC
COMMENT WITH THAT. THAT CD AND
CD PH BRIAN INDICATED STUDENT
WITH RESPIRATORY ILLNESS AND
THREE DISORDERS MOVEMENT
DISORDERS ANXIETY DISORDERS
COMMUNICATION LIMITATIONS AND
BEHAVIORAL DISORDERS WILL BE
MANDATED TO DIFFERENT LEARNING
THAT THEY ARE UNABLE TO COMPLY
WITH VISIBLE DOES TO THE INMATE
MASKING REQUIREMENTS. THE
EIGHTY A AN IDE A REQUIRE
STUDENTS BASED ON THEIR UNIQUE
NEEDS. REASONABLE
ACCOMMODATIONS MODIFICATION TO
ENSURE ACCURACY THE LEAST
RESTRICTIVE ENVIRONMENT OUR
LEGAL REQUIREMENTS NOT OPTIONS.
WITHOUT EXTENSIVE DISCUSSION
COMMUNICATE ON THE TOPIC DOWN
TO BE LEFT TO FILE DUE PROCESS
AGAINST DISTRICTS FURTHER
DEPLETING ALREADY ABYSMAL
FISCAL LANDSCAPER STATE
EDUCATION. I AM FOR OUR
EDUCATIONAL LEADERS TO PROVIDE
CLEAR GUIDANCE FOR STUDENTS
WITH DISABILITIES AND TO INVITE
DISABILITY RIGHTS ADVOCATES TO
THE TABLE WHEN DISCUSSING HOW
COOL RE OPENING IMPACTED WITH
EXCEPTIONAL NEEDS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. OUR NEXT CALLER.
NEXT FROM ONE OF TWO AND NINE
TWO ZERO NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
IN TWO HUNDRED AND NINETY. ONE
FOR E I. HELLO OUR THIS IS
JOANNA HEDRICK I AM A PARENT OF.
A TEN YEAR OLD AND SEVEN YEAR
OLD ATTENDING A PRIVATE
MONTESSORI SCHOOL IN
SACRAMENTO- MAY FOCUS ON
COMMUNITY TEACHING CHILDREN
HAVE A TINY AND FRIEDMAN TOLD I
DO NOT SUPPORT TEACHING
CHILDREN. TO FEAR THEIR FRIENDS
CLASSMATES AND TEACHERS AND
QUESTION THEIR OWN BODY'S
ABILITY TO FIGHT OFF TO THE
VET. DO NOT THE COURT HAVING
KIDS BACK TO SCHOOL WHERE YOU
NOT. OR MAYBE TEMPERATURE CAT.
I DO NOT OUT OF SUPPORT.
MANDATED VACCINES FOR THAT
LACKEY MANUFACTURE OUR
LIABILITY FREE. THEY ALREADY
HAVE LIABILITY FREE VACCINES
ANY NEW VACCINE WILL BE
LIABILITY FOR YOU AND I WILL BE
TAKING MY TAX DOLLARS IN MY
VOTE TO TAXES MOVING OUT OF
CALIFORNIA. NEXT CALLER. NEXT
CALLER'S FROM LINE TWO HUNDRED
AND THIRTY ONE TWO THREE ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY.
NAME IS ANNE I WON AND I'M A
PARENT OF AN INCOMING
KINDERGARTEN A WITH SPECIAL
NEEDS ORANGE COUNTY. I HAVE
CONCERNS REGARDING FACIAL
COVERINGS BEING A REQUIREMENT
WHEN SCHOOL RE OPENED IN THE
FALL WE CAN ALL AGREE THAT
CHILDREN ARE NOT A HIGH RISK
FOR DEVELOPING COMPLICATIONS
FROM CALLED NINETEEN DUE TO THE
VERY LOW INCIDENCE RATE IN THE
STATE AND COUNTRY IN CHILDREN
UNDER EIGHTEEN. AS A RESULT WE
SHOULD REALLY FOCUS OUR EFFORTS
ON PROTECTING THE ADULT SCHOOL
ENVIRONMENT. I DID JUST THAT IN
PLACE OF WEARING MASKS WHICH
ARE DIFFICULT TO BREATHE IN AND
DO NOT SHOW FACIAL EXPRESSION
AND SAID. YOU'RE NOT BACK
SHOULD BE INVITED TO WORK THE
SHIELDS WHICH ARE CLEAR COST
EFFECTIVE EASY TO CLEAN
COMFORTABLE TO WEAR AND EASY TO
BREED THAT. CHILDREN
COMMENTATOR TEACHER SMILING
FACES THOSE WITH SPECIAL NEEDS
AND DIFFICULTY HEARING CAN READ
LIPS AND FACIAL EXPRESSION AND
FEATURES VOICES WILL NOT BE
MICHAEL DURING LAST THAT.
MASTER DETRIMENTAL TO
CHILDREN'S EMOTIONAL AND ABOUT
MENTAL HEALTH AND WELL BEING
AND SHOULD NOT BE A REQUIREMENT
FOR SCHOOL RE ENTRY. BUT THE
CHILDREN THEY BUILD
RELATIONSHIPS AND EACH OTHER'S
FACIAL EXPRESSIONS AND I'M OFF
SCHOOL ENVIRONMENT THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU I
BELIEVE FACIALS OUR LEAST AN
OPTION I BELIEVE. IN THE
GUIDANCE OUR CALLER. IS LINE.
THIRTY THREE TWO THREE THREE
LINE ITSELF. THANK YOU NAME IS
OF BERKELEY I AM ESPECIALLY
CATION TEACHER IN ROCKLAND. I
WOULD LIKE TO ECHO WHAT MANY
FOLKS OF ARE YOU SAID ABOUT THE
MATCH THE PREVIOUS CALLER WITH
HER SUGGESTION FROM THE SHIELDS
WITH MUCH MUCH BETTER. I'M
THERE NEEDS TO BE A REALLY GOOD
STUDY DONE BY THE BOARD OF
EDUCATION IF NOW ARE TO BE
IMPLEMENTED THERE ARE TOO MANY
QUESTIONS THAT HAVE TO BE
ANSWERED TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT
PROPERLY CHILDREN OF A HIGHER
RESOLUTION RATE THAN ADULTS THE
MASTER GOING TO BE SATURATED
AFTER TWENTY MINUTES SWITCHING
THEY HAVE TO BE CHANGED EVERY
TWENTY MINUTES WHO'S GOING TO
DO WHO'S GOING TO PAY FOR IT
HOW ARE YOU GOING TO PREVENT
CHILDREN FROM BEING THE BASQUE
PHONE. ONE WHAT CAN. I DROPPING.
ALSO IT'S REALLY A PART TO BOND.
WHEN YOUR TEACHER THE STUDENT
FOR WEARING A MASK SO AGAIN I
STRONG ENCOURAGE MUCH INTO
STUDY AND FROM VERY GOOD
GUIDELINES TO BE AND BEFORE
ANYBODY. BUT NOT ARE GOING TO
BE REQUIRED THANK YOU. THANK.
BUT A LINE TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FIVE TWO THREE FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN MEANING THAT THEY
THINK TACTICALLY OUT AND- COACH
HAPPENS RECTOR FOR CALIFORNIA
THEY HAVE BEEN WHICH IS
EFFECTIVELY OF EDUCATIONAL BEER
SUFFICIENT. THEATER IF I NEED
FOR THE MOST COLLABORATIVE OF
SUBJECT AREA IT'S NOT JUST TO
TEACH. ARE YOU A LOT OF THE ART
AND TO CREATE FUTURE APPEAR
PRACTITIONER MEDICALLY PROJECT
MANAGERS LEADERS INNOVATORS
CREATORS AND PEOPLE PASSIONATE
THE MUNICH BUT THAT. FORMULA
WE'RE LOOKING AT DOING NOTHING
GIVEN ACCESS TO THE ARTS
CURRICULUM THE THING RESULT ARE
SO THAT THAT SO MANY PEOPLE
RELIED ON DURING AT HOME OR
INNOVATION AND CREATIVITY
EDUCATION AND ENTERTAINMENT T
IS SO IMPORTANT FOR OUR
STUDENTS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. Q. TURNING CALLER. LITTLE
AYE NUMBER TWO AND THIRTY SEVEN
THREE SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS LEE AND I AM A
FORMER EDUCATOR DIRECTOR OF A
CHILDREN'S PROGRAM. BOARD
MEMBER INCOHERENT. I AM CALLING
TODAY TO ENCOURAGE THE STATE TO
REEVALUATE THE GUIDANCE AND
GUIDELINES THAT THEY HAVE TO
WORK. PERSONALLY AFFECT OUR
MOST AFFORDABLE POPULATION AND-
WHITE IN THE AN EQUITABLE- GAP
IN THEIR EDUCATION. I AM ALSO
ENCOURAGING ALL SCHOOL THREE
OPEN FULLY WITH SPORTS CIRCULAR
ACTIVITIES THAT ARE NECESSARY
TO THE WHOLE DEVELOPMENT OF OUR
CHILD INCLUDING THEIR SOCIO.
ELEMENTS AS WELL AS THEIR AT AT
AT DEVELOPMENT OF THEIR
EDUCATION- I ENCOURAGE SCHOOLS
TO REOPEN WITH NO RESTRICTIONS
SUCH AS MATH SOCIAL DISTANCING.
WE CURRENTLY KNOW TRUTH STUDIES
THAT THIS VIRUS CALLED WITHIN
OF MORTALITY RANGE OF INFLUENCE
THAT THAT IT AFFECTS LESS THAN
1% OF THE CHILDREN. AT IN OUR
POPULATION AND ACCORDING TO THE
CDC THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION THERE HAVE BEEN NO
DOCUMENTED IF THE MEN EIGHT
MATIC TRANSMISSION OF THE VIRUS.
RIGHT NOW THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION HAS
STATED THAT OVER 65% OF OUR
CHILDREN ARE EXPERIENCING
DEPRESSION ANXIETY. THAT IS
LEADING TO FEELINGS OF
ISOLATION COMING BACK WITH
THOSE OF THE IN THING
GUIDELINES AS WELL AS MATHIS
ONLY GOING TO INCREASE THAT.
AND WITH THE WITH RIDE BEING
THAT THE NEW SECOND LEADING
CAUSE OF DEATH IN THE
POPULATION. HEALTH CONCERN THAT
WE NEED TO TAKE A LOOK AT. WE
ALSO NEED TO ADD SOMEBODY
MENTIONED LOOK AT THE REST. OF
MOUNT IN THE ROOF OF LAWSUIT
FOR ANY DISTRICT THAT.
IMPLEMENT THESE MEASURES. IF WE
ARE IN FORCING CHILDREN TO OUR
MAP THAT BREED BACTERIA BECOME
WAYS RESTRICT EVERYWHERE. AS
WE'VE SEEN IN COUNTRIES SUCH AS
CHINA HOLD. THEIR BEEN
DETRIMENTAL HELP INCREASE WITH
SUCH AS THE PRESS IS ENOUGH AND
EVEN DEATH. THANK YOU POINT
THANK YOU FOR. I JUST JUST TO
NOTE I'M LOOKING ON OUR AN
ARTICLE HERE THAT JUST CAME OUT
THAT SAID BEIJING. HAS SHOT
THEIR SCHOOL SYSTEM THE VIRUSES
CASES HAVE I ASSUME RE SPREAD.
SO THAT'S WHY WE'RE IN THIS
HEARING TO MAKE SURE WE DO IT
RIGHT TO OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
WELL I NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FIVE TWO TWO FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME TODAY MY NAME IS
MEGHAN STANTON TRAY HAND AND I
AM. DIRECTOR OF THE YOUTH
JUSTICE LEGISLATION CLINIC AT
LOYOLA LAW SCHOOL AND I'M HERE
SPEAKING- IN SUPPORT OF THE
EQUITY COALITION AS WELL AS- IN
AGREEMENT WITH THE- LETTER THAT
PUBLIC COMMENT WATER SUBMITTED
BY ON THE NATIONAL MORE FOR YOU
BOB- AND I JUST WANTED TO TAKE
A MINUTE TO- EMPHASIZED THE
IMPORTANCE. OF PROTECTING I
NEED STUDENTS- PARTICULARLY
THOSE THAT WE NOW.ARE MOST AT
RISK WHEN STANDARDS ARE- OUR
FLEX MADE FLEXIBLE OR YOU KNOW.
THINGS SUCH AS INSTRUCTIONAL
MINUTES MAYBE COM- YOU KNOW.
LESS LET'S REJECT THE I MEAN I
WE ALL UNDERSTAND THAT WE'RE
GOING THROUGH A DIFFICULT TIME
RIGHT NOW BUT I'D LIKE TO URGE
YOU TO THINK ABOUT MY CLIENTS-
AND OTHER HIGH NEED STUDENTS
WHEN YOU'RE MAKING SESSION SO.
FOR EXAMPLE. HE'S A SPECIAL
EDUCATION JUVENILE JUSTICE
INVOLVED FOSTER YOUTH STUDENT.
HE HAS NOT HAD MEANINGFUL ACT
AT THE LEARNING DURING THE
COVERED NINETEEN PANDEMIC
FORECLOSURES BECAUSE IT TOOK
HIM THREE MONTHS TO GET A
COMPUTER- THE SCHOOL AND THE
PARENTS WERE TRYING TO GET THAT
TO HAPPEN BUT IT JUST. DIDN'T
BECAUSE VARIETY OF REASONS
THANK YOU SO. THAT ACT. TO OUR
NEXT CALL. LITTLE AYE NUMBER
TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY TWO TO
FOUR TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
THERE I'M KAREN A HIGH SCHOOLER
AND LIVE IN PALO ALTO WHICH
UNFORTUNATELY ALONG WITH THE
WHOLE OF SANTA CLARA COUNTY HAS
THE HIGHEST RATE OF SUICIDE IN
CALIFORNIA FORMULA AMONG TEEN.
DEPRESSION MENTAL HEALTH ISSUE.
WITH A VERY REAL LOOKING AND
HAVE INCREASED DRAMATICALLY
DURING HAS BEEN. SEEN NEED
SCHOOL AND A FRIEND TO TRY AND
KEEP THEIR MENTAL HEALTH
STABLE. FIFTY GUIDELINES
OUTLINED MEASURES THAT MAY WHAT
FOR K. THROUGH EIGHT BUT DO NOT
ADDRESS HOW HIGH SCHOOL COULD.
COULD OPERATE. THERE IS A NOT
VERY ANOTHER STUDENT IN MY
DAUGHTER'S SCHOOL HE TAKES
EXACT SCHEDULE ACOSTA OR EVEN
THE SAME CLASSES DUE TO HER
ELECTED. THERE IS NO
POSSIBILITY OF COLLEGE BECAUSE
SHE MOVED FROM CLASSROOM TO
CLASSROOM. ACTUAL DIFFERENT
THING IT'S GOING TO TAKE AT
LEAST OUR TO GET FROM PAUL FROM
TO CLASSROOM WHEN THERE ARE
THOUSANDS OF STUDENTS. I
UNDERSTAND THAT SOME OF THE CDC
GUIDELINES ON CD PH GUIDELINES
MAY WHAT AND I SAY MAY BECAUSE
I DON'T EVEN THINK PAUL WHAT
FOR THE CAKE- EIGHT CLASSROOMS
BUT I REALLY DON'T UNDERSTAND
HOW HIGH SCHOOL ARE THEY GOING
TO EXPECT TO GET BACK INTO-SCHOOL. DO THERE AP CLASSES YOU
THERE ON A FULL. PARTICIPATE IN
FORT BUT THAT THEY CAN'T GET
INTO THE COLLEGES BUT THEY WANT
TO GET INTO I THINK THERE IT
NEEDS TO BE MUCH MORE FOCUSED
ON OUR HIGH SCHOOLERS AS WELL
AS EVERY OTHER AGE BUT OUR HIGH
SCHOOL IS REALLY MEAN THE
ATTENTION. OKAY THEY ARE OKAY
PERFECT. THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
I JUST WANNA COMMON ON ALLOWS
CALLERS COMMENTS BECAUSE SHE IS
CORRECT THAT WE DO NEED TO
FOCUS ON HIGH SCHOOLS WELL. MY
BACKGROUND IS OUT OF A MIDDLE
AND HIGH SCHOOL TEACHER AND
I'VE BEEN PRETTY FERVENT WITH
REGARD TO THE HIGH SCHOOL.
DYNAMIC BECAUSE A LOT OF PEOPLE
DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT THE-
CREDIT NO CREDIT YOU MAY BE IN
THE LONG TERM HARMONY STUDENTS
WHO WANT A HIGH GPA TO GET INTO
A TO IT. TO A TOP NOTCH SCHOOL.
YEAH YOUR- IS. ACTUALLY LET.
RAZOR G. WE HAD LONGER WHERE I
COME. POP BUT I'M WATCHING
SCHOOL SIT. IN A- IF AND THEN
CAN. TO MAKE SURE WE DO PAY
THAT I AS WANTING TO GO ON TO
HIGHER EDUCATION AND THEN BEING
LIMITED BECAUSE OF SOME OF THE
THINGS WE'VE DONE IN CALIFORNIA
SO I CAN ASSURE YOU I CONTINUE
TO MONITOR THAT AND WE HAVE
DONE SOME THINGS THAT I THINK
ARE POSITIVE. TO ADDRESS THOSE
ISSUES MAY THERE BE MORE YES
SIR MAY BUT WITH THAT LET'S GO
TO OUR NEXT CALLER. THANK YOU.
WE'LL GO TO LINE NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY THREE TO FOUR
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
CAN YOU HEAR ME. GOOD GOOD
BLESSING. OKAY THANK YOU. IN
MANY HELLO BUT I'M A VERY
CONCERNED PAN OUT IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA I HAVE A COUPLE
CHILDREN THAT ARE IN THE SYSTEM
AND I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW WHAT
HAPPENED TO MY BODY MY CHOICE.
WHO IS GOING TO BE TAKING CARE
OF THESE KIDS. PUTTING LINE.
WHEN THEY GET SICK OR THEIR
BRAIN START GETTING DAMAGE FROM
THESE FACE COVERINGS THAT ARE
GOING TO BE MANDATORY. FOR THEM
TO GO TO SCHOOL ALSO DIFFERENT
THAT THE- DEFENDANT NOT OKAY.
FOR THEM DESERVE NOT OKAY
THAT'S TO ASIDE RATE HAS GONE.
GRAPHICALLY HIGH AND NOBODY'S
TALKING ABOUT THAT WERE OKAY
WITH. DOING A PROTEST FOR
PEOPLE A HUNDRED. OUR LAST BUT
THE KIDS CAN BE IN A CLASSROOM
THIRTY CAN. I CAN'T PLAY WITH
EACH OTHER WHO'S GOING TO BE
TAKING CARE OF THEM I WANT TO
KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON WITH MY
BODY MY CHOICE OR DOES THAT
ONLY APPLY TO ABORTION. AND
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN WITH OUR
TAX DOLLARS FOR THOSE WHO ARE
NOT GOING TO BE PUTTING OUR
KIDS BACK IN THE SCHOOL SYSTEM
WOULD BE RIDICULOUS
REQUIREMENTS. I WANT TO KNOW
HOW ARE LEGALLY ABLE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SHARING.
NEXT CALLER. WELL THE LINE
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
EIGHT ONE THREE EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI GOOD AFTERNOON I'M
A CONCERNED PARENT- FIRST LOW
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU OUR PHONE CALLS IF YOU'RE
NOT PLEASE THIS PARENT. ALSO
PICTURING HOW RUDY GUYS ARE WE
CUTTING OUT THERE AND OTHER
SPECIAL. CONCERN ABOUT OUR
CHILDREN YOU'RE THE ONES I'VE
BEEN IN. ALL CONCERN BECAUSE
WHEN THEY GO TO SCHOOL OTHER
THAN AT THE PEOPLE HELPING THEM
OUT BECAUSE TO BE SCARED BE
NEAR WITH IT'S GOING TO BE CABS.
FOR AND HOW PEOPLE. WHICH WILL
ALSO EXPRESSED MY CONCERNS. YOU
KNOW THAT SO LIVES AND TING
WERE YOU DO WITH. IN OUR PLAY
TIME. AND THAT LUNCH. AND ALL
OF THAT ON THE RESOURCE THEY
USED TO HAVE AND THEN WAS GOING
TO GO THE EXTRA MONEY THAT
WE'RE NOT GOING TO USE OF I
DON'T HAPPEN LOCAL AFTER SCHOOL.
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN LINK
WHAT IS IT THAT GO I KNOW YOU
HAVE A WILL SCHOOLS PARTS YOU
ONE OF. GO AHEAD ABOUT A DAY
THIS. WELL I HAVING OPAL FOR A
CALL AND ALSO BANKS NEED TO AT
IT FOR TO HAVE THAT I DON'T
THINK IT'S RIGHT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU YEAH ONE WAS THANK
YOU AND JUST TO BE. WE CENTER
THE BEGINNING THEY BE MINUTE UP
PUBLIC. SOME HER. TELLING
PUBLIC COMMENT SO I OF THOSE OF
SO HERE TO LIVE TO THE PUBLIC
WITH BELIEVE ESSENTIAL TAKE A
COMMENTS SO THAT'S WE'RE DOING.
SO WITH THAT OUR TO OUR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. YES AT THAT THAT
WE'VE TO THE OF OUR Q. AT THIS
TIME. THAT IS IT OKAY THANK YOU
TO OUR MY- TH YOU TO ALL OUR
PRISON A LOT OF INFORMATION
STILL ALL. OF CAN. WE'RE NOW
HEADING IN. A QUOTE UNQUOTE
RAKE YEAR I THINK WE- THAT
THROUGH THIS HEARING. AND WE
NEED TO BE READY TO BE. VERY
FLUID NEXT YEAR- AS AS WE AS WE
YOU KNOW. AS AS WE HEAD INTO
THE NEW SCHOOL YEAR- AGAIN MORE
WORK TO BE DONE I THINK IT'S
WORK WE DON'T YOU KNOW WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO DO. SO AN
INTERESTING YEAR BEHIND US AN
INTERESTING YEAR AHEAD OF US. I
THANK ALL OF YOU COMMITTEE
MEMBERS HERE PARTICIPATION
THOSE WHO PRESENTED. THOSE
LISTEN THOSE WHO WATCHED- THOSE
WHO CALLED IN. AND CERTAINLY A
TONYA LEE RAN IN THE OTHER
STAFF WHO HELPED PUT THIS
TOGETHER TODAY. AND THANK YOU
ALL FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION
THANK YOU. THIS MEETING IS
ADJOURNED.